Hello, everybody.
Hello, welcome back to the Elo Minds.
The Marvel Rival Minds.
As we try again to get to one above all.
As we go again.
Oh my god.
Can today be the day where we're finally free?
You guys can finally go home after camping here for so long.
Is it just today that day?
I didn't make my gamer subs yet.
I should actually.
Let me get the...
I should.
I think it's like tradition.
My body has like pavloved itself in a way where like...
I have to like get the gamer subs in me to be locked in.
Before the grind.
Oh my god.
Anyway, give me a sec.
Let me make my gamer subs real quick.
Before I go back to this hellhole.
Oh my god.
Alright, story time.
It's not much of a story.
It's more like confessions of an alcoholic.
And by alcoholic, I mean confessions of a grinder.
So, for those who don't follow...
Oops, sorry, that's my bottle of water.
So, I'm not an alcoholic by the way.
I'm not an alcoholic.
I'm something much more worse.
I have terminal Marvel Rivals brain rot.
And I feel like that might be a bit more worse than being an alcoholic.
Anyway, so, if you don't follow me on Twitter, there is a tracker site that basically tracks if you're like top 10 of whatever on Twitch.
And apparently today, I found out that I was the top 10 female streamer on Twitch during the weekend.
And that was... I should be very proud of that.
But, that weekend, all I did was just play Marvel Rivals.
That's all I did.
And it wasn't like I streamed on Twitch for three days.
I streamed on Twitch for like two of those three days.
And the thing is...
Because I streamed on...
Wait, no, it was for two days.
No, the thing is, because I streamed on Twitch for two of those three days...
I still somehow got on the leaderboards for that.
Because all I really did was just stream Marvel Rivals.
So, I just got publicly exposed to the world of my crippling addiction to this game.
Oh, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, PTD.
Thank you for the 300 bits.
Thank you, thank you.
We're back in the mines, baby.
I got publicly shamed to the world of my crippling addiction to Marvel Rivals.
I should be so happy.
I mean, I am.
I am happy about the accomplishment.
But also, it's a little sad.
Just a little bit.
It's just...
So, here's the chart.
And like, I don't even go there, too.
That's the thing.
That's the other worst part.
It's like...
I don't...
Twitch is not my primary platform.
I literally have like one-eighth of my following count on Twitch.
So, like...
The fact that I made it to top 10, even though it's like one-eighth of my following count...
And it's just Marvel Rivals.
I don't know how I feel.
Oh, my God.
I'm proud, but yet I'm also like...
I should get help.
It's okay.
In three days, it's all gonna be over.
They don't know I'm from YouTube.
Yeah, exactly.
I was like...
I'm like, I'm on YouTube and yet somehow I was able to accomplish that.
Just because I have a problem.
Oh, my gosh.
This...
Is this bottle broken?
Oh, I might need to throw this bottle away.
It's leaking.
Oh, my God.
When I was trying to shake it, it's leaking.
So, I might have to throw this bottle...
Oh, I didn't...
Oh, I'm dumb.
I just didn't...
I didn't fucking...
I didn't close it properly.
No!
Anyway, I got Gamersup's drink on my fucking desk.
Now, I'm like cleaning it up.
I like twisted it a little bit.
I was like...
Oh, I didn't fully twist it.
Oh, man.
Did I break it?
No, I just didn't fully twist it.
Anyway...
So, that's like...
Confessions of a Marvel Rivals grinder today.
Oh, thank you for the 10!
Get the sauce!
Thank you!
Other than that...
What other life update...
I mean, not much happened.
Other than...
Oh, yeah!
Funny story.
So, apparently...
So, I have a spy.
Well, I don't want to say a spy.
But like...
I have a friend...
That's like...
Within the Marvel Rivals pro scene.
And I've been like...
Following Marvel Rivals players.
Like...
Because I...
I don't know.
It seems like an incredibly difficult concept for people to understand.
But like...
So, like...
I've been following like...
A bunch of Marvel Rivals players.
Because I genuinely enjoy watching really good gameplay of Marvel Rivals.
Like, I genuinely enjoy that.
So, like...
Ever since the Overwatch days...
I just like watching streamers who are really good at their game.
So, like...
I do that for like Apex.
I do that for Overwatch.
And I'm doing that right now for Marvel Rivals.
But the thing is...
Since it's still like a new game...
The pro scene is like quite new in Marvel Rivals.
But I can tell who's like a really good player.
Like, you know...
They're like in the tournaments and stuff like that.
So, I've been following their streams and stuff.
But they also have like a very low following count.
So, they can see like me following them.
And they freak out about it.
So, like...
One of my friends who's like within the scene was telling me about it.
And was like...
Wait, you follow this person?
You follow these people?
And I was like...
Yeah, how did you know?
And they're like...
Yeah, because they're freaking out.
Because I was like...
I was like...
Why?
They're really good at their game.
I just...
I genuinely just enjoy like watching good gameplay.
Because I learn from it.
Like, it doesn't matter if they don't play support.
If they play a DPS player or a tank player.
It helps me improve my game.
Because I learn from how they're playing.
And how like a certain DPS player...
Like the position and like what their thoughts are.
Because it improves my game knowledge.
Seeing what they're doing.
So, I've been following a bunch of like Marble Rivals like pro players.
And like apparently some of them are freaking out.
Because they're like...
Oh my god, did you hear JokeyBird follow me?
I don't know why she would follow me.
Like...
They're like...
She's so big.
Like she said she's so big.
Like she's so famous.
Like I don't get why...
I genuinely just enjoy...
I don't understand.
I just like watching good gameplay.
Like...
I said...
I like to play Marble Rivals.
And I like to watch good gameplay.
So...
I thought that was...
I thought that was really funny.
So like...
They're like...
Oh my god, you see her following Kat?
Like oh my god, why does she follow me?
And I'm like...
I don't know why freaking...
I just like watching people be good at what they do.
Like...
And so yeah...
Yeah, that's basically...
Basically that was like silly update in life.
I thought it was really cute.
I was like...
Oh man, that's so silly.
Hey guys!
Before we begin...
We...
Um...
I finally got a four stack for the...
Well, I didn't get the four stack.
Mace got the four stack.
Because I was telling Mace...
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna have to...
We have literally like...
Um...
We have three days left.
And I was like...
Don't start...
I was like...
Three days...
Three days to get 250 points.
I don't even know what 250 is.
It's a 200!
Okay.
So like...
Um...
So...
I don't even think 250 is the cut off.
198 is the...
Anyway...
I was literally like...
Um...
I don't think we're gonna make it, Mace.
I think I might have to throw in the towel.
Because the goal is getting further and further away.
And I...
And yesterday...
Oh my god.
Technically, it was yesterday.
Yesterday, we went...
We gained technically...
Technically 20 plus another 20.
Because I...
I'm sorry, guys.
I played two more...
I played a few more games off stream.
Because I really wanted to hit 100.
But like...
I didn't want you guys to yell at me at the moment.
But then like...
Um...
Uh...
Wait, Mace.
Give me a sec.
I'm still talking to my chat.
Give me like five more minutes.
And then...
And then so...
I went to play like a couple more games.
Until I hit 100 points.
Because I was like...
I'm not stopping until 100.
I...
I was just like...
I can't stop until 100.
So I played a couple more off stream.
And like...
I knew you guys would yell at me.
So I'd rather do it...
Ask for forgiveness.
I'd rather just ask for forgiveness now.
Than...
Than have you yell at me yesterday.
So...
Because now...
Now like...
It happened already.
It's too late.
You can't stop it anymore.
It's already happened.
So...
So I just...
I just wanted you guys to know that.
Because you might be like...
Why are you at 101 points?
You stopped at 88.
At one point I was at 60...
I was back at 66 yesterday.
But you guys didn't know that.
Because I'm now at 100.
Anyway...
So...
I told Mace that.
I was like...
Sorry buddy.
I don't think I'm gonna make it to the top 500.
So like...
GGs.
And then Mace was like...
We're getting you a four stack of like...
Pro players.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Wait.
I'm gonna get the VTuber Shroud treatment.
Even though I have like...
1 50th of his following count.
Oh my god.
I feel so...
Even though...
I'm like...
Oh my god.
My make a wish has finally happened.
My make a wish...
I get to be Shroud for the day guys.
I can't believe it.
I get to be Shroud.
I get to be Shroud for a day.
Oh my god.
I get to be Kayden.
I'm just mad.
Not make a wish.
Anyway.
So...
I did tell them.
I was like...
Please.
If...
If it is getting too hard.
We can stop.
At any...
You guys can stop.
I won't stop.
But like...
You guys can leave me.
Like...
You guys...
If it gets too frustrating.
You guys can leave me.
I won't stop.
But like...
I don't want you guys to suffer through this.
So...
Um...
Anyway.
So yeah.
Also like...
Um...
Yeah.
So yeah.
That's basically life update.
Alright Mace.
You can add me now.
Life update.
So we have...
I believe our stack is...
From what Mace told me.
It's Mace.
Ryamazing.
And...
Super Gomez.
Oh my god.
Whatever his name is.
I know like the ending was Gomez.
But like...
I mean...
I mean look.
I should have checked it out.
Yeah.
Super Gomez.
Okay.
I was gonna be like...
It's either...
Uh...
It was something S Gomez.
And I literally went...
Oh my god.
What if it's not Super?
Like...
What if it's not...
Anyway.
Uh...
Those...
That is our stack for today's grind session.
It's also why it's early today.
Because finally...
We got like players that wanted to play with me at a decent time.
It's...
Oh my god.
We finally did it.
We actually got like...
Players who are willing to play with me at...
Like...
At an actual NA hour.
Instead of waiting until like...
10 to 11 PM.
Where I get hit up and be like...
Aye.
Plan Z moment.
It's your time.
The booty call.
It's your time to hop in.
Cyberpunk.
Thank you.
She's not gonna be done in Season 1 because of the new Celeste.
Oh yeah.
I heard they're adding a new rank.
Um...
New Celestio rank for it.
But like...
Why would I aim for Celestio rank when I could just be like Eternity?
Oh.
Thank you for the...
Uh...
Bitties.
Thank you.
Anomalous.
Thank you for the gifting and sub.
Thank you.
Anyway guys.
Next season I won't be like as...
Um...
Terminally ill.
I don't know how else to explain it.
But...
What do you mean?
What?
When did I get so many messages?
When did they message me this?
Like...
What is...
W-Y-N?
Oh my god!
I got a message from Rosa!
What is W-Y-N?
What does W-Y-N mean?
Rosa message me.
When's your next...
The fuck does that mean?
What did she...
What you mean?
W-Y-N?
I don't know what that means.
What does W-Y-N mean?
Where are you now?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Rosa wanted to help out too!
That was our...
That was our ticket.
Yesterday.
Apparently, their team won.
Apparently, their team won the tournament, by the way.
So like...
Wait!
What's that?
That's Kurova!
Alright, nevermind.
I didn't mean Rymazing.
I mean Kurova.
I guess.
I guess it's not Rymazing.
It's Kurova.
Kurova is...
I know Kurova is an Atom player.
I've seen...
I've seen Kurova...
Play Atom really well.
Yeah.
Sorry, JK.
I lied.
It's not Rymazing.
It's Kurova.
And in the end, Doki successfully pushed Rosa.
I did it, guys.
But I didn't...
I was not a home record, chat.
I...
A good Atom!
I'll have you know, I won 100% my Atom games yesterday.
Guys, I...
Apparently, okay.
I was rewatching my Atom games.
Because I was like, how did I do that?
Like, how did...
How did I win all my Atom games?
Because I don't play Atom that much.
And then, like, apparently, people...
Some people actually thought my Atom was really good.
And there was, like, this one moment where I didn't even...
Like, legitimately, people thought I intentionally did it.
So, they thought I was, like, insane.
Like, I was a really good Atom player for that, doing that.
And, like, I was like, oh my gosh, she's so big-brained.
So, there was this one moment where the strange went up and tried to ult me and Mantis.
And then I pressed Q instantly.
And then, because my ult, basically, was an invincibility frame for the strange's ult.
So, then people were like, oh my god, she's so fucking smart for that.
Like, how did...
Like, that was insane.
And then, legitimately, when that happened, I thought I was...
So, like, reflexively, I pressed Q.
Because a Luna ult would cancel out the strange ult.
So, I didn't even know that would work.
It was legitimately, like, reflex from playing Luna so fucking much.
So, like, I didn't know the Atom ult is, like, an invincibility frame for the strange ult.
So, like, people were like, even I didn't know you could do that.
That's right, I didn't know either.
I didn't know either.
Like, I... we... none of us knew.
Like, you didn't know, I didn't know.
We learned a new tech.
I basically invented a new tech right there.
I got... it was all planned out.
The unintentional genius.
That's why I was like, oh.
I was like, oh, hey, it worked.
I was like, I don't know how, but it worked.
So, I literally didn't know that.
But now I do.
And now you guys do too.
And people were like, wow, I learned this new tech from Toki Bird.
I learned that new tech on the spot.
The Atom Toki tech.
It was totally planned.
But yeah, that's basically...
That's basically how it went.
I don't know how this session's gonna go.
Not gonna lie.
Because, like, legit...
I don't know.
Like I said, I...
I don't know how this is gonna go.
It could go anywhere.
We could end up getting sniped by four other people.
I don't know.
I feel like they're gonna see this.
They're gonna be like, oh man, it's time to farm Toki Bird.
And then some sick fuckers are gonna...
Oh man, I'm just gonna say it.
Now the pro players are watching this right now.
They're like, that's such a great idea, Toki.
Let me grab three other players right now and farm you.
So like, I don't know.
Anything could happen.
Four other pro players could fucking create their own four stack and just farm me.
So we'll see how they get her.
She doesn't even go here.
She's not even a fucking Twitch streamer.
Let us get her out.
Get her out of my category.
No skins?
I will spend money in this game when Marvel Rivals sponsor me.
Like, don't be it.
That will be the only way you'll see me use a skin.
What servers do I queue?
Oh my gosh, why are you asking me that question?
Alright Toki, give us the exact servers you queue.
And also like, show your queue time up top so we know when exactly you're gonna queue up.
And also, how many people are in your stack?
These are all just general streamer questions that we ask everybody.
I didn't warm up too.
I'm such an optimal role model for my stack.
I didn't warm up, I just woke up.
I woke up, guys, I need you to know I hibernated so fucking hard after the 16 hour stream.
Like, I kept waking up at random hours because my body is like, where are we?
My body is like, what time zones are we on anymore?
So like, I was waking up randomly on and off yesterday.
And then at around 3, I kept waking on and off until like 3 in the morning.
And then I grabbed something to eat because my body was like, alright, even though we don't know what time zones we are in, we know you're hungry.
So, because of that, and then after that, I went back to sleep.
After digesting, I went back to sleep.
And then after digest, I just fucking slept.
I just slept the entire time and I woke up at like 4pm today.
Oh my god, my fucking body.
I woke up at 4pm today.
So, let's hope everything will be okay.
Someone, oh yeah, I'm not modding my game because I feel like, I feel like modding.
Oh hey, Surefour is here.
Surefour, I swear to god, you picked Jeff.
I swear to fucking god.
I heard about his, I heard about his Jeff arc.
So like...
I heard about his, oh thank god, we have two supports already.
I heard about his flanking Jeff arc.
So...
Wait, I know what to play this game.
No, no, no you do not.
No, you do not.
I know what to play this game.
I know what, alright.
No, no, no, no, you do not know what you're playing this game.
Okay, I think we ban the group.
Oh, it would be awkward if it went to Black Widow.
No, everybody ban group, everybody ban group.
I'm a fan, so...
What the fuck?
No, what the fuck.
It's okay.
Okay, Jeff, come on.
Oh,
I'm so sad bro, why do we have four supports?
It will work, I bet it will work.
We're really crafting.
Alright, listen, wait, this is genius.
We have four supports, but like lowkey, we're like not even real supports.
Yeah, like yeah, your other two supports are basically DPS, so it's like, it's perfect.
Actually, the Jeff isn't that good on this map.
I trust her, Jeff.
If you ever die, it's Kuroba's fault, because he's supposed to be the number one Adam, and how is he not saving your life?
Alright, there we go, that's fine, that's fine, I got Black Widow off, it's fine.
Guys, he's not on Black Widow.
Guys, we have to ban him, make sure he doesn't play Black Widow.
There's a Wolverine behind you.
Wolverine low.
There's a Hulk.
Oh,
goodbye.
I'm backing off.
I don't think so, it's just me and the support.
Oh, I'm backing out.
Alright.
There's a Hulk in the center.
See, we didn't have to...
Look guys, see, we didn't have...
We didn't have to ban Groot, they didn't even play Groot.
Look at that.
They didn't even play Groot, so like, my ban would have meant nothing.
It would have meant nothing, guys.
Guys, see?
We saved...
We saved the game.
I slept somebody, I slept... Oh, he's dead anyway.
Yeah, yeah, I can rez too.
I'm gonna ult this.
I'm gonna push up.
I'm on Luna.
Kill Luna.
I killed Luna.
Oh, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Alright.
I'm fucking... I'm trying right now.
Nice.
Oh my god, I'm looking at the lowkey here.
Iron is still half.
Okay, I got you.
I'm gonna... Oh, we capped, okay.
It's fine!
It's so fine!
They have no lamp.
Guys, it's okay, we're just getting used to the chemistry.
We're getting used to this chemistry.
It's so healthy.
Got you.
Do they have Hulk ult?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
Hulk is one.
I damage boosted you, but I'm on the point.
We're really close to it, but I might die.
No!
Alright, it's fine.
We're just getting used to the chemistry, guys.
Everything is so new here.
It's like the honeymoon.
It's not the honeymoon phase yet.
We're figuring each other out.
When I come back, I'll...
If it's winnable, if it's winnable.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Oh, we're alive.
Oh my god.
I'm frozen.
I have Hulk on me, I have Hulk on me.
Alright, I'm gonna rez.
I'm rezzing.
Help our Luna if you can.
Alright, damage boost you, Wolverine.
Got you.
Loki, Loki, I'm on Loki.
I'm on Hulk, I'm on Hulk.
Oh my god!
This is so chaotic!
Oh my god.
This is way too chaotic.
Oh, left side, Iron Man.
Oh my god.
Mace, we can't see you, Mace, Mace!
I'm here, I'm with you.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
I am not okay.
You have damage boost?
Oh, I can't get to you.
There's a Hulk right behind us.
I might be able to grab Hulk soon.
If you can keep me up.
Oh!
I can
touch point and...
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
That was so chaotic.
I didn't realize that, like, the point was...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, that was a fucking brawl there.
Holy shit.
That was insane.
Maybe we do need four supports.
You're right, five supports is the answer.
Guys, five supports is the answer.
Maybe you're right.
If we have five supports, nobody will die.
If we think about it.
I thought we could touch...
I thought we had people to touch the point.
That's why I ulted there.
I thought we were close enough.
See, guys?
Me, picking, banning Black Widow...
Helped us.
It worked.
You're losing?
Yeah, but the enemy team didn't pick Root!
That was the entire point!
He's low.
He's asleep, he's asleep, he's asleep!
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Oh my...
I think the issue is that they also have two tanks.
Like...
Like, that's...
That's also, like, a little bit of a problem.
Oh my god.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear.
It's fine.
I could be hearing so much fear.
So much fucking fear.
I'm just gonna damage boost our banner so he can grab ult first.
It's fine, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
They're low, he's one, they're low, he's one.
I'm rezzing.
Trying to get to help you.
I can sleep him, I can sleep him.
Oh my god.
This is so fucking stressful!
I'm gonna fall!
I'll try to max his ult first.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, I actually fell down.
Woah!
I have an iron fist on me?
I'm multi-miss.
Am I Magneto?
Iron Fist on me, Iron Fist on me.
Where?
Where is this?
Hulk low, Hulk low.
Oh my god, I'm getting chugged!
I can't tell where I am!
Please, get it off of me!
Get it fucking off of me!
He's asleep.
I hate...
I really...
I can't, it's just in the air!
He's the fist.
And there he goes.
I was trying to touch the ground for ten seconds!
How is that possible?
But what if you die, Surefour?
I'm all behind you, man.
I'll go in.
Oh my god!
Some good-ass tank!
Oh my god, he's so fucking... What do you mean?!
He was gonna play Jeff!
I don't know if I'll get to him in time.
But...
Alright.
We need help, Surefour, if we can.
Loki's one!
We don't have the entire team helping you!
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Surefour, you're... Oh my...
Fear!
So much fear!
Oh my god.
I'm ulting this for you, Mace.
Surefour, get out!
You're gonna die!
I gave you so many leads, Surefour!
Oh no.
Fear.
We're down.
Oh, yeah, I don't think we're gonna live.
Oh, unless...
There's a Bucky to our left!
I'm trying to keep you up.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I got you.
I got you!
You can live!
Nevermind.
Nevermind, he didn't live.
I was trying to get him to live!
He lived, but at what cost?
At what cost?
He fucking lived.
I think a first game on fucking...
On Mantis is very...
Wait, Bucky's low!
Bucky's low!
Fear!
We're up one!
I slept Loki!
To your right.
I built this.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm not...
They grewed him well.
Okay, maybe I should have banned Groot.
How was I supposed to know he would play fucking Groot?!
He didn't play it in the beginning!
Groot's half.
Groot low.
Help!
Help our Hulk!
Hulk!
Oh.
Oh, this is last fight.
I slept Magneto!
Fear.
No!
I'm trying to keep you up!
Triforce is healing me!
No!
I can't respawn!
I can cocoon!
You have to live though!
Oh my god!
I have all of you guys keep living!
Save point!
I'm contesting!
Nice try.
Okay, guys.
I'm not banning Black Widow anymore.
She is unfortunately cursed.
Guys, it's not even fully my fault!
The Luna also banned Black Widow with me.
Look!
Luna also banned her with me.
So we are both to blame.
It's not just a me issue.
It's me and Luna.
It's...
She could have chose Groot as well, chat.
She could have chose Groot as well.
I just did it just to fuck with sureplay.
It could have flipped to Groot if we had all Groot!
I'm taking accountability!
But I'm sharing accountability with our Luna.
You're right.
Honestly, it was sureplay's fault.
If he didn't say he was going to play Black Widow, I would have banned Black Widow.
If he didn't say that, then I would have...
It all ties back to him.
Look, guys.
Guys!
But the content, though.
The content, though.
Guys.
We got...
Guys, but what about the content, though?
I know my limits.
True.
It was a good content game.
We did win, but...
We got the YouTube video.
We got the YouTube video and that's all that matters.
Now I know!
Guys!
Now I know to not do that.
Okay?
I now know.
I know again.
Guys, now I know again to not do it.
It takes me... I just need a reminder every day.
That's it.
As long as I get reminded every day to not do that, then it's fine.
Now I won't...
Yeah, but all the other three times.
I was reminded every time in-game.
It just needs to happen in-game...
For me to not do it.
You don't learn.
I do!
I just forget it the next day.
Because I'm like, wouldn't it be funny?
And it was funny!
Until I lost.
Until I lost and it was less funny.
But, it was so funny.
I do!
Guys, I want to be top 500, I swear!
When you have the number... I had... He was the number one player.
He was.
Guys, now... Now I'm locked in.
Guys, now I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in now.
This is it.
After a lot of going back to loot.
I'm locked in now.
Guys, I swear to god.
I swear to god, I won't troll this time.
I won't fucking troll.
I won't fucking troll this time, I swear to god.
No, it's true!
This is it!
I'm not... Look, it's just because Surfer was on my... It was the first game, okay?
It just triggers something.
It triggers something in me to go...
It just triggers some innate trolling inside me.
I'm just... I just feel a little silly, okay?
I just feel silly.
Silly.
I just feel very silly.
Oh my god.
I can stay up here and nothing bad will happen to me.
Right?
I can stay here and nothing bad will ever happen to me.
Okay, I have to go down.
That's called foreshadowing!
Mace, you're walled off.
Guys, it's not foreshadowing and it didn't happen.
But...
Use a hard knock knife.
That's us.
What?
What?!
Who?!
No!
I was so locked in!
Okay, now I'm locked out.
Now I'm locked out.
God damn it.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm locked out now.
It's over.
The one time I'm like, yeah, let me stop trolling.
Let me fucking stop trolling.
I need to figure out the...
Every time I swap from Luna to Mantis, it fucks with me so much.
Cause like, I don't have the projectile speed in my head.
Like, I haven't locked the projectile speed of her yet.
It's such a weird...
It's such a weird speed.
Like, I feel like I have to aim in the future when I play Mantis.
Oh wait, has someone edited my...
Wait, do I have any mods online?
Or are my mods asleep?
We need to edit our squad command.
It's pretty...
It's... When you transition from Luna to Mantis, it's...
For me, my hip brain can't...
My brain can't like, figure it out.
I'm supposed to mod a new mod.
That's actually... That would be online.
Wait, actually I was supposed to mod a new person.
Let me check their name.
They're like, remember to mod this person.
And I was like, okay.
And then three days later, whoops.
Alright.
SilentCroaky, you are now...
You are now modded.
If you're here.
Get on that account right now.
Get on that account.
We have SilentCroaky now.
So I don't know if they're actually online.
But if they are, fix my squad tag.
Cause I'm not gonna do it.
I'm not gonna do it.
Fix it.
Streamer doing their own...
Guys, I didn't...
Guys, I am not going to short port his mod.
He's fucking streaming, guys.
He's streaming right now.
She made a whole new mod because she is lazy.
Go to his chat and be like, edit my command for me.
No, I'm not gonna do it.
I'm not gonna fucking...
I'm not gonna fucking invade his chat just for him to fix my command.
Wait, is this a stack lobby?
I don't know who these people are.
I never play at these hours, so it's...
I'm like...
I never play at these hours, so I don't know who these people are.
I've always been degenerate hours.
These are new people.
This is a whole... Yeah, this is way too early for me.
It's a whole new world.
Like, who are these people?
I'm never online at this...
I'm online at this time, but no one's...
No one plays with me at this time until now.
Guys, I've stopped banning things because I realized that I'm a detriment to the team when I start banning.
Baron, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Lassa, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
And Tom, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I just...
No, every time I'm given the responsibility to ban things, I'm like...
I don't know.
What do I...
What do I play?!
JK, I'm not.
It's alright, we're here.
I was going through like an identity crisis for like...
For a while, so...
Go, Rocket, so I can get blue pack, please.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's Rocket?
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
It's alright.
Was Adam banned?
Oh, I didn't notice.
I wasn't paying attention.
As someone that's trying to get top 500 should do.
Alright, I'm so fucking ready.
I'm so ready.
Where are they?
Oh, they're over there.
Woah.
Oh my god, that's scary.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna get rid of...
No!
Oh my god!
I'm a little scared though, playing that area.
I have Venom on me.
And uh, oh...
Psylocke's asleep.
Oh my god.
He went instantly on me.
I got died by both Psylocke and fucking Venom.
God damn it.
Oh shit.
That's scary.
Oh hey, I got headshot.
I'm scared.
Fear.
I ult this?
Oh, sorry, I thought I was ulting first.
I thought I was ulting first!
I thought I was first!
Mantis is always first unless they say something.
Oh no, support ults.
What did we get out of that?
Strange and...
You wanna do Mantis or Luna first?
Okay, okay.
Alright.
I just always go Mantis first!
It's been a tradition for 20 years!
Guys, I think they might leave me.
There's a chance that the stack might leave.
LOL
Maybe.
Just a maybe though.
There might be.
But it's okay.
I know my place.
Oops, sorry, I trolled a little bit like that.
Oh my god, where is the Berserker?
Oh my god, I was not expecting that.
Venom's half?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, I'll be second.
I know my place.
Venom's low.
Venoman, no passive.
Yay!
I learned!
I can learn new tricks!
Oh, there's a Cyberpunk!
It's okay.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Oh, everything is so healthy.
Everything is so healthy.
I'm slowly backing up.
Oh, I don't have anything.
Please.
Oh my god.
He's a sleepy sleep.
Oh my god, I'm alive!
I lived!
I'm so healthy.
So incredibly healthy.
Oh my god.
I'm alive.
I feel so alive.
I feel...
Oh my god.
I'm so locked in.
Why does everybody think I have one trick?
It's just my second game of the day.
Okay, Mantis requires more.
I can't autopilot on Mantis.
I can autopilot on Luna because I have a godly insane amount of hours on her.
But like, I cannot autopilot on Mantis at all.
A stack of the tournament team?
That's the tournament winners?!
Oh no.
It's happened.
They created their fourth stack to farm me.
Why?
It's only my second game.
Have mercy.
Farm me later.
Oh my god.
I dropped down.
Oh no.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
Why can't they farm me later?
Why do they have to farm me now?
Give me buff for Furious.
I need heals.
Oh my god.
Bro, she walked away from me.
No, dude.
I was trying to chase after the Lulu.
What do I do?
Oh my god.
Lamps is a snotty.
I am.
They're like, oh, it's time.
They made a fourth stack for her.
It's time.
We gotta get her out of this elo.
Please.
If you put me in this elo, I can bring more attention to Marble Rivals and not know what you want.
Oh no.
Oh, I got hit there.
Oh my god.
I don't think Luna is very good here.
Okay.
I got one.
We can probably walk in.
I can push in with my ult.
Alright.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh, they have Iden.
I'll save it for Iden.
Look at this.
I'm shooting Magnia.
I'm gonna use this ult.
I'm gonna use it.
Fear.
Oh my god.
Back, back, one.
Back, one.
Oh.
I'm on Strange.
I'm on Mantis.
Did you see that?
Did you see him target me?
He actually fucking targeted me.
Did you see that?
He could have chose anybody else.
He could have done anybody else.
Oh, I didn't sleep him in time.
Oh my god.
I might be dead though.
I couldn't.
I was left alone.
Fear.
Oh my god.
I followed him to late.
Yeah, I didn't think they were gonna fucking go.
I didn't think they would like fucking walk in that corner.
Yeah, I should not have followed him.
I should not have followed him.
I should have fucking just ran.
I should have ran.
Yeah, I know I should hit headshots more.
I'm just so used to like... I need to like untrain my apex aim.
Because like in apex, it's better to body shot than like center mass.
Because when you're aiming in apex, you have to center mass here.
So like I'm so used to aiming like that versus like this.
So like I really have to untrain my like my four plus years of aiming center mass.
That's why I'm like struggling.
That's why I struggle the most.
Because I aim for body shots, not for headshots.
But I'm trying not to.
I'll call it otherwise.
Yeah, I'm the body shot bandit.
Apex gave me a lot of bad habits.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, scary wind.
I'm trying to save you right now.
What's up?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I see you, I see you.
I don't...
Whoa!
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point.
Oh my god.
What happened?
What?
I don't... what happened?
I don't even know what happened.
Oh, I'm dead here.
We lost both supports.
Oh my god.
What happened in that first fight?
I don't even know what happened.
Things just blurred together.
Don't worry, I'm safe here.
Oh my god.
Bro, okay.
Guys.
Wait, there's a Psylocke behind me, there's a Psylocke behind me.
Grab Psylocke, grab Psylocke, go, go, go.
Psylocke here.
Where's this?
Psylocke, Psylocke, Psylocke.
There's a... no more behind me, no more behind me.
No more Zombie.
Oh my god.
I can ult after, I can ult after.
Oh, I'm stuck in the air.
Oh my god, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
I did it!
Oh my god.
There's a Psylocke behind, Psylocke behind too.
Oh my god, if you'd let me live, oh.
Oh my god.
That Magneto was actually chasing me, it's actually...
It's crazy.
Oh my god.
This Magneto, he looked at me this entire time.
Like, what do you want me to do?
Holy fuck, I hate...
Oh my god, this is why I'm anti-mute it.
This is exactly why.
I'm ulting this, push up with it.
Tracer's low, Tracer's low.
I'm capping point, I'm capping point.
I'm damage boosting.
I think they're respawning soon.
Oh no.
They have no plop, they have no plop.
Not the will, not the will.
Not the will.
I got willed.
I was in such a bad position there.
Oh my god, I got willed!
Why did I get willed?
Oh no.
I'm trying to save our Mag, but he's gonna die.
Oh my god.
Why is this so hard?
I literally was in such a position that I couldn't move from the will.
I couldn't move from the will.
I couldn't...
Oh my god.
I got targeted so...
Yeah, I should've moved forward.
I should've...
I was gonna say, what did he do?
I was like, oh shit.
Oh my god.
Chilled, oh my god.
It's just a warm, you're right, it's just a warm up, guys.
It's just a warm up.
Not my fault!
I should've moved up though, my position was so ass there.
I should've actually moved up.
Actually, I don't know, I don't know if I live.
If I live, if things would be different, because I was not close to ult at all.
I wasn't even close to ult there.
I don't know if me living would've helped us.
But like, I got whaled so hard.
Like, I was just like, goodbye life, I guess I die.
I should've moved up though, definitely.
I'm getting warmed up right now.
I think I am getting farmed though.
I feel bad, I'm sorry!
I told them if they want to leave, they can leave whenever they want, because I know I'm not that good!
I don't wanna die!
I told them, I was like, please, you don't have to force yourself.
It's okay, if you wanna leave.
I know I'm the weakest link, so I get hard targeted there, because they're like, she doesn't know what she's doing!
She only plays for fun!
What is she doing?
Why is she here?
She doesn't even go into the school.
Get her!
She plays for fun, not for money!
Doesn't have the competitive drive that we have.
Imagine playing for fun, the classic hasting nerd.
I think I'm more casual though, because I don't scrim.
Like, these players, the people I'm playing against, they fucking scrim every day.
I've done scrims before in Overwatch, and that shit fucking kills me.
They do scrims, they do VOD reviews.
Yeah, but I just play ranked, that's different.
I don't learn...
I don't learn, I learn from sheer fucking brute force.
I learn my positioning from figuring out what I'm doing wrong, and then just like, on the go, be like, oh, I shouldn't do that next time.
But these players, they like, scrim every day.
They do VOD reviews every fucking day.
And they have coaching lessons every fucking day.
And then I'm just here.
I hit my head against the wall until I learn something.
That's basically what I do.
Don't they have a... surprisingly...
No, pro players do not have a...
Pro players don't have a life.
Their entire life is just playing this game to be the very best, and like, win tournament money.
They actually, like, me knowing, like, pro players, they surprisingly just spend their entire life on a video game.
I mean, I spend all my life streaming.
The only difference between me and a pro player is that I don't have to do scrims or VOD reviews.
Wow!
I know, right?
I can't believe I somehow queue into Kurova, Maze, and Gomez.
Oh my god.
Make more money?
Well, to be fair, like...
Esports...
Marvel Rivals is so new.
So, like, the funding for Marvel Rivals...
You know, like, first place, they got, like, $15,000.
But you gotta split that to six players.
And that was, like, two...
That's the crazy thing you think about it.
Like...
In a tournament, they get win 15... I think it was $15,000, right?
But then that's split six ways, too.
But it's the first tournament, so, like...
Isn't esport in general a bad investment?
It's a bad investment in a way where, like...
It's a bad investment because, like, in the beginning...
Because a lot of business people don't know what the fuck esport is.
And because they don't know what esports are...
They're, like...
They put a lot of money thinking it's gonna be, like, Major League Baseball.
Overwatch League.
I heard...
I heard some players were paid equivalent to, like, baseball players.
Because they thought it was gonna be, like, Major League Baseball.
And...
Because of that...
They were paid, like...
Some wages were fucking ridiculous.
Some players were paid, like, $500,000.
For, like...
Just being there.
Just, like, their salary was literally 500k.
Which was fucking insane.
For Overwatch League.
Yeah, it was Overwatch League.
Because a lot of them didn't know what, like...
They didn't know, like, what...
Like, what the...
What it should be.
Like...
Because it was so very new.
So they're, like...
What should be what we paid for?
You know?
People were so, like, confused.
On, like, what the potential was.
Oh my god, I'm frame dropping.
We're locked up.
I'm trying to...
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
He's low.
How about change on me?
Oh my god.
There's more behind me?
I don't like being up here.
Alright, I guess I'm here.
I guess I'm here now.
God, I was frame dropping hard.
That was crazy.
I was scared.
I was like, oh no, I'm frame dropping.
Like, that...
That was scary for me.
That was...
I was like, oh no.
Oh no.
I'm ulting.
Weeeee.
Well...
Nice.
Slay.
That's fine.
That's my inner monologue when I fucking...
When I play Luna.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I just wanna heal.
I just...
I just had no perspective.
When I heal.
I have to reload, sorry.
Oh my god, please.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Oh, I have a...
A Psylocke up behind me.
Oh my god.
Nooooo.
Alright.
Fear.
He like pinned me off because he saw me fearing.
I didn't realize this...
I got killed by a Hawkeye?
Do you have a Hawkeye?
We didn't ban Hawkeye.
What did we ban?
I was like, what did we ban?
I'm just surprised we have Hawkeye.
I have to position myself differently.
Oh my god.
I gotta position myself in a way.
Is there a Psylocke behind you guys?
She's half?
Goodbye.
Psylocke behind?
Okay.
That's five.
That's so five.
Where people are?
Oh.
She never missed.
But what if I'm here though?
Oh.
I'm back up.
Why do you guys wanna farm me?
I just wanna be...
I just wanna make a YouTube video.
I can't see you.
I just...
I just wanna make a YouTube video.
If I never get it, you'll never be in the YouTube video.
Enemy champion team.
Don't you wanna...
Psylocke behind you.
They're gonna hide.
Don't you also wanna be on a YouTube...
There'll only be a YouTube video if I get my goal.
Oh, what?
Oh.
I got Hawkeye'd.
I got the kill out.
What?
This is why I hate Hawkeye.
This is exactly why.
Read advertisement.
I thought they were all dead.
But they're alive.
I legitimately thought they were all dead.
Look, I have a deal.
You will be in my YouTube video if you stop trying to farm me.
Isn't that so cool?
Wouldn't that be so cool?
Guys!
I got it.
Alright, let's go.
There we go.
It's ending now.
That's fine.
Look at this freak.
They get to be in the video!
I don't know.
I don't know if they're actually...
Because if they're stacking, then they'll always be against me.
So it's a little scary.
It's a little scary.
Because of that.
That's why I'm scared.
Because they'll always be on the enemy team.
And I have to try so hard!
He shot.
Please.
This is my make-a-wish.
Am I winning?
I don't know.
This is supposed to be my VTuber Shroud Vicka win.
No more on top.
He's on me.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I have ult.
I have to be if I die.
There's one on top.
I have to ult.
I was wanting to.
Oh my god.
They have Psylocke here.
We can't.
Stop whining.
I didn't.
I had to ult there.
I was 1 HP.
If he dashed through me, I'd die.
I didn't think I could get healed in time for it.
That was why I had to ult that.
It's okay.
We can full hold, guys.
We can full hold.
YouTube's make-a-wish on Twitch.
Right point.
It was literally, I died from...
I died from the turret plus the dash, so I had to.
I knew, like, right after, I was gonna get...
It was gonna be like 20 different ults.
It's okay.
If I get farmed, it's okay.
I can't do 16 hours.
I can't.
Maybe they'll get tired.
Maybe.
Maybe they have to...
Oh, wait.
Tournament's over.
They're free.
They're free now.
Tournament's over.
They can farm me as long as they want.
I forgot.
I forgot the tournament's over.
We might be here for a while until it's their bedtime.
I...
Watch me get farmed.
Hey, guys.
Have you ever seen a...
No, everybody's seen a YouTuber get farmed.
It ain't new.
I did.
I literally, like, rested for, like, almost, like, a day and a half.
It's fine.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in.
Guys.
I'm not dooming no more!
Don't worry!
I ain't no doomer!
It's winnable!
I'm not a doomer, I swear!
There's a...
There's Psylocke to the right.
I'm not gonna doom!
Everything is winnable!
I hear Psylocke above us.
Oh, I tried.
Psylocke's behind you.
It's okay.
Believe.
We can still believe.
It was just the unfortunate Psylocke.
It's okay.
Guys, like...
I'm just a little guy.
But, like, I still believe.
It's gonna make the victories much more cooler when we do have our first win.
Let's just make it.
I can't see you up there.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I can't even see him.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Okay, it's fine.
We all lived at least.
My crew told me when you went ult.
He didn't tell me.
He stopped telling me when he went into ult.
He was so far away.
There's an Amour behind us.
I can't go for it.
I got your back.
Oh my god.
He couldn't tell me when he went ult.
I got confused.
It's okay.
That was my bad.
I can't even touch with TP.
I feel bad.
I'm confused from, like, the ult.
Sometimes he wants it first and sometimes he doesn't.
I feel bad.
I feel a little bad.
Okay, Jk, I feel really bad.
Hey,
wouldn't it be great if we had a support ult?
Yeah, yeah, I'll ask her next time.
I thought she was, like...
She was, like, really far.
So then I thought, because he was really far, I should ult there.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
This is a...
We can full hold this!
It's okay!
My Make-A-Wish is... I wanted to donate.
I'm so kind.
This wasn't a Make-A-Wish.
This is early Christmas presents to the Marvel Rival players.
I just...
Okay.
That was actually so smart of us.
Merry Christmas!
I'm here to donate.
Donate points.
Merry Christmas.
It's my late night Christmas present.
I'm here.
I'm here to donate.
I'm here to donate all the points.
I'm just not... never ulting first.
I'm just telling you guys, I'm never ulting first.
I'm never ulting first.
I'm just never ulting first.
Oh my god.
At this point, I'll never ult first again.
I'm never ulting first.
I'm sorry.
I'm in my head now.
After the first game, I'm too confused.
I went to ult first.
I'm way too confused now.
I'm way over my head.
I'm never ulting first.
I'm just gonna let him ult.
I'm just gonna restrain myself from ulting and I'm just gonna let him ult.
Fuck it.
I...
You die though?
It's alright.
I'd rather die.
I'd rather fucking die.
If...
Double support ult.
I haven't had that problem in fucking...
I haven't had the fucking double support ult problem in so fucking long.
I don't know why.
Today is just one of those days.
I told you!
I told you I'd do a fake snipe!
I could feel it.
They're like, get her out of here.
She's not even a pro player.
Get her out of here.
She's the weakest link.
So farmable.
So submissive.
And I agree.
I'm very farmable.
Because I'm not...
Every time I finish rank, I just fucking... I have to do work stuff.
I have to prep for work and everything.
Because guys, even though I'm playing Marvel Rivals every day...
After Marvel Rivals, I actually have a lot of behind the scenes work to do.
Like conventions and sponsors and merch and stuff.
So it's like...
If I could...
It's not always Marvel Rivals.
I'm very busy also.
But it's okay.
I know my place.
No, I've been... I'll let you guys know.
The last couple of times streaming this, I've been stream sniped a lot.
Which is why sometimes I play...
I do miss playing off stream.
Because it's surprising how easy games are when I'm playing off stream.
And now, I've never...
Because when you're on YouTube, you don't get stream sniped on YouTube.
Because it's like, they don't know I exist on YouTube.
No, it's not that.
I never get stream sniped when I was on YouTube.
Because they don't know about my existence.
But ever since I started streaming on Twitch...
I didn't talk about it a lot, but this one has been the most obvious stream sniping.
Because making a stack and queuing against...
You'll always get queued against another stack.
I've heard people do that for other streamers.
But this is the first time.
Because this is my first stack.
Because in the past, I've been...
I've been only duoing and trioing.
So it's harder to stream snipe duos and trios.
So like...
But I have been stream sniped by other duos before.
I've recognized it.
Because I've had somebody...
One of my friends told me...
Was it a streamer?
There was a player that literally stopped their queue...
To wait for me to queue up.
And then just to play against me.
To try and fire me.
I was like, that's cringe.
That's so cringe.
On stream!
Like what?
That's so cringe.
On stream?
Like...
Like what the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
That's crazy.
I know.
I'm just trying to fuck around.
But I've had it happen the last...
Every time I stream on Twitch.
I've had it happen.
So that's why like...
I'm trying not to let it get to me.
Because I'm just like, oh whatever.
I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to have fun.
That's why after this season...
I swear...
Stream snipers, after this season...
You won't see me here as often.
Please let me have fun.
It's just for this season.
I'll return to YouTube.
No, I'll still stream on Twitch.
I'll still stream on Twitch.
It's just that...
I've always said after this season...
I'll return back to regularly stream on YouTube.
But I'll try to stream on Twitch once a week.
Like...
At most...
Like once a week or once every other week.
After this season.
It's only because I really want to try and get top 500 this season.
That I'm doing this.
That I'm on Twitch.
Because I hate...
I hate no scheduled...
No scheduled streams on YouTube.
Because I also like...
I have to pay my thumb...
I really feel really bad.
Because I have to pay my thumbnail maker.
I have to like...
Ask my thumbnail maker...
To make...
To make thumbnails and stuff.
But like very last minute.
But what if you don't make it?
Please don't say that guys.
I don't want to do this all over again.
I don't want to...
Don't do this to me.
We want to be free.
Alright,
I'm locking in.
I'm... Okay.
Okay, he's not on Mantis or Luna.
He's not on Mantis or Luna.
So...
I can...
Whenever.
I'm also in my head right now.
Support ults after the first game.
I don't like multi-streams.
I never like multi-streams.
Because...
Because like...
I don't like dividing attention.
Between two different chats.
Chat preying on your downfall.
If you...
Oh my god.
Guys, don't please.
We want to get...
Guys, please.
I need a return on YouTube.
I don't...
I still don't like dividing attention to two different chats.
It's just...
I'm like...
I don't like dividing the audience base too.
I like...
I'd rather have all my audience in one area.
I just like having them all in one area.
I'm not a fan of like two areas...
Like in...
Both areas.
It's just not my thing.
I like having...
In one spot.
I'm trying to be positive in the darkest of the night.
I'm just...
I'm trying to be positive right now.
Please.
This is my make-a-wish.
Rival players, please.
Let me have...
Please.
You didn't...
You sniped Shroud this badly.
Please.
Shroud is streaming right now.
You wanna be on Shroud's team, don't you?
I'm just a VTuber.
He's sniping me.
It's not fun.
It's not as cool.
Just think about it.
Jesus Christ.
It'd be so much cooler to snipe Shroud.
Woah.
But I don't endorse it.
Just if you really want to snipe anybody.
I, of course, I do not endorse sniping.
But...
Oh, I'm...
I win.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my...
No!
Oh my god.
Bro, I just...
I'm sorry.
I said it!
Oh my god.
I'm just...
I can't help it!
I literally tapped and saw that he didn't have his ult.
Oh my god.
I literally saw that he did have his ult.
I don't know how he got it so fast.
How did he get it so...
Okay.
I'm locked in.
Actually, I'm fucking...
Oh my, I'm so tilted at that.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my god.
That actually...
That actually tilts me so hard.
I feel so bad.
Don't ult.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
I've never played so badly with Corrin in terms of like support ulting.
That's actually...
I don't know what it is with me and Kurova.
I think we just have like negative chemistry on support together.
I didn't think it'd be possible.
I think I found my like...
I think I literally found like my...
My negative support partner.
We have zero synergy.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, there's no more right behind us, guys.
I didn't know who keep me up was.
I didn't know who it was.
It didn't show.
I don't have the...
Oh my god.
I didn't have the thing.
Top left.
It's like keep me up.
Who was it?
Who said that?
I thought it was Hella.
Keep fighting until we have a winner.
That's not important.
I have to reload.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
To reload.
The voices.
What's the word for opposite synergy?
What we seeing right now.
What we're seeing right now.
This is the most opposite synergy I've ever had with other support.
I'm like brute forcing synergy right now.
Don't worry.
We'll go to therapy.
We'll go to support therapy to fix this.
We can fix this.
We will force synergy if we have to.
I can't.
Don't.
Oh, it's me.
It's not you, Kurova.
It's me.
I'm sorry.
I'm the problem.
We can fix this, but you can leave.
You can take 50%.
We will force synergy if we have to.
I...
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Fear.
Fear still.
Oh my god.
Fear.
So much fear.
Oh,
fear.
Fear!
I did it!
I weakened force chemistry!
See, guys?
Never give up on your relationships.
Never.
Never give up.
You can force something out of nothing.
That's the lesson.
We don't need therapy.
We can just manually fix this through brute force.
Through the risk of rank 1.
There's a... there's a stream behind me.
Oh my god.
Guys, but if your relationship is an issue, you should go to therapy.
Guys!
Forcing things is not it.
I'm just doing it for the sake of...
But if you're in a competition, you might as well.
Fear.
There's a strange on me.
He's still on me!
I have to hit, I have to... I'll just...
Oh my god.
3, 2, 1...
Holo one.
I'm warned.
Oh my god!
This is a fixable relationship!
We can do this!
We can force synergy!
We can force it!
It's not broken!
It's fixable!
The spark is still there.
It's fixable.
It's so fixable.
I believe.
Even if we lose this, at least we know it's not negative.
It's like zero now.
The synergy is at zero, but at least it's not negative.
And that's all that matters.
Even if it's not negative anymore.
Zero point... If we win this, it becomes zero point one.
If we win this.
We figured it out.
Slowly but surely, we figured it out.
I was a problem, and I was willing to change.
Oh my god, that frame drop was crazy though.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
I'm gonna
ult here, I'm gonna ult here, I'm gonna ult here.
That's me.
I had Zul too, but he got shamed over it.
Alright.
Phantus can die.
Yippee!
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Did that ult hit me while ulting?
I don't know what happened.
I actually... I don't know what happened.
I don't know.
I'm legitimately just as confused as you guys are.
Oh my...
Like, I'm so confused.
What happened?
Like...
I don't even know what happened.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I need help, I need help.
Oh.
Hey guys.
It's fine.
Oh, I got hit by Hella there.
I'm gonna ult this.
Come on.
Oh my god.
This is technically last fight.
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ.
That was last fight.
Oh my god.
I got Hella moment right there.
I got Hella... Wait, can we touch... No, there's no way.
No, there's no way.
I was gonna say.
It's okay guys.
Now we know the synergy is at zero now.
We've made it to like...
It's not negative because we fixed the synergy issue.
We fixed it, so it's at zero now.
I think the issue is that like...
I'm bad.
As the...
It's at... At least...
That's the...
Now that we fixed the issue...
Wait here.
Now that we fixed the synergy issue...
Now it's the skill issue.
I got my Oshies washed.
Now it's just the skill issue.
So, we gotta work on that.
We gotta work on skill.
We need... Honestly, no.
We need a team building exercise.
We need a fucking team building exercise here.
I need a team building exercise.
I think maybe...
No, no, no, no, no.
We don't need therapy.
We fixed the support synergy now.
Now it's at zero.
Like, things should be fine.
We're at zero now.
Now this is it!
The moment we win the game, it's up... It's all uphill.
As in like, it's gonna go well.
Now that we won.
We need family therapy.
We don't need... It's not a support issue anymore.
Now it's just family therapy.
Right...
Now...
Now it's a...
Now it's a family therapy session.
Now...
I'm also not used to such high elo...
Like, super high elo games too.
So like, I'm learning as we go.
I'm like... I'm just a fucking lowly Eternity player.
So like, it's fine.
I'm just...
I'm getting... I'm learning how to be a better player though from this.
From Brute Force alone.
At the risk of everybody else's rink ruins, I'm...
At least I'm like, learning how to play better.
Guys, that's a positive.
That's... I'm learning how to be a better player.
At the expense of everybody else.
Thank you.
Enlightened, a major.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
It's a sacrifice I'm willing to make...
At the risk of everybody's expense.
Did I ask their permission?
No.
I'm gonna hold all your points hostage.
Alright.
Some of you may derank.
Most likely me.
But that's the risk I'm willing to take.
Wait, hold on.
That's not how the phrase goes.
Look.
It just means we'll be better players in the end.
Guys, I'm establishing synergy.
I've literally made...
A miracle has happened.
I swear, we definitely have negative synergy.
I swear to God.
After...
We definitely had negative synergy going in.
But now it's different.
Now it's like...
Now it's a lot better.
It's zero.
So it's not negative.
It's zero now.
So like, we're getting there.
We won't bash our head in.
Yo, is that the fucking god team or what?
No, on me this is the god team.
We gotta go to therapy.
We are not going to therapy.
We don't need couple counseling anymore.
We don't need support counseling anymore.
We don't...
We can fix this without professional help.
We don't need professional help.
We're fixable without them.
X.
Mmm.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
I ult second.
I'm like so in my head though because of this.
Do you want to take this corner?
Okay, take the corner.
Or we can take that corner.
Or we'll bring the right corner.
Oh.
Oh man.
I'm gonna push the cart a little bit.
Oh no.
Hey yo.
Oh my god.
I'm pushing cart.
Look at him go.
Oh my god, look at these cams.
There's a stream behind you guys.
There's a stream behind.
Oh my god.
Change, change, change, change.
Change half.
Oh my god, there we go.
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Where'd he fucking go?
Where did he go?
Where'd he go?
Also, I got confirmation that stack was...
That force stack was sniping us.
Oh my god.
Yeah, isn't that cringe?
You won first in the tournament.
What do you need my points for?
You already got the money.
You already got first place.
What do you need my points for?
I don't understand.
They take money and points.
You don't understand, Toki.
They won it all.
You don't...
It's not about...
It's about everything.
Okay.
I won it all and I won it now.
It's not about the money, Toki.
It's about sending a message.
He did.
He definitely sent a message.
Toki...
Oh, that's true.
I had more viewers than the tournament.
Nevermind, it's understandable.
It's understandable.
Nevermind, I understand now.
I don't have ult.
They're pushing me.
I'm focusing Mag.
Ulting.
Oh my god.
Psylocke to your left.
They won it all.
It truly is a dark world.
I can ulti here.
I'm pushing cart.
Heard, heard.
Goodbye.
You only have cloak heals.
Out, out, out, out, out, out.
Everyone out.
Get out, get out, get out.
Here I go.
Wait, what is Toki asking about?
I was like, I think they're sniping.
Because they're force stacking and I'm force stacking.
So, like, it's weird, you know?
It's weird, because it's like...
If you force stack, you always get the enemy.
You always...
I'm trying to save you.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
Nice.
Farming you for points.
They won it all.
They're not happy with winning the tournament.
Oh my god.
This is it.
They won my points.
They've been paid by the devs to keep you from reaching your goals.
So see you all next season.
You're right.
I got a hit on me.
I got...
I got a fucking hit on me.
I'm on the list now.
I'm on the list.
And I still won't be sponsored.
I'm sorry.
Alright, let's go.
Keep her in purgatory so she'll be here forever.
She'll be stuck here in the fucking slums.
Oh, it's that one more win hit.
It's like the...
They're trying to keep me.
It's like one more hit.
Come on, just one more.
Just one more win.
Just one more win and then you can uninstall the game.
Then you can uninstall it.
Just one more.
One more.
Three, two, one.
The tournament is done.
I will never stop digging.
I will never.
They know.
They know what I want.
And stats that need it.
Oh, good stuff.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Mr. Fister.
You're locked up.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I'm playing in it.
Alright, where are you?
Where are you?
Do you still have your damage boost?
Oh my god.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see the mystery.
I don't want to spoil myself.
Because I want to experience it.
I want to experience it during when I play the season on YouTube, by the way.
I'm going to do YouTube streams for checking out the new season stuff.
But rank stuff would be...
The rank stuff would be on...
I slept him, I slept him.
Do they have Groodle?
Alright.
There's a group behind, guys.
Group behind.
I'm ulting.
Oh, we're dead.
We're dead.
The moon.
You're still stalling.
Our Thor is stalling.
Oh my god.
I have a Bengi on me.
Not the moon.
The scream about the portal.
Portal's gone.
No.
Not the portal.
That poor guy.
Not the fucking portal.
Oh my god.
Who said that?
Is that Mr. Fister?
Where is he?
There's a Psylocke behind.
There's a Psylocke behind us.
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
Oh, he got up.
Shake it off.
Nice.
Oh my god.
He fisted them.
Look at him go.
Look at our Fister go.
We're safe.
No.
Oh my god.
I couldn't.
I couldn't live through that.
I got all the pockets in the world.
Yeah, I couldn't live through that.
We let the Fister down.
We're gonna have the...
Watch out for the portal.
I thought...
I mean, you'll be fine, right?
There's a Psylocke all out there.
I'm stalling for him.
Yeah, Psylocke ult.
They had Psylocke ult.
Oh, I can't see anything.
I'm fucking blind.
He's doing it.
I dodged everything, but then I still get fucked.
Oh my god.
They're all on, all on, all on.
Just walk up.
Nevermind, I lied.
Oh, the tree.
I thought I could slip that in.
I was like, haha, I can slip this in.
Fear.
Actual fear.
Oh my god.
I got the shark.
The fact that...
The shark went for me.
Did you guys see that?
The shark went for me and then...
I got double solo ulted.
Like, what the fuck is this?
They're all freaks.
Like, how did I get double solo ulted?
There.
How the fuck was that possible?
He's low again.
Okay.
I, what?
How was I in it?
Oh no, it was not in it.
I was not in it.
I'm coming over.
If you guys can live, I'm still close to ult.
Body, body.
Oh my god.
I'm on Groot.
Magnio's low too.
Please, they're both low.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Why did I get triple solo ulted?
I'm fucking just a little guy.
I'm just a little guy.
I...
She's cackling getting double solo ulted.
What can I do?
The fact that the shark aimed for me and his ult and then...
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
I'm like just a little guy.
I'm literally just a little guy trying to make it in this world.
I didn't know Mantis has tank aggro.
The shark could've ate anybody else.
Literally, we had the whole... I'm fucking... I'm gonna draw this out.
You know, you guys... I know you guys just saw this, but even I can't believe that happened.
So like, alright.
So this is the wall.
This is the car.
This is my entire team just standing around the car.
I'm here.
And then the shark was like, you know who to target?
That one person that's secluded.
It's okay.
I'm gonna show you guys.
Don't worry.
I drew it and I'm gonna show you guys.
Oh my god.
Wait, did my stream crash?
Oh no, it didn't.
Where did my stream go?
Where did my stream tab go?
Guys, I lost my OBS.
My OBS disappeared.
I don't know what happened to it.
It's not in my tabs anymore.
My OBS is not...
You guys still see yourself, but like, I don't have an OBS bar.
I don't have an OBS bar.
Where did it go?
Tabs.
Where is my OBS?
The OBS app isn't even in my app!
Oh my god.
No, I did alt-tab to find it, but it's actually gone.
It's not even...
It's actually not...
It's just gone.
Oh, my OBS got sniped.
I literally don't see it.
Where did it go?
It disappeared in my apps.
OBS got solo'd.
I can't even show you.
I'm gonna put an imgur.
You will be missed.
Alright, guys, this is my...
No, it's not even in my task manager.
Alright, this is my picture.
So, like, as you guys can see...
So, that's the wall right there.
And then...
That's the wall.
And then the circle, that's the card over there.
And then there's, like, you know, five of my teammates.
Yeah?
There's five...
There's...
And that's me at the bottom.
By myself.
And then the shark was like...
Who do I eat?
Who...
And then they thought this right here was...
Was where...
Guys, I'm literally posting the imgur link in chat.
You see it now.
I have my OBS actually disappeared.
I can't see my OBS anymore.
It's not even, like...
It's not even in my apps.
For, like...
Like, that's the crazy part.
Like, I don't...
It's in my background...
Thing.
But, like, the whole thing is just gone.
It's literally gone.
What the fuck is that?
Just doing my best here.
I'm doing my best in this fucked up situation I'm in.
I'm doing my best.
Guys, I really am.
I did all of that with my mouse!
What do you want from me?
It was my mouse and keyboard.
I'm suffering here.
Alright, here we go.
This is where I suffer.
Woo!
Guys, I haven't done art in so long.
I actually haven't done art in a while, though.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, can you taunt me out real quick?
Oh my god!
Everything will be fine.
Oh!
Right side, McNeil.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh, my.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
We're so healthy.
Everything is so healthy.
Everything is so...
What happened?
Who did I kill?
I don't even know what just happened.
So healthy.
So fucking healthy.
Look at that.
We're figuring things out!
See, guys?
Every win we get, our synergy goes up by 0.1%.
It's just gonna take us like...
If we keep playing together for two more years, maybe this relationship is salvageable.
Maybe it's fixable.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear, fear, fear.
I fucking fucked it.
Three, two, one.
I have Magneto on me.
Magneto's one, Magneto's one.
Did you see that?
Did you see the target?
What the fuck was that?
We had three other people there, bunched up.
But don't fuck me, Angus.
Magneto warning me, bitch.
They're like, she's the weakest link.
She's a streamer.
Guys, TimTheTatman is streaming.
Ninja's streaming, guys.
To all my stream snipers out there, Ninja's streaming.
Oh, I got juicy Ninja Qs.
Whoa!
Imagine those juicy Ninja Qs right now.
Oh...
Oh, die, me.
She's not flying.
No supports.
They're like, nice try, Doki.
We know your games.
Guys, oh my god.
Wouldn't it be so funny if you make Ninja rage?
Guys, you can't make me angry.
I just laugh.
It's not as funny.
It's not.
All I'm saying is that it's not as funny because I just laugh.
Oh my god.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear.
I fucking hate you.
Oh no.
I'm on Starlord.
And that's not a strange.
It's okay.
They were so thirsty.
I still can't eat.
I still can't.
I'm here.
Bro is trying to warn you that the fear is for you.
There were three people grouped up but he still went for you.
I told you.
I told you this is a hate crime.
What do I do?
Like, help me.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
You should farm.
Literally farming for YouTube content.
Instead of like my road to top 500.
It's like everybody wants this streamer dead.
My clickbait title.
Every Marvel Rivals player wants me out of Twitch.
Who's that for?
Me?
Your two people in your stack is me.
Oh yeah, shit.
I was like, me?
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
It is me.
There you go.
Here's another one.
Oh, it's gone now.
Did it work?
Guys, I don't think the strat worked.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
The Runaan's.
Please.
You all require healing!
Oh my god.
Here.
That was fast.
Oh my god.
Dance.
Dance, Doki.
The whale.
Finally.
The one...
Guys, I forgot what it was like to be not 24-7 on a hit list.
That was like...
I think that was the first round.
I actually was not on a hit list there.
That's crazy.
And it was for half a round.
It was for half a round.
I was actually like...
Freedom.
I'm not on...
I'm not on some fucking list there.
That was insane.
That was actually insane.
I still can't believe it was like...
Hey, Magneto.
Who should you use your ult for?
The three people stacked up together?
Or this Luna player on the side.
That has a fucking building to cover her.
I wonder if it's also because...
I think it's also because they saw me running.
And they're just rubbing their hands together.
And they're like...
Vulnerable.
No one else runs away.
But because I get Stockholm Syndrome from all the...
From all the Magnetos targeting me.
That I just run at that point.
They're like...
This person fears me.
She's running.
She's weak.
The easy target.
Not Stockholm Syndrome.
Oh, what's the other word for it?
I think they realize how like...
How I've...
I Pavlov.
Yeah, Pavlov.
I Pavlov my way to just run after that.
Every time I hear Magneto say fear.
Yeah, conditioning.
Yeah, they condition me.
We're so back.
I can't believe I lost my OBS.
It literally disappeared.
I don't know where it went.
It's gone!
Like...
I don't have...
It says OBS is launched.
But it's gone.
Where did it go?
It's like...
I try to open it.
But they're like...
It's like...
Where did it go?
The OBS ran away.
How will I...
How do I do?
How do I end my stream?
OBS here.
We're here forever.
I think I'm gonna go high ground here.
Try finding...
It's not in my task manager.
It's not in the apps.
It's in the background processes.
But I can't...
I can't bring it forward.
Because it's in the background.
It's just in the background.
He's opening a portal, guys.
Woah.
Yeah, I'm gonna go in.
Whatever they're looking for.
Woah!
Goodbye.
Guys, I wish I can get headshots from down here.
Actually, I just wish I could get headshots in general.
Wait, there's people on the point.
There's two on point.
Wait, we never capped.
Hello.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Someone break this, please.
I'm too weak.
I'm so weak.
Somebody break this, please.
Our supports are not with you guys.
We're trying...
We're trying to break this thing.
Oh.
Alright,
I'm dead.
We're just...
We're at one beat.
Sorry, the supports are trying to fight.
We shouldn't have fought a pillar.
I just saw Kurooba doing it.
So I was like...
That seems like what I should be doing, right?
I'm gonna ult this first.
I'm not on ult.
Oh shit.
There's a strange on me!
It's okay.
Oh, he's fucking low too.
I need to save mine for a Starlord ult.
I forgot the Starlord existed, not gonna lie.
I legitimately forgot Starlord.
I didn't realize the Starlord was around.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
He did not exist for me.
Jesus Christ.
Oh no, not the Hulk.
Oh no.
He's low.
He's half.
There's an Iron Man above us.
Oh no, he made him mad.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
He's trying to get to you.
I have a Hulk on me.
I'm on.
I'm ulting.
I'm ulting him.
I'm asleep.
Let's change one.
Oh my god, they're gonna have Starlord ult though.
Oh my god, they have Starlord ult though.
They have Starlord ult so I'm a little scared.
Fear.
There he is.
One point.
Iron Man's one, bro.
Iron Man's one.
He's not one anymore.
He's not one.
I didn't know where he was.
What do you mean?
I slept...
Oh, I can't.
I was like, where?
Where do you mean?
When he was like, where is he?
I was like, what?
What do you mean?
Where is the Iron Man?
I know.
I was like, where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Yeah, when he was ulted you didn't look at him?
Where?
Please ping the Iron Man.
I even looked up and gamers normally don't look up.
I just did the impossible and I still couldn't find him.
Also, hello, Rod!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Hello, everybody!
My name is Doki Bird.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Markiplier.
Sorry.
Hello, everyone!
My name is Doki Bird.
I used to stream on YouTube, but now I'm getting stream sniped on Twitch, so let's go!
Let's go!
So I'm on Twitch because I want to get stream sniped to oblivion and donate my points to the cause.
They TP'd.
I'm flanking them right now.
I'm gonna go right side.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, I can't focus!
I can't!
Hulk is low!
I'm sorry!
I'm on Ironman!
You're in this spot!
I love it!
He's so over it!
He was so over it!
Oh my god.
I couldn't focus there.
I'm sorry.
We lost that fight because of that.
It was just so funny.
That was like the fucking cry of like, I hate my DPS players.
I think it was Korova.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it was Korova that said that.
That was like the cry of, I'm so over it.
Bro, I can't get these heals.
I'm 1v6ing.
Bro, where the fuck's my heals?
There's Starlight Turret left.
I'm ulting.
No you don't.
No you...
Where?
Who's we?
I'm waiting for leaves.
I'm waiting for my leave cooldown, please!
Yes!
Every win our synergy goes up by 0.1%!
It's working!
We're doing it!
Oh, it's not over.
I know, we lost the first one, dude.
Welcome, raiders.
Welcome, welcome.
SushiCat, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Only 0.1%.
Yeah, only 0.1%.
We're at 0.2% right now.
0.02% actually.
It's 0.01%.
Every win is 0.01%.
I told you!
You got TP this time?
I shouldn't say that.
I go to therapy sometimes.
It's not a scam.
Guys, you just gotta find the right therapist.
But counseling therapy is a scam.
That's right.
If the relationship is over, fuck it, just end it.
I mean, but it's fixable.
But like, no, no, Kurobo and I, our support synergy is fixable.
Synergy is fixable.
Put it on them, put it on them.
Yeah, I'm going on top of them.
Tell me when though, tell me when though, tell me when though.
I got it right now, I got it right now.
Guys, I don't think he... Oh my god!
What the fuck?
What hap... What happened?
What?
Okay, let's go.
What happened?
I know, I was so surprised.
Oh, I shouldn't have done that.
I was... I shouldn't have cocooned.
I was so surprised I accidentally left clicked.
I was... I was so surprised.
I was not ex... I don't know, I just... I was not expecting it.
It like surprised me so much.
Like, it was such a weird ass fucking kill.
I slept Hog.
I don't have ult for that.
I can't peek.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god, that was crazy.
I can ult this in here.
Alright, let's go.
Stop laughing.
Okay, I'm gonna ult.
I have a strange on me.
I... I don't see you, I don't see you.
I'm... I healed you.
I'm on... I'm on the strange.
I'm on the strange.
Strange is one.
Strange is actually solo.
I'm really... Oh, there's Sylar.
There's Sylar behind us.
Oh!
I don't have leaves.
I have a strange on me too.
I'm cocooning.
I have a strange left.
There's a... There's a strange.
There's a strange.
There's a strange on point.
Please!
Oh my god!
I was like, get on point!
Strange is on the point!
What do you want me to do?!
I was like, guys!
What about strange?
What about the one character that's on the point?
Oh my god, isn't that silly?
That's so... I'm ulting.
Get on... near me.
Oh my god.
I'm with our... I'm with our Adam.
I don't have... I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Did I... Am I gonna... I'm gonna...
Oh no.
I slept him.
No!
Let me live!
Are we gonna get there?
I don't... I don't know.
He got a touch.
No!
Why did he spaz on that ult?
Rest in peace, all of our friends.
Oh my god, rest in peace.
How did he miss?
They were right in front of them.
That's true.
True.
The thing is, they have like a million shields.
They had... We also had like one guy who doesn't play strange that was on strange.
So he was like uncomfortable too.
So it's like, you know, it is what it is.
Okay, we sort of like... I also got a bit distracted in...
I also got like a bit distracted there when our other support literally screamed at our Ironman being like, you're in their spot!
I'm the team 1v6 and missed every ult.
That... That was... I couldn't focus.
I couldn't... It was so hard to lock back in.
It was so good.
I was just like, that's the support player right there.
That was... That's a... That's a support player.
I thought he disappeared.
BabyBae was like... Was an Overwatch player.
For like... When Overwatch first came out and he was like pretty well known.
And then he just disappeared.
I never expected to see him back.
I see so many players that were like gone-gone for so long and then they just came back for Overwatch.
It's crazy.
BabyBae, he's a... What was he known for?
He was known for being incredibly toxic.
But I think he's reformed.
He got older, you know?
He got older.
He's reformed now.
Like... Like he mellowed out.
Like he could've said worse things.
He has said worse things in Overwatch.
But like he... Clearly he seemed like he got better.
This is... Yeah, this is technically mellowed out.
I remember back in the Overwatch BabyBae area.
It was a lot worse.
This is the norm endorsement you think this is.
I'm bronze and never whiffed a pulse charge that hard.
Okay, but like when you're in bronze they don't know what to...
Okay, but like when you're there in bronze the players have like... Don't have the fucking game sense to dodge.
Don't have the game se... Yeah, bronze players don't move, guys.
Bronze players don't move.
I'm sorry.
If they wish to stop queue at any moment, I understand.
I understand my teammates.
It's been... It's been a very rough session and I understand.
But at least we're having fun, right?
At least chat's having fun.
I'm sort of having... I'm having fun.
I'm having fun too.
But like... I told them they're allowed to leave whenever.
Because I understand.
And yeah, that's fine.
I'm okay with that.
I know my place.
I know my place in the world.
I signed up for the circus.
We're all here.
If I was... I mean... I... If I really, really wanted to like act at climb, I'd do it off stream.
Yeah, that's true.
But also like, I know you guys enjoy watching the climb too.
Because I feel like if I do make it... If I do make it, it's so much more satisfying, you know?
It's so much more satisfying to accomplish it on stream.
After, you know, getting hate crime for the last week.
After getting fucking hate crime for the last week, it feels like I'm literally going against God.
Fighting a war against God right now, trying to get top 500.
He's sending everything possible to get in my way by being on stream.
Like, I'm literally... I literally got hit list by a fucking first place team in this Marble Rivals tournament.
I literally was on a... I got hit list by the number one team in Marble Rivals.
I know my place.
I...
Huh?
I'll support you regardless.
How much damage does Mantis do?
I don't know.
You should watch a video for that.
I just play the game.
I just know it does more damage.
I don't even know how... I remember like, when I used to play Overwatch a lot.
And I was known for my over... Oh, for Overwatch and Apex stuff, people would ask me these questions.
They're like, how much damage does an R9 do per shot?
And I'm like, I don't fucking know.
I just know it does a lot of damage.
Like, what?
I would have... because I used to be known as... I used to be really, really good at R9.
Like, I still am, but R9 gets nerfed so much in Apex.
But like, so it's not a good gun anymore.
But when it was like, the gun, I was like, a monster on it.
Because I have really good tracking skills.
And then like, people would ask me, they're like, how much shots does a one R9 bullet do to a head?
And I was like, bro, do you think I fucking care?
Like, as long as the person dies, that's all that matters.
Like...
They die, next question.
They just die.
And then like, but the thing is, like, I was talking to like, pro players about it.
And they're like, you don't know?
It does blah, blah, blah, damage.
I'm like, what?
I'm sorry, I live outside the game.
Like...
I'm sorry, I have a career outside of Apex.
I'm sorry.
Like, I'm sorry.
Oh, sue me, I don't know what the damage is for one fucking bullet.
Like...
They do, pro players know like, what the damage is for like, each shot and stuff.
So like, I'm fucking nerds.
Nerd!
I don't touch grass, but like, I have a life outside of it.
Like, nerds!
I just want the gun, give me... exactly.
Exactly.
I have a dog and I'm contractually obligated to touch grass.
That too.
Honestly, I'm glad I have a dog so I can actually go outside.
I think if I didn't have Dirky Amber Doge, my...
I would never see the sun.
I would actually never see the sun.
If like, he was... if he never existed in my life.
I need to start eating pills.
Like, those like, supplements.
Not like, bad pills.
I meant like, vitamin pills.
I need to start... I need to start actually taking like, supplements and stuff because I feel like...
I feel like I'm like... I definitely need more vitamin.
Vitamins in my system.
Vitamins are pills!
Aren't they just pills?
They're like pills, right?
Dirky, the word is vitamins, but they're also pills, aren't they?
I should get some scummies too.
Aren't there gummies that actually do stuff?
There's gummies, like the Flintstones ones.
There's like, non-children versions of it.
I don't know.
Sometimes I don't know if gummies are like, a scam or not.
Gamer gummies are definitely a scam.
I think if you put gamer in front of anything, it's just a scam.
Wait, but not GamerSubs!
GamerSubs is different!
I'm drinking GamerSubs right now, guys!
If anything, GamerSubs is not a scam because I'm drinking GamerSubs right now!
If you use my code, DIRKYBIRD, you get 10% off, off of every purchase.
DIRKY, you scam!
Okay, but I've seen gamer gummies and I think that's a scam.
Just buy regular gummies.
And buy it at bulk in Costco, because it's cheaper.
I feel like... If I know what's not a scam, GamerSubs.
You know what was a happy surprise yesterday?
Knowing that Space King episode 2 came out.
I fucking love Flash Gitz.
You can tell what my humor is like because of it.
Guys, if you guys didn't know, Space King episode 2 came out.
It was a good episode.
I liked it very much.
Do you know what's not a scam?
My sponsor, exactly.
It was.
I like how they want to make money, and they're tired of getting Warhammer-ed suit, I guess.
Because they want original content.
They want to make money and make merch and stuff, but they can't do that off of parody content.
So they just literally made Space Marines 2.
But what if... But they call it Space King.
Which I thought was really funny.
I'm not a gamer, girl.
I'm just a gamer.
You guys hear that Notch announced Minecraft 2?
Like, that's crazy.
He basically announced... He announced Minecraft 2.
I don't know where he announced that.
I literally just saw my Twitter being like, Minecraft 2 is actually gonna come out!
And then Notch was like, yeah, Minecraft 2.
I'm like, how do you make 2 of Minecraft?
He's still alive?
Yeah, because he sold Minecraft to Microsoft, so technically he's not allowed to make a second Minecraft.
So I'm pretty sure he's just gonna be like... It's gonna be Minecraft, but Notch owns it again.
But when Notch owned Minecraft, there were no updates, so I'm just... I don't know.
I don't know.
There were barely updates when he owned Minecraft, so I don't know what he's gonna do.
True!
It's just basically him talking about his next project, but like, trying to be like, it's Minecraft 2!
But legally, it's not Minecraft 2.
Like, legally.
It's just Minecraft, but owned by Notch again.
How did we get Minecraft 2 before Silkside?
And legally distinct Minecraft 2.
It's gonna... Oh my god, I actually backed the Kickstarter for Cube World!
I'm so stoked to mention Cube World in this household.
I actually backed it.
So did I.
What the fuck is Cube World?
Cube World was gonna be like, RPG Minecraft, and then like, it died.
I was so sad.
All that... Yeah, all that squandered potential, I agree.
I feel like it definitely could've... It definitely could've been like, a really good game.
If they weren't stuck in development hell.
And then the developers got really depressed because people hated where it was going, and then they literally just stopped developing it.
So it's like... So like, you know, nothing came out of it.
Yeah, it was like, literally like, RPG.
I'll play Loki.
Actually, I don't know what would go well with this.
I don't know.
Cloak is that Loki?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
I'm sorry.
I'm being a detriment to my stack.
I just wanna play Loki.
I wanna win too!
I swear to God, I wanna win.
I...
I swear to God.
I swear to God, I do wanna win.
Yeah, I think... Oh wait, is he not gonna... Oh, is he not gonna go Atom?
But you're number one Atom!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let's let Kuroba rage at me for trying out Atom again.
Alright, Kuroba.
I want you to cry when you rewatch this part of the VOD after losing you so many points.
I hope he watches this part of the VOD and now understands why he's losing.
I'm not actively throwing!
I'm just bad!
There's a difference!
There's a difference, guys.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Come on!
You guys can kill them!
I believe.
That's sad.
I just need them to understand.
I'm trying my best.
I am.
I swear to God, I'm trying my best.
I swear.
I'm not intentionally...
Oh my God.
I'm not intentionally fucking up.
I'm just... I'm just not the best.
Am I all... I'm popping in here in 3, 2... Big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big!
Oh my God!
Oh no, it's fine!
He got it!
We're doing it!
Tell me to pass it to your friend.
I heard you saying you had your ult.
I'm not smart enough for that shit.
Oh my God.
No, no, no, our...
I mean, he's screaming, he had ult, but...
Nevermind, I'll just... I'll just fucking do it.
Not smart enough for this shit.
You guys are welcome.
Where did they come from?
No idea.
We're so healthy.
Oh, I'm not healthy no more.
JK.
I'm still so healthy.
Bro, I'm not healthy anymore.
There we go, we got to 99.
We did it.
We're so healthy.
Look at us go.
Alright, let's go.
Now that we're all so healthy, things will be okay.
Things will be so okay.
Things will be so okay, I believe.
Things are... Oh my God.
Things are so healthy.
Things are so...
No.
That's fine.
We're so fucking...
We're so healthy.
Don't worry.
We're so good.
Oh my God.
Look at us go.
Come on, review me.
If you're watching this, I would love to give Audrey...
If you're watching this part of the phone, do you have any nose caroba?
Do you have any?
Mr. Number 1 item player.
And then we lose this game after.
I told you guys, we're so healthy.
Does he have any notes?
Does he have notes?
That's messed up.
I think we're TPing, I think.
Come on.
Damn.
I don't know what to do.
I didn't expect to get signed.
But I'll make less money, so I don't know.
Sorry, I shouldn't say that.
I'm so funny.
Okay.
I mean, he's like in my face right now.
Oh, he's a respawner.
Yo, rez us Doki, rez us Doki.
I'm rezzing.
Oh, he's on it, he's on me.
Okay, you got it, let's go, let's go.
Let's go.
There's a guy behind us, there's a guy behind us.
There's a strange on me.
There we go, plan.
That's plan.
I'm doing it.
Planned!
So planned.
So...
Portal behind me.
I soulbonded.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, I'm so dead.
No!
Oh, that's not ours.
That's fine, that is ours, JK.
Planned!
100% planned!
Let's go!
Ain't no go.
I'm not doing so great, don't go.
I'm getting stream sniped oblivious.
I just changed my stream title to be like, just quick play gaming.
Not playing rank at all.
Not playing rank.
I soulbonded us.
What do I do?
Oh my god, there's so many!
Come on, Maze, we're chilling.
Yeah, yeah.
I hope we lose this game.
Woah, goodbye.
It would be great if we had a strange ult right now.
That would be so silly.
That would be so silly, right?
Guys?
I'm gonna watch him kill you.
I can't believe he lived!
Oh shit!
Nice!
Wait, there's Starlord still here.
Everybody take TP, everybody take TP.
TP, TP, TP, TP, TP, TP!
What is that?
I'm having too much fun here.
This is a problem.
There we go.
Look at that, 100% win rate on Adam.
There you go.
The perfect Adam win streak continues!
Let's go!
I don't know how I keep winning on Adam.
I don't know how.
Even when I'm not fucking stacking.
Guys, we're almost...
After 3 hours, we're just down...
We're just down 10 points.
We did it!
We're totally down 10 points after 3 hours.
I'm just that good.
Sound about right.
Noco, what's your ink now, Noco?
That's when you know it's a good session, guys.
When you're almost back to where you started.
That's when you know.
270?
Oh shit, you're climbing!
I've been stuck in purgatory.
I legitimately think I have a target on my back right now.
I'm like, I don't...
Ever since I came back to Twitch.
What's the cutoff?
I think cutoff would be 250 or 260.
It's like climbing 20 points a day.
Am I winning?
Well, after 3 hours, I'm down 10 points.
Is that winning?
Yeah, the Marvel devs made a hit list for me.
They're like, we're gonna get her.
We're gonna fucking...
She's gonna...
She's gonna be here forever.
She's gonna chase the top 500 high.
And then just barely miss it every time.
And then every season, she'll think it's different.
And then we're just gonna hire like...
We're just gonna hire the entire Marvel rival player base to fuck her up.
I feel like I'm going into like conspiracy theorist territory right now.
I think they're all out to get me.
Honestly!
Stream snipers!
Do you know who's also streaming?
Shrouded Ninja!
Oh my god.
Oh, you know what would be funny?
If they get mad at your stream sniping.
Oh, it would be so funny.
It would be so...
What the fuck are you talking about?
I've been playing Marvel rivals for too long.
Oh, he's doing cat.
They don't know that.
They'll be like, oh my god, he is.
And then they're gonna click out of the stream.
Hahaha.
Who are you talking to, bro?
Guys, making Ninja crash out would be so funny.
All I do is laugh.
Hahaha.
But it's funny to stream snipe the VTuber?
It's literally not real.
How would it be funny?
You laugh and cry.
I'm not real, I'm virtual.
Oh my god, it's Mr. Fister!
Oh, women are real too.
Didn't you guys know that?
They're not real.
Have you ever seen a woman?
It's just a conspiracy theorist.
Invented by the government.
See, I'm not trolling.
My team's trolling.
I let them ban players now.
Yeah, women are like a government psyops.
Just like birds.
Bitches aren't real either.
Have you ever seen a pigeon sleep?
No,
he can't.
Who is he gonna fist?
He can't fist.
It's the fucking aura, bro.
It's the aura.
Who's Black Widow?
Alright.
Oh my god, please lord, make the game ha- No fist, why live?
Exactly.
If you can't fist anybody, then you might as well just...
Do a flip.
Off a cliff.
In game.
What is he gonna do?
It's his life!
It's literally his life!
He's gonna be called Mr. Fister just to not fist?
Like, what's the point?
He's literally lying on the internet.
Who does that?
Guys, I can't believe they target banned me.
The 100% win rate Adam.
That's so fucked up.
Specifically me.
Me.
Alright guys, this is my wake up call.
Can we log in?
I can't believe they target banned my Adam.
Alright, Mr. Fister.
You know how to play, right?
Uh, kind of.
Kind of?!
No, I was joking.
Yes!
Oh!
Wow!
And you get topped off, you.
Third day TP'd.
That box looked so dead.
Fucking third inning, not gonna lie.
Oh man.
I'm a little scared being here.
Like, not gonna lie.
Wait, there's a Hawkeye.
He's frozen behind me.
I don't wanna look at him.
Wait, where?
He's right here, he's right here!
Oh!
No!
I couldn't do anything!
Oh, it's third!
No!
Mr. Fister!
Guys, don't say that.
I don't think they're willing to play with me for 16 hours.
I think he'll leave.
This group will leave by then.
Guys, I'm just gonna ELO terrorize them for like, until they're done with me.
No!
Alright.
Alright, I'm dancing!
I'm dancing!
Here.
I'm dead.
Oh my god, he never missed!
What does Mr. Fister play?
What's my rank now?
I'm down 10 points.
If that sort of tells you what's going on right now.
If that gives you an indication of what my life is like at the moment.
Guys, I have a feeling that Mr. Fister might not be a Wolverine.
Yeah, I...
Come on.
Maybe he'd get our ass off, Wolverine.
As he gets nobody with it.
Oh my god, he got his first fucking grab!
I love how he's like...
We literally saw him get nobody and then we're like, maybe it's time to retire.
The Wolverine.
What is he without the fisting?
Okay, Mr. Fister.
Okay, no longer does.
There's a stranger just running at me from behind.
The gorilla man, there's no way I just heard you say, I got wild.
Like, they have no dude, brother, it's your own world!
I got walled by my own teammate!
I don't even have a crit!
What are you saying?
Please don't die trying to heal.
It's winnable, it's winnable.
Oh, I'm going in.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they have a stranger Hawkeye.
There it is.
Oh my god.
I'm trying.
There's someone behind us too!
Wait, you're focusing on me?
You're full HP.
There's a Mantis right behind us.
We stay here, we stay here.
I have a plan, I have a plan.
And it's D.Va's, it's D.Va's, it's D.Va's.
I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan, I have a plan.
Here's my plan, here's my plan.
Oh my god!
I got a kill, I got a kill, it was all me.
Let's go, let's go!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, that...
Okay, I...
I got walled with you, me.
They told us that Groot is our own Groot.
But...
Oh!
Oh, Mr. Fister, you're living.
Okay, three, two, one.
Please.
I'm heal boosting for you.
Oh no!
We saw another fight.
Mr. Fister, I think you need to make sure you're not Wolverine.
I'm glad you swapped out Wolverine.
I got you.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Nice!
Oh my god, they're doing it!
They're doing it!
It's legendary!
Oh my god, he's doing it!
He is great!
Like, Wolverine was...
I don't...
I don't think...
Guys, who would have thought...
Having claws while fisting is not great.
It's not like... it's not...
Who would have thought that...
You shouldn't have claws while you're fisting.
I mean, it could help too.
I can!
Exactly.
She gets it.
Okay, okay.
Wait, what?
I did not say that.
Is this fine?
That's a punch-up muncher right there.
Punch-up muncher?
Oh, my fault.
See?
I guess we all agree.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
I'm so scared, I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
Wait, chill.
Chill, chill, chill.
Just chill, chill.
Wait, what the fuck?
I got pushed instantly.
That's what I'm saying.
I was so good.
Why is he back?
You can't leave the fisting life, guys.
You don't understand.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, my God.
I soloed him, I soloed him.
Oh, my God, he did it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, this is scary because there's a Hawkeye just fucking looking at me right now.
This is so scary.
This is actually so scary.
Oh, my God.
No, Mr. Fister!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
That's awkward.
Get off it, get off it, get off it.
Okay, that's good enough.
Get off it, get off it right now.
I'm gonna go left side.
If you can play like a boss or something here, it'll make me so happy.
How did it die?
Here, here, here.
Nice.
Oh, it's gone, it's gone.
I have... oh, no, I couldn't do anything.
Wait, did he swap up?
Oh, now he's on path.
I don't understand.
He was so good at Hawkeye.
He's not playing every Fister character possible.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're stopping.
I got you, bro.
I got you.
Bro, I don't got you.
I got you, bro.
Don't worry, bro.
He's got you.
Oh, my God.
He's got you, bro.
Here,
here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, my God.
I'm asleep.
No.
If you guys survive, I have ult.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
Three, two, one.
It's gone.
I have Hawkeye on me.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I think banning Fister was the...
I think Mr. Fister got a little...
Yo, Fister.
Guys,
who paid off Mr. Fister?
Who was it?
Who was it in chat?
Who paid him off?
Who paid off Mr. Fister?
Who was it?
Not me.
Sorry, I got his name wrong.
Who the fuck was it?
He was an inside.
I refuse to believe he was not an inside job.
I refuse to believe that.
It was Marvel.
It wasn't Spider-Man, that fucking menace.
I actually have no idea of the lore behind Iron Fist.
I have no idea who he is, other than the fact that he likes to punch.
What I like about Marvel Rivals is that they are introducing a lot of characters that are normally not popular in the Marvel Universe.
That's what I like about it.
He's rich.
I mean, that's like...
That's like majority of these fucking... except for Peter Parker.
Thank God he's broke.
Fucking menace to society.
Whoever did it, I'm laughing.
Wow!
That's right.
He deserves it.
That's why he's broke.
Camera boy is broke as fuck.
That's right.
I was gonna say something really fucked up, but like...
Alright,
this is a joke.
I don't actually mean it, but like...
But like...
That's what he gets for being a photographer.
For trying to make a hobby a career.
Should've got a real job.
That's right.
You should've got a real fucking job, Peter Parker.
Travis Clippet.
He's a sa- It depends on which Peter Parker lore you're trying to look at.
Cause like, in one instance, he's just a photographer for a newspaper, which is a dying media.
Peter Parker, you're a fucking idiot.
That's what you get for trying to be a photographer in a dying media.
Just fucking be a blogger.
These have been some of the most cursed games.
You know what's funny?
Mace was like, don't worry, it's gonna be so easy.
Six wins, let's go.
I'm sorry.
I warned him.
It was never gonna be easy.
I told him it won't be easy.
It was rigged from the start.
Mace walked into the hole.
He did.
I wish people moved just like these bots.
Then I'd definitely be top 500.
Doom Q.
I'm not dooming anymore, I've accepted my fate.
I've accepted my place in the world.
Always chasing the dream.
Never achieving it.
Just the way it is.
If I get it, it'll just be a very pleasant surprise.
Evolved Control Q.
I wanna say this is a really fucked up joke, but I'm really worried that they'll take offense to it.
For legal reasons.
To my stack who may or may not be watching this stream right now.
It's a joke.
I swear to god.
I just thought it's a funny joke.
Please, it's not personal.
But...
Sorry, I was hesitating.
Disclaimer, this is just a joke.
But...
They're used to losing, so what's one more loss?
It's a joke!
They won the last two tournaments!
I thought it's a joke!
Stack, leave now.
Leave her now.
Clip it, clip it.
It's just kicked from, removed from the stack.
Yeah, the stack is done.
Please!
It's just a joke!
I put 400 disclaimers!
Wow, you're gonna end up being solo ulted by an entire team.
You didn't have to do it to them.
They're really good players!
They won the other two tournaments!
Well, like two of them did.
Sorry, I need to stop.
I need to stop.
I'm sorry.
The twitch in me is coming up.
What?
Doki, why did you keep digging the hole?
Stop doubling down, Doki!
Doki doesn't stop digging.
No, you don't even have to send it to the enemy team.
You send it to my own team.
I'm literally sabotaging my own stack.
Stop kidding.
It's okay, I'm reformed now.
Now I'll lock in, guys.
I'm gonna lock in right now.
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
This time, I realized.
Guys, I literally don't know what happened to my OBS.
I don't know how to end my stream.
I think I actually have to force quit my stream.
Just to actually be able to end my stream.
Wait, what?
Wait, you're chilling.
Wait, it's you.
Who's you?
Can you restart it?
I don't have my OBS anymore.
It, like, disappeared.
It actually disappeared everywhere, but, like, background process.
It's still in my background processes, but, like, it's just gone everywhere else.
So I have to, like, force quit.
I literally have to force quit my OBS on Task Manager.
It's gone!
I'm looking through Task Manager, and it doesn't exist in, like, regular apps.
It's not, it's, like, not, and then when I click OBS, when I click OBS, there, it's, like, you already have OBS open.
Do you want to launch another?
And then I'm, like, what?
No, what do you mean?
Where is it?
Oh yeah, I heard they're nerfing Hawkeye and Hela.
Thank fucking god.
Yeah, there's nothing on my tray.
At all.
I couldn't.
I can't bring it back to the foreground.
It doesn't exist.
I don't know how.
I don't know how, how, uh...
We had Mr. Fister, and it was... He did really well in Hawkeye!
He was really good as Hawkeye, though.
I don't know what happened.
He got a little too silly.
I think the Wolverine's coming for us.
I'm a little weird.
Oh, shit.
Oh,
what?
Where did I get hit?
What?
Oh my god, he's insane!
That was a crazy snipe.
Holy fuck.
This is why I always ban Hawkeye.
This is exactly why.
I fucking never trust anybody to be like, let's leave Hawkeye open.
Let's just leave it open.
What's the worst that could happen, you know?
What's the worst that could possibly happen?
I'm gonna get sniped.
I can feel it.
I can feel myself get sniped.
Oh my god.
I thought I had to use that.
Oh my god, this is scary.
I'm like, I don't know where the Hawkeye is.
I'm so scared.
I'm actually so scared.
I don't know where the Hawkeye is.
I'm so scared.
I
don't know.
I'm so scared.
I'm...
Where is he?
I died to him once.
I don't want it to happen to me again.
Where'd he go?
Woah.
Here.
What?!
Why is it always me?!
I can't... I saw... He wasn't... I was like, oh he's not looking at me.
I'll fucking come out of the room.
I'll... I'll come out of the room!
I never... I got a bit cocky there.
I legitimately looked because I thought he wasn't looking at me anymore.
So I thought I was safe, but you're never safe.
You're never safe.
You always have to fear.
Just fear.
Just always fear.
Like, never... never believe in anything.
Just...
Never!
Just never!
Never believe again!
Always be paranoid!
Always think they're out to get you!
Always think the government is always watching you!
Never turn your face around!
Magneto said, psych!
The government is always watching!
Never think you're safe!
No!
3, 2, 1...
What?!
Ow!
I got headshot.
Oh my god!
I'm just gonna track everything.
Fuck it.
Fear!
It's not me.
That's fine.
Not the moon.
It's not just me.
I'm sorry, Kurova.
I'm just happy it's not just me.
I'm...
Sorry.
That's a lot.
I'm sorry.
It didn't lose us the game at least.
You know, that's all that matters.
That's all that matters.
At last!
It's not just...
There's a Starlord above.
I have to reload.
I'm just happy.
Oh, at least the Magneto targets other healers.
You know?
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
No, I'm just healing.
Just heal!
That's fine.
He never misses, guys.
And I don't want to be there for it.
3, 2, 1.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
He fumbled it.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Oh, thank fucking god.
I don't think they've never played...
My stack might have had the fucking hardest games of their lives trying to play with me.
They might have just played a tournament, but this might be the hardest thing they've ever done.
This could be it.
This could be the hardest thing they've ever tried to do.
Playing with me is the training, wait.
If they can survive playing with Toad Keeper, they can win the next tournament.
They're like, this is just gonna be a casual fun time, right everybody?
Suddenly sweats their fucking ass off.
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Don't forget, securing the mission area is crucial.
If they're truly top 100 in the world, then they should be able to do this.
Here they come.
It's Kurova.
What?
Wait, I'm...
Oh...
Guys, what the...
What was that?
I'm so confused.
Why couldn't I fit the door?
Sorry, Luna's too dumpy.
You all saw it.
You all saw what I saw.
What was that?
I literally was so confused.
I was like, what happened?
Was my dumpy too thick?
Too thick.
That was the weirdest TP of my fucking life.
Like, everybody else entered the TP.
They're like, what happened?
What the fuck happened?
Okay, hey guys.
There's like a Starlord raid on...
Whoa.
We got too thick.
Yay!
You must be skilled to use...
Does anyone have a clip of that?
Like...
Like, does anyone have a...
Someone give me a clip of that.
That was such a fucking...
I walked straight.
Legitimately, like, what happened?
I'm like, huh?
Can we get a replay of that?
Yeah, I'm looking at this clip.
I need to know what the fuck happened.
I'm like...
I'm walking straight.
Like, what's going on?
It's like, you cannot enter.
I guess I must just do a thing.
Like, what the fuck?
Literally just walked in.
They're like, we know you're not.
You don't deserve to be...
We found a YouTuber.
They're like, you can...
This portal is only accessible to all the real Twitch streamers out there.
And then they found out.
They knew.
I wasn't worthy enough.
Why is everybody so mean to me?
The dibs almost got me.
What's up, you're back.
I'm gonna use the bathroom, guys.
I'm back.
And I got myself a banana!
I need to make sure I eat these bananas.
Because I keep...
The last time I bought a banana, I forgot about...
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna give you guys some girl fail right now.
I'm trying to remember to eat my bananas.
Because the last time I got a banana, I forgot about it.
And you know what happens when you forget about you having bananas?
They go...
Yeah, they go bad.
Have you ever seen a bad banana?
I didn't realize you can turn black.
I forgot I had bananas.
No, I forgot.
I had it, like, stored in this corner.
And I forgot about it.
I legitimately forgot about these bananas.
So, like, I bought groceries, like, three days ago.
And I was like, gotta remember to eat these bananas this time.
I didn't smell.
I couldn't...
To be fair, my nose...
Um, I don't have COVID.
I just, um...
My nose, for smelling, isn't that good.
So, like...
I can smell...
I do often smell, like, some scents.
But I can't catch it, as well as other...
I can't, like...
In terms of, like, an average person.
So, like...
And this is, like, really strong.
So, like, I didn't smell any of the...
The...
I didn't smell the fucking rotten banana.
So...
Um...
No, it's...
You know how I know it was...
By the way, the black is still good?
Um...
Not when it melted out of the fucking banana peel!
It melted out of the banana.
So, I knew it was bad, bad.
I...
That's definitely a really bad banana.
But I'm okay now.
Now I'm eating my bananas, cause I...
No, it's cause I forgot!
I forgot I bought bananas, cause I stuffed it in a corner.
So, I forgot about it.
And then, like...
And then I noticed...
I was like, what is that over there?
I was like, oh yeah, fuck, those are the bananas I bought.
And I was like...
Oh, fuck.
And then...
I was like...
I picked up the...
The most fucked up part...
Is that...
It was in a plastic bag.
You know?
Cause when you get bananas, you put it in a plastic bag, right?
Like you would do.
It melted through the plastic bag.
Cause I thought nothing was wrong.
I thought nothing was wrong with my bananas.
I was just like, oh, it's just old, so I'm just gonna throw that bag away.
I picked it up.
And then there was like, brown sludge at the bottom.
And I was like, oh, it's bad, bad.
It's bad, bad.
It went through the bag.
I don't even...
Like, I don't even know how the...
Why is Karoma's item targeted so hard?
I feel like every time I watch Karoma stream, he gets to play Adam.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with my...
Yeah, I feel like...
How come every time I watch his streams, he gets to play Adam?
And now that he's playing with me, he doesn't get to play Adam.
Well, you see, dude.
I'm joking.
There's one main factor in all of this.
Okay.
Alright, me too, but that's okay.
That's alright, me too, but that's okay.
No, we're not playing Rocky Raccoon.
I'd rather cut off my head than play Rocky Raccoon.
Because even with my hands cut off, I can still play that character.
Oh yeah, speaking of Rocky Raccoon.
One of the Rocky Raccoon players I, like, fucking roasted.
But it was not him.
It's just in general.
I just hate all Raccoon players.
So it's...
It's not...
It's technically not targeted.
It's literally me just hating a specific group of people.
So he's not...
It's like I hate all of them.
So...
It doesn't make it better.
But I just need him to know that.
But, like, he added me.
He...
He added me.
So...
Sorry, not people.
A certain group of rodents.
I think that makes me sound a little better.
I just realized that sounded really bad.
But, like, a particular group of rodents.
Um, anyway.
So, he added me on Marvel Rivals.
But, like, it was right aft...
It was, like, a day after.
So I think he watched the stream.
And he wants to know, like, what the fuck is wrong with me.
They're not!
They're raccoons!
They're not even real!
They're not even real raccoons!
Oh...
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh...
This is bad.
I mean, we're even.
Nevermind.
Like...
I don't know what's going on.
I'm going to help with this.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
I am ready to put on a show!
Feel better?
Oh my god.
We are undefeated!
Do it!
Yeah!
Oh.
Not yeah.
Yeah!
That's right!
I'm happy.
I saw him use...
I saw him hit that mantis.
He has no fear for you.
Oh.
That's not what I wanted him to target.
I wanted him to hit...
Whoa!
I can't...
That's not cool.
That's not cool at all.
There's a...
There's a train just walking up to me.
My god.
Why did they let him walk up to me like that?!
They just let it happen!
I was like, guys, he's walking up to me very slowly.
Very fucking slowly.
Oh my god.
Miffy, you guys can, like, do something?
Maybe.
Maybe they heard you.
No, guys.
Guys.
Strange.
I'm like, guys.
Guys, he's walking up to me.
Guys.
Fuck me, I guess.
He's not good in high elo.
Like, he's not...
Like, everybody prefers Mantis Luna.
Because if the enemy team has Mantis Luna, it's just like...
It favors...
It favors the enemy team more than your own team.
Sacrificing...
Sacrificing two defensive ults.
Emmie, thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you, thank you.
Rabbit, thank you for the tier one.
Dish, thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you, thank you.
That's alright.
And now we have a Wolverine.
It'll be different, right?
It'll be so different.
Now we get to watch...
I don't...
I don't know about that.
Our games have been...
Our games have been pretty...
Wait.
I need help here.
I slept Wolverine, I slept Wolverine.
Oh.
I'm ult... I'm ulting this?
Come on!
He's so... Oh my god, he's so low!
He doesn't see me here, right?
Guess I gotta go down here.
Which one?
I slept him, I slept him.
I don't have leaves, I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That was scary.
That was... Like, what happened?
What happened?
I don't even know what fucking happened.
I slept him, I slept him.
He'll be fine.
Oh my god.
It's fine, everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
It's okay.
We're... I feel so healthy.
I'm damage boosted to you?
Fight him!
Wait, they're on point, they're on point.
They're on point.
I slept somebody.
I'm ulting, oh no!
Oh my god, I got my ult off too!
How?!
Where did he go?!
What the f- I lost my ult, I'm so sad.
I should've feared, I should've feared.
I don't know why I thought I could do it.
The one time I stopped fearing...
The one time, the one time I stopped fearing, of course.
Oh my god, I saw that, that was crazy.
That's actually crazy.
What the fuck is wrong with you?!
Like...
Oh my god, what is wrong with-
You're nothing!
I need to start fearing more, guys.
I need to...
The one time, I was like, things will be okay, right?
Things...
Things will be okay.
I slept him, I slept him.
I got him.
Oh, wait.
No!
We're well, it's okay.
No, I have to start fearing, guys.
I have to...
I need to start fearing.
Why did I stop fearing?
Why would you stop?
I don't know why!
I don't know!
For one moment of my life, I was like, maybe it's not that bad.
Maybe...
I was just like, maybe...
Maybe things will be okay.
New fear.
Start fearing.
I think they're gonna realize, after playing with me...
They're gonna love their team so much more.
I'm like, I'm like the friendship test.
I'm literally...
This is also what they're like, do you wanna join the discord call?
I was like...
I feel like, you need to let out your frustrations privately.
It might be too hard to pretend you're okay, but I'm like...
Before the session, they're like, do you wanna join the call?
I'm like, hmm...
Maybe it's better if I'm not in the call.
They can say whatever they want privately.
Not in front of an audience.
Yeah.
Dude, they're gonna start drinking because of me.
Yippee!
No, wait, no.
Guys, no.
No yippee.
Guys, I'm not gonna ruin a person's life because of Marvel Rivals.
I'm gonna ruin my own life because of Marvel Rivals.
Guys, no yippee.
No yippee.
Yay, I'm a problem for someone else other than myself.
Let's go!
Let me see that.
Still no stream.
Guys, he has to keep the private frustrations private.
They're worried.
Alright, guys.
Let's make a bet.
Let's make a prediction.
When do you think they'll tap out?
That's fucked up.
I give him four more hours.
Three more games.
Alright, keep me up and I kill them.
When do you think the stack...
When do you think the stack will disband?
We've been playing for four hours and we're fucking...
Holy shit.
It's okay, guys.
What are we betting on?
Alright, let me do a prediction.
I haven't done a prediction in a long time.
Prediction.
Wait, how do I...
How do I do prediction?
Alright, mine.
Prediction.
This is what my prediction is.
The prediction is like...
Prediction.
Do you think they'll tap out or commit to the grind?
And then we'll predict that.
And then the option is they'll tap out.
In three games.
Or like, they'll tap out or they're here for the long haul.
No, no.
We should have predictions.
I know I have one mod awake, I think.
No, prediction.
Bet your fake money.
I want you to bet your fake money.
I want people to go bankrupt.
But like, in-game.
Fictional money.
Not like actual...
Guys, fictional money bankrupt.
I don't want people to actually...
Wait, there's a mantis behind us asleep.
We got mantis.
Come on, Hulk.
Oh, not anymore.
I'm fucking scared of her.
Oh my god, Aaron, thank you for the 100 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, did you guys see that?
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for supporting this.
Thank you so much!
Oh my god, thank you for the 100 gifted!
Even if we don't have ELO gains, at least...
Oh, there's a Namor below me.
Oh, there's Namor!
I got fucking Namor'd!
I was like, what?
What is he doing there?
That's alright.
I traded my life for subs.
Okay, I need to vlog.
I need to not look at chat.
Sorry!
I looked at chat, so I'm sorry, but thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
I can't see you.
It's okay, I'm locked in now.
I don't have a fuse, sir.
He's asleep, Hulk's asleep.
I'm ulting this.
Oh no.
Wait, a stranger just won!
A stranger just won!
I got you.
Oh no, I don't got you.
Oh no.
I slept him.
Whoa!
I got you.
Iron Man's low.
Oh my god!
Okay, did we make the prediction?
I don't know.
Is my mod?
Okay, we did not.
Alright, I'll make a prediction.
Alright, how do I do this again?
Oh my god, I have to actually do my own...
I have to run my own channel?
I have to...
How long do you think we have until Stacks taps out?
Okay, do you think the Stacks will survive?
They will tap out?
They are in it...
They are in it until top 500?
Alright, I'll make the pull 5 minutes.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, it's like I'm a streamer, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm like...
I slept the Hulk behind us.
Damage boost!
You're so low!
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best to keep you up!
This is a little bit scary.
We're all...
All in on tap out.
Damn, people lying on the internet like that?
Oh my god.
Am I taking this?
That's fine.
Oh my god.
He's mad, he's mad!
Let's go, let's go!
He's mad!
He's so mad!
There we go.
Oh my god, he's so mad.
He's so mad!
Jesus Christ.
Is he still mad?
I'm trying to keep you up!
Will!
There we go.
Wait, Hulk.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Believe!
Would be funny if they just disband right after this game.
That would be pretty silly.
Oh my god.
Where's our fucking Iron Man?
I always have to keep track of him.
That would be pretty silly.
I'm locked in though.
I'm trying my fucking best.
It's just he he ha ha's jokes, you know?
No you don't!
Oh yes you do!
Yes you do!
Oh my god!
No!
Don't be angry!
Oh my god, I'm trying to look at him.
Damage boost!
That's right!
Now he's angry!
Yeah!
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
Oh he's one!
Oh my god!
Oh no, he's smashing!
You're so alive!
Woman!
But women aren't real, so she's not alive.
Let's go.
We did it!
Oh my god, another win.
We definitely lost at the next game.
Oh my god!
I think my stack is going crazy.
I think they're going crazy.
They're like, win, loss, win, loss, win, loss.
You see, this is my life, so I'm like not, like, I'm like used to it now.
I don't think they're used to it.
They're like high ELO pro players, so they're used to having win streak.
But now they know what it's like to play in my fucking lobby.
They know what it's like in my ELO hell.
So much.
They're in my world.
Hey guys.
Okay, I think they all have...
Wait, let's see.
You can tell when they started playing with me.
Okay, wait.
Let's see if they're...
Apparently, they keep their...
Okay, you can see.
Guys, when do you think they started playing with...
Okay, not this part.
There's...
Okay.
What do you think, guys?
When do you think they started playing with me?
I see...
I see confetti.
Hey guys.
This is when they were playing by themselves.
Playing with each other.
And this is when they started playing.
You know how like in Valorant, people are aiming for the green carpet?
This is called the gray carpet.
The striped carpet.
The gray...
No, it's not even fully gray.
It's like striped.
Correlation does not equal causation.
The beige carpet.
It's like the zebra print.
It's the fucking zebra print.
This is it.
There's some yellow in there.
There's some yellow.
It's fine.
There's like a couple of yellow in there.
The tiger stripes.
It's kinda ugly.
It's like my tiger print.
But like the tiger has like...
It's albino.
It's like my albino tiger.
That's basically it.
It's fine.
Quit the game.
You're gonna make them quit the game.
I'm gonna make them all retire.
Yo, what's up, mace?
Play with Dookie is like...
It's like an assignment.
What's that supposed to mean?
Is that supposed to be positive?
What did you do?
I can't tell.
It can be positive if you want it to be.
Who on their team is...
Spank.
Sorry.
I'm sorry, Fullmetal Ants.
I'm sorry.
I think he's like...
Who's on this team that's streaming?
I saw the ban, Strange.
I did it.
And then two other people did not vote.
Including your fucking duo, man.
I'm not banning anymore.
I think you need to start blocking your team.
Where are these bans?
It's called going to the Marvel Rivals category and seeing the front page.
That's what my bans are.
Wait, Adam...
Wait, he can finally play Adam!
We did it, guys!
After six games!
Oh my god.
We finally did it!
There he is.
Who's target banning my Penny?
Oh, I have a C!
Not anymore.
That's my ban.
I didn't realize.
It starts in five seconds.
I got a little too excited.
Guys, just...
Oh no.
No, they have Hawkeye.
No.
Oh no.
I really wish you banned Hela.
We wish a lot of things, guys.
We just will.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I froze him.
Oh my god.
How did we lose both?
Oh.
Wait, we did ban Hela or Hawkeye?
What happened?
How did we let Hela and Hawkeye through?
What kind of lobby?
How did we let them both through?
What?
That's crazy that happened.
That's actually crazy that we let both of them happen.
This is like the dream lobby right there.
It's literally the dream.
Wait, what?
What?
What happened?
Wait, I have a...
I have a...
What?
Wait.
What happened?
Did I specifically get DDoSed?
Like,
what was that?
That was crazy.
Like, I literally don't know what that was.
Fear,
fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Let me freaking go.
Here we go!
That was the one ping.
Like, what was that?
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I'm like so confused as to what happened there.
I don't know what happened.
I'm still like...
We won that fight!
Like, how did we win that fight?
Okay, I'm freaking locking in.
That was actually crazy.
That was so freaking crazy.
I did not know how that happened.
No, like the lag there.
Did my stream lag or was it just the server?
Like...
It was just me, yeah.
That was so weird.
I was like...
Bubble beam.
I have a Venom on me.
I didn't freeze him.
He's looking for me!
Oh my god!
I forgot I have C.
I forgot I have C again.
That's my bad.
I keep forgetting I have E.
There's no one on the left.
It's the last.
I keep forgetting.
I'm pushing the cart.
Let's go.
Push it, push it, push it, push it.
Oh my god, no way.
Oh my god, Kuroba playing Adam is like a whole different player.
It's actually crazy.
It's crazy!
When you can...
When they can play...
Here.
I'm alive!
I have a Venom on me.
Yes!
Guys, there's still a Venom.
What do you mean there's still a Venom?
There's still a Venom!
Venom!
C!
Fucking C!
I forgot about C again.
Guys, I'm gonna remember C this time.
This time.
I never play with an Iron Fist, so it's like so...
It like fucks with me.
I need to remember I have C.
Okay.
Here we go.
No!
No, I tried to keep him up!
I pressed C though!
I pressed it!
I actually did it!
I did it, guys.
I pressed C.
No.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The bright heroes could make all the difference.
Listen.
I mean, can you really blame me?
Yes.
This game is entirely your fault.
You cannot blame the 25% chance on me.
What makes you think that's true?
You've been playing this game for how long?
I want to ask you.
I actually need to know.
What about it?
How do you find Strange a bad character to go against?
It's possibly like the most common thing you ever go against and you don't like it.
Yeah.
It's all falling apart.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
You can blame that on me all you want.
That's fine.
But we still have two people that vote.
The girls are fighting.
Guys, the girls are fighting.
What do I do?
I'm about to get mad.
Please stop fighting.
I don't want to watch my family get into force in front of me.
Wait, I have venom on me.
Frozen.
Please,
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Don't get into force, mom.
Dad.
Don't.
Please.
Please don't get into force.
He's rude.
He lied.
He lied about the bubble.
Oh no.
Are they gonna be okay?
Yeah, they are.
What are we gonna do with it?
I'm sorry.
I can't help you.
Thank God.
Thank you.
I got the...
It's so easy.
If you just stop dying.
I can't touch my ball.
We can touch.
Yeah, we touch.
Stop.
Dad.
Stop fighting.
I know I'm overreacting.
Never miss.
Please stop fighting.
Mom's dead.
I'll come back.
Just chill.
Please don't kill me.
Where's the venom?
Venom one.
I'm gonna be a child of the force.
Live on stream.
He died again.
They're gonna kick our little...
My big older brother out of the house.
Cause he's not pink.
He turned 18 and they're not paying rent anymore.
And then mom and dad are gonna blame it on each other.
Saying you're the one that coddled him.
And that's why he's a deadbeat.
And then...
And then I have to pick who to live with.
But I don't.
But I'm gonna get two Christmases.
Two Christmases.
I'm ulting for you.
No more ult in three seconds.
This is the last fight.
I trade, I trade, I trade.
Two Christmases, let's go!
Venom's on cart.
Venom, no passive.
I fucking hate you two.
I hate you both.
I hate both of you.
No!
What is happening?
Two Christmases!
Yippee!
Yay!
We're still crashing out.
Pause it, let's go.
I think Supersteam was much more stable than whatever the fuck I was going through.
I think, I think, I think Supersteam...
There's no way Supersteam was like as destructive as my team.
There's no fucking way out of this.
I don't even know.
I don't...
I don't know.
Hahaha.
No shot.
There's no way their team had to go through what I just went through in that game.
There's no way.
Super is sitting head and hands in despair.
I felt that.
That was my team in general.
They were like, they were this close to dropping slurs.
I think...
Hahaha.
My team was this close.
Honestly fair.
Bro, we didn't even have that.
We had Iron Fist.
It literally was like we didn't, we almost didn't even have Hella.
We almost, we almost didn't even have a Hella.
This is the power of toxicity.
Yay.
Oh, he's taking it out.
Hahaha.
Okay.
I did not expect that.
Valid.
That's valid.
Not gonna lie.
That was, that was valid.
I fucking can't.
The way he looked at me.
That was...
You weren't supposed to see that.
He's...
Oh my god.
That dude's crazy.
He's on the list.
That Iron Fist is definitely on the list now.
There's no way.
He looked at me.
He was like, this isn't what it looks like.
I swear.
The secret is safe with us, right guys?
The secret is safe with us.
Don't tell anyone.
He's still going at it.
He has to let it out.
We saw nothing, guys.
We don't know where the body is buried.
We weren't there.
Body?
What body?
It's funny that I mention a body when he's a missing person.
Sorry, I meant like...
I have no idea where he went.
Last time I saw him was in this Marvel Rivals map.
Last time I saw him was in Shibuya.
Where we're having like...
Jeez, I won't...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Anyway, the last time we saw Mr...
What's his name?
Who was it?
The last time we saw Mr. Fatback.
He was...
We were having a nice family dinner in Shibuya.
And like...
Not gonna lie, they were...
I think they were like bonding and stuff.
Whatever.
He's letting it all out.
He's letting it...
Yeah, but that was like...
That was like, you know...
I saw him like last week, you know?
It was last week.
Bro is venting right now.
They're not crashing out, guys.
They're not gonna tap out, chat.
They're not gonna tap out.
Everything will be fine.
What is the percent...
Actually, what is the percentage of it?
Of the prediction?
How do I check?
How do I check my prediction?
Does anyone know what the percentage was?
Like...
Of like people who think they're gonna give up versus they're here for the long grind.
Anyone saw the percentage?
That is 44 to...
Do you real...
You guys...
Wow, you guys really believe.
I can't believe...
56% of you guys really believe.
That's crazy.
I believe but I chose to tap out.
It's alright, guys.
Guys, we broke the streak.
We're finally...
For...
After...
Four and a half hour...
After four hours, everyone.
We're finally up a game.
It just took four hours.
Look.
It's all about the end result.
Not how...
Not the journey, guys.
Not the journey.
Holy song.
See?
Someone was like, I picked the wrong option.
I picked the wrong...
I picked the wrong option, guys.
I believe.
It's okay.
We're gonna make it, everybody.
We're gonna make it.
I believe, guys.
We need 250 and we're at 120 something.
We're so close, guys.
So close.
We're almost there.
We need 100 something.
We're so close.
Can you teach me the ways of what?
God.
Just don't be a pro player.
Honestly, just don't be a pro player.
That's the only way.
Pros are never happy.
I'm sorry to tell you this.
Why do you think they all retire and go to Variety?
I don't think I've ever met a happy pro.
I'm gonna be honest.
I really am.
You only become happy if you win in a tournament.
I don't think a lot of pro players aren't happy playing ranked for long hours.
I was gonna say.
You're only happy at being number one.
Other than that, just stream.
I think I'd be a lot sadder if I wasn't streaming.
Because at least you guys can all laugh with me at how ridiculous our games were.
At least you guys can all laugh with me.
It's happiness and positivity.
We're in this together.
We're all in this together, guys.
I'm sorry, Gobus.
I'm so sorry.
What hero do you think you want to be today?
I'm Luna Snow.
For those who missed out, he was like, Derky, can you teach me the ways of laughing at pain?
I'm sorry I'm laughing at your pain.
I'm sorry.
Alright.
I believe in my team to ban people.
Hello!
Tough.
Sidelock.
We're not gonna ban.
Oh, hello?
Okay.
I'm gonna contribute!
I did it!
I contribute to a ban and I'm not trolling.
Oh.
Goodbye, Adam.
Mo and Krill?
Oh yeah, there's Mo and Krill.
He's top 500.
I saw him on the leaderboard.
Why ban Mang?
I don't know.
Thank god.
Fuck me.
No more
fear.
That's right.
I'm here for the anti-immune resistance.
They are a menace to society.
They think they're better than us because...
Because their DNA is just a little different?
True.
How dare they think they're better than us.
How dare they.
The DNA stops now.
Toki Puli.
Sounds like an okay striker.
Stop acting like a Twitch streamer.
What is that?
Alright.
Everything is fine.
Wait, am I solo heal?
I can solo heal this.
Don't worry.
Alright.
I can solo heal this.
Please, I'm going through it right now.
There's someone to our left.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, there he goes.
He goes again.
Guys, I think...
Guys, it's fine.
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Will we be fine?
When he never misses?
Oh, that's fine.
Will we be fine, guys?
Where's the Hawkeye?
What happened to me?
Wait, who's win trading?
Who's win trading?
Who the fuck is...
I have no idea who's win trading.
Who is it?
Goodbye.
Bye.
Oh my god, what's going on?
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
We're so healthy.
We're standing in a line.
Oh my...
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
Things were not fine, guys.
Things were not fine.
What?
Guys, things will be fine.
Alright, here I go.
Here we go.
Yippee!
Let's hope I don't get Hawkeye!
Oh.
That's...
Oh!
I don't feel safe.
Remember what you said about me earlier?
Wolverine?
Why does this always happen to me?
Every time I...
Why does this not always happen to me?
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The right heroes can make all the difference.
What is...
Yo, I got here.
I'm playing DPS.
What's going on?
What's going...
Who the fuck is Window?
Is that...
What?
Now I'm part of some fucking drama.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I'm just...
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh wait, that's the rank one.
Isn't that?
How the fuck did I get here?
I'm just a little guy.
I'm in some...
Smiling wave, everybody.
I'm just a little...
A small guy.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll win the next one.
How do I...
How do I counter this?
I thought this was a con...
Oh, this is...
I'm trying, bro.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on?
He sounds so...
Don't worry, guys.
I'm trying.
I'm just a little guy.
How did we get here?
Sorry, I broke that.
That was my fault.
I broke his only platform.
We were locked out.
What's going on, guys?
Why can't we be friends?
Here we go.
Let's be friends together, everyone.
Let's be friends.
Oh my god!
What happened?
What the fuck?
What is going on?
We waited for the right moment.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Things aren't looking grand.
I left.
I think I would've made it worse if I say anything.
I think I would've made it worse.
Guys, now you know why a lot of pro players are depressed.
Now you know.
What is he angry about?
I don't think he's okay.
I don't know what to do.
Look, he can't...
Guys, look.
This is his therapy right now.
I've played these games before.
Damn.
Guys, he's crashing out.
Guys, my team's crashing out.
Guys.
And then we'll never see them again.
Guys, I don't think they're gonna invite me again.
Guys.
I think this is the last time I'll ever see them again.
After this stream, remove.
List.
Avoid.
Get your therapy.
Again!
They're like...
Mace, what did you...
Mace, I thought you said it'll only take six games, Mace.
I thought...
I thought you said...
I thought you...
It's so hard!
No!
They do me!
They're gonna tap out!
No!
He wants to go again.
But there's a...
That's a third option!
That's a secret third option!
What I mean tomorrow.
It continues.
Wait!
I gotta fight it back!
Guys, it's not over yet!
This prediction lasts until tomorrow.
Guys, we're holding your points hostage until tomorrow.
We won't get you top five.
We're gonna hold your points hostage.
Then we'll see if they tap out.
They don't hate me!
Oh hey, there's them again.
They don't hate me, guys!
I can.
I'm pretty sure I can.
I think they just hate your Qs.
Guys, they don't hate me!
That's a win!
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
Keep talking, bro.
You're good.
What's going on?
They don't hate you as a person.
They just hate me in game.
That's different.
They just don't hate me in game.
I mean, they do hate me in game.
But they just hate me.
But they don't hate me off game.
Cora, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Super happy, thank you for the tier one sub for nine months.
They hate the idea of Doki.
Alright, what are these rows?
Jesus, if I'm not good, what are you, bro?
Fourth place?
You're one place above!
Fourth place talking to the fifth place.
Sure, that's gonna happen.
Yeah, and guess who put you there?
Me!
Sure, that's gonna happen ever again, bro.
Like, I have zero problem with you freaks, but you're just hard win trading.
Nad, to get rank one back.
Window plays pp, it's so funny.
Lol, no one is win trading.
He throws our games, that's why.
Yeah, for sure, bro.
Oh, it does more?
Holy shit, how long were they typing when I scrolled up?
He solo'd the amount of games Window has thrown on our team.
Look at his profile.
You don't even know.
I'd love to, but it's private.
He's a troll, plays DPS.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, bro, we're private cause win trading.
I knew it, clip it.
Definitely not cause of scrims.
Holy shit, it's still going.
That's an entire novel.
How did it still keep going?
I was not expecting it to still go on.
I thought it ended.
And then I kept scrolling down.
I was like, it's still going?
Jesus Christ.
Oh no.
Catbug!
Cat...
Oh my... you know I'm not gonna waste it.
I'm not gonna waste it.
We were all fucking dead.
I'm not...
I'm not gonna waste that.
That was not... that was not a winnable fight.
No Groot.
He wants to be Groot.
I am Groot.
Oh my god, he's like right behind us.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
He's ruining.
How's it going?
I'm okay.
But my...
But my stack is...
They're feeling my...
I think they might need therapy.
I'm not sure yet though.
I'm not sure yet.
They might need therapy.
I'm having the time of my life.
Am I frozen?
I'm having a great time.
I wanna say I made new friends, but I can't tell.
Oh shit.
I can't tell yet.
We can't either.
It's so true.
I can't tell.
Wait, there's a Hawkeye above.
I got him off the platform.
He's like to your right.
Wait, oh.
How is he still alive?
Okay, there you go.
I was gonna say.
Wow.
How the fuck was he still alive?
I leave.
Jarvis implode your stacks.
I imploded my stack by my sheer existence.
Yay!
Say no more.
I hear someone above us.
Can't see you.
I pulled in the Wolverine.
Come on.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna die for this.
What?
Wait, we're... What?
Alright, we ulted after we all died.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I was gonna say.
I'm just gonna... I held it because...
I held it because like it wasn't winnable.
I didn't think it was gonna be winnable.
I wanna say... I just wanted to like hold that.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm alive.
Bye.
Okay.
Alright.
I was like, I'm alive?
What's up?
Frozen Wolverine.
No passive.
Alright, here we go.
I'm looking for fall.
Oh.
Alright.
I have no idea where this moon is.
I...
Oh.
I'm gonna get you.
I got you.
I don't got you.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I didn't know I was on damage.
Go.
Oh my god.
I didn't... Okay.
We still... It was so intentional.
We won that because I was on damage.
Guys, if I... Guys, all I'm saying was like if I wasn't on damage, we would have lost that.
We got like literally two picks because of it.
Guys.
Like...
We literally... We got two picks because I was on damage.
It was... It was so intentional.
Hundred percent.
Hawkeye to the top left.
Protect me.
I'm portaling off their spawn.
I have to reload.
Oh no.
I portaled off their spawn.
Stand point.
I fucked up a portal on the right.
The root can't come out.
There's people to the left.
Stand point.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's not okay anymore.
He's frozen.
Oh, this is the last fight.
This is the last fight.
I'm like one HP.
It's working.
You thought we were... You thought we were losing.
Dude.
Catbug.
Have you... Have you heard or played with any like Iron Fist players at all?
Yeah.
Why?
Do you want to like stop living after that?
At all?
You know.
Stop breathing.
Anything like that?
You know.
Hurting yourself.
Anything like that?
Are you talking about on my team or the other team?
Well, obviously, if they're on the other team, you're like happy-go-fun.
Right?
But I'm talking about when they're on your team.
Bro, he said he lives Iron Fist.
What was the other one?
Like Fatfuckmuck or whatever?
He's living red.
He's lost it.
He's actually... He's going to do it.
They're kind of stupid as fuck.
What are they coming and doing?
I feel like if they...
My Iron Fist player picks something else and they just feed.
That's the problem.
He's like... Catbug is literally his therapist right now.
He's using Catbug as a therapist.
That's like his...
Fatfuckmuck or whatever his name is.
Fatass.
I don't know.
But he literally just kept going in over and over and over and over and over.
24-7.
What are you doing?
He's trauma dumping.
Yeah,
that's rough, buddy.
That's rough, buddy.
That's actually rough.
He's reliving the game one by one.
I froze him too.
There's a Wolverine top left.
Gotta do it.
Gotta do what you gotta do.
Bro needs a friend.
Bro, he has a friend.
His entire stack is his friends.
And I think I'm cool.
I'm like a plus one.
I need... I need heals.
Oh my god, I still have no ult.
I'm close ult.
I got it.
I got the soldier.
Berserker rage!
Let's go!
Fuck that guy in particular!
Ah!
What is this?
Don't worry about it.
I won't.
What's this?
I'm solo queue this whole shit, bro.
What's he stacking?
Dude, he just has two top 10.
I got one!
Where?
I'm defending myself.
Oh my god!
That man literally was like, how did that guy got top 10?
Again!
Bro!
Dude, it's actually Logan.
Three ults, but again.
Where's my Wolverine?
Don't worry, I got him.
No!
Not again.
How is he still here?
Holy shit, he's still here?
He traveled to a different country!
Oh my god!
What was that?
Actually, what was that?
That was scary.
That was actually scary.
Not gonna lie.
That was so scary.
Oh my god, do you think he's okay?
Guys, I don't think he's okay.
I don't think he's okay.
I think he's dead.
I think he died.
What the fuck?
I froze him!
Oh my god.
What happened?
He chocked.
Yeah.
How did he get out?
How did he get out of there?
I tried so many times to try to get out.
Oh, he's alive.
Wait, there's someone.
There's a Bucky right behind us.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
There's someone to my right.
There's a Bucky.
Watch out, Bucky.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna lose.
I need to reload.
Yeah, I'm gonna loon out now.
Wow.
This is... yeah.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Missed.
No!
Everything is not...
Everything is not okay.
Yeah, they snowballed hard there.
Maybe make sure to have top.
I can go tank.
Oh my god, what is he saying to him?
I'm worried.
I can't...
Oh, I think he said something bad in Korean.
I think...
I think something happened.
Oh no.
Oh bro.
Something happened.
Oh, you really...
Oh no, he pulled out a fucking Korean.
Oh, my stack's crashing out.
It's okay guys, I'm having a good time.
Guys, my stack might not be having the bestest of times, but like...
I think... I love everything.
But like...
I'm glad... I'm glad I'm here to spend...
Spend my grind sessions with my chat.
I'm glad I get the...
I get to spend...
Spend it with you guys.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
That's rough.
I'm actually so worried about getting sniped there.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
What did he get?
Oh...
This is last fight, I think.
I'm a little worried here.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
I need... I need heals too.
Thank you.
Oh, there's a Doc I...
I have to heal.
Oh my god.
You're so healthy everybody.
Everybody, you're so healthy.
You're so healthy.
Guys, I don't think they were healthy.
I don't...
Guys, I don't think...
I don't think they were healthy.
Guys...
I don't think people are healthy.
Maybe not that healthy.
Maybe...
I shine in darkness Hey guys, how's your weekend?
Hey guys, don't we all love Marvel Rivals?
See, this is why.
Guys, how was your weekend, everybody?
I love Marvel Rivals.
I feel like...
I feel like, um, I'm making a lot of friends and um...
I'm having a great time playing and streaming it for my chat and um...
And like even if my my teams are imploding, um...
Like, at least at least I have you guys to keep me company.
So even if they- whoa!
Um...
There's a Wolverine top left.
I'm a little scared too about that Wolverine.
There's a change behind us.
Oh my god!
Um... um... um... um...
I'm so excited to have that vehicle!
Final score.
Three, two, four.
What happened?
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Just a little guy!
It's bad!
Holy shit!
Hey, um...
Guys, maybe in the end, I'm the win trader in the end.
Guys.
Guys, maybe like I'm the win trader in the end, chat.
Just- but like it's not a- No!
Shit!
He's gone.
But like it's not on purpose.
It's just my sheer existence.
My sheer existence.
Bro, actually.
Guys, no, no, it doesn't end yet.
They said tomorrow, unless they don't show up.
Then maybe like, I don't know.
I don't know if tomorrow's real anymore after that game.
I- I don't know if tomorrow's real anymore, chat.
I- I can't tell.
Guys, no!
We still have- Oh shit, we're bringing- Guys, I told you, it's okay!
We're bringing reinforcements.
It's okay!
It's- it's so back!
We're so back!
I told you guys, we're so back.
And the dream is real.
It's okay, everybody.
Thank God.
You guys get to keep your houses!
But then like, I don't know, 50%- 50% of you guys get to keep your houses.
50% of you guys are gonna lose your houses, so we don't know.
Where are the reinforcements?
Who are they?
Cover- It doesn't matter if I cover up my screen!
Who's Hogs?
Who's this guy?
Oh, he's a Hog player!
I don't know these people, to be fair.
I don't- I don't really know, like...
I really don't know- I don't really know, like, the people in the pro scene, to be fair.
Oh, it's a- He's a...
He's- Oh, he's their tank player?
Oh!
He's their tank player?
What happened to Mace?
Is he okay?
Is he- Is he- Is he- Okay, but like, is he okay?
I just need somebody to call him.
Mace, inform me that whatever he said in- Did we get an edit on the squad?
Can we- Can we get an edit on the squad list?
It's obviously- Someone please check on- I think after that game, I think something- I think something broke.
Hey, guys!
Let's mark that off a checklist on another pro player that...
That Doki Bird broke.
Kuroba smack-talked me?
Oh, not surprised!
I was terrible.
I'm not surprised.
I'm not- This man is used to playing with actual good support players.
I'm just a VTuber trying to make it in this small world.
Like, it's not- I'm not- I'm- It's like...
Uh, I'm aware.
He's- He's used to playing with players who, like, VOD reviews and scrims.
And, uh...
And, uh, and I'm doing the best I can.
I'm doing the best I can in this tiny world.
Hey, Sinatraa.
Yeah!
I knew what- No, and then more so, like...
Cause pro players, like I said, pro players, all they do is just...
They, like, play the game 24-7.
And, like, they do scrims and then they do VOD reviews and everything.
So they're very aware of, like, the stuff they're doing.
I, like, bash my head against the wall until- I basically learn by brute force.
I don't, like, learn from- I learn by brute force and I learn by, like, watching other streamers.
But, like, obviously pros have more- are used to a higher level of play than, like, what the fuck I am.
Cause I'm just, like... I'm trying.
Cause they learn by, like- Cause, like, for them- Cause, like, for them in the tournament setting...
What's up?
In the tournament setting, they can't make a mistake cause that basically is, like, their winnings and everything.
Like, their tournament winnings and stuff.
But, like, for me, for me, like, all I lose is just my rank points.
Like, so, like, I'm okay- Okay, I'm okay if a pro player calls me bad.
Because, like, they know what they're talking about.
What I'm not okay is some fucking random calling me bad.
Cause what the fuck are you- What do you know?
You're just like me.
What do you know?
So, like, I don't feel bad.
I'm like, that's valid criticism.
If a pro player calls me out, that's valid.
We are the same versus we are not the same.
Get damaged or something.
Oh, behind.
They have a Haka.
Oh, my god.
Oh, no.
I don't have enough heals.
No!
That's not good.
That's okay.
It's fine.
We got it.
Everything will be okay.
Everything will be- Why is everybody- Holy shit, everybody's been maxing right now.
That's actually crazy.
Like, I'm- What do I do?
Everybody has been- Everybody is forced stacking from rank one.
What do I do?
Bro, that's a different forced stack.
That's a different rank one force- There's two heal behind us.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, my god.
No, that's a forced stack.
Uh, Kal, Nectar, Speed, Mun- That's a forced stack.
I know, cause like- I know that- Cause they're trying to get rank one, too.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Are you okay over there?
No, no.
Are you okay?
I'm gonna try.
I got you.
We can kill this.
Change.
I'm good.
You're so healthy.
We got it.
Oh, my god.
Everybody won- Everybody is like grinding for rank one, and I'm here being like- Oh, my god.
Wouldn't it be cool if I get to be top 500?
That would be so cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't- You're damage boosted.
You're damage boosted.
Oh.
I have No More on me.
No More is half.
Fear.
You're so healthy.
No More is still right.
We got it.
Oh, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
Oh, my god.
I don't think we need it.
Oh!
I've damage boosted him!
Damage boosted streamer!
You want Orbs in?
Oh.
That's fine.
That's not okay.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so- Oh.
Fuck, I'm not healthy.
Oh, I'm not though.
Oh, okay.
I don't have leaves.
There's no more to it, right?
There's no more- You're damage boosted?
Oh.
I'm opening a portal.
What is this bug about?
There's still a chance to stop them!
Okay.
I have Luna.
Drop.
Go.
Oh, he's never missing.
He's never missing.
Fine.
Wait, there's a Bucky- There's a Panther by us.
I'm ulting.
By the eye of Agamotto!
Shoot!
I have shrooms on me!
Shrooms up!
Shrooms one!
Oh my god!
Do they have support or no?
I don't think they have Luna yet.
I'm gonna go quick.
Wait, where are you?
Okay, I got you.
Don't damage them.
Don't shoot their tank right now.
Okay, I am a wounded soldier.
Hey, they have Venom.
Venom is looking for dive.
Venom is looking for dive at the top.
Wait.
Should we all go?
Is Venom on me?
I slept Venom.
And there's Black Panther on us too.
Oh!
Venom one.
Nice.
Venom is one.
Yeah, fuck me, I guess.
Fuck!
Oh my god!
Jjonatra is also streaming!
Why don't you kill him instead?
Why kill the streamer?
There's multiple streamers!
They still might not have Luna.
I don't know.
They should have her.
Just play like they have her.
Fuck Vtubers in general though.
We have...
I slept Venom.
What?
Yeah, yeah.
It's lagging.
Change to the right stream.
There's a planter.
We're only trapping him.
Oh my god!
You're right.
Everybody's streaming, but there's only one Vtuber.
There's only one!
Yeah, I'm running into other streamers when I'm getting fucking farmed.
Pass.
Pass please.
There's so many force stackers.
And they're all trying to get rank one.
There's literally force stackers going up trying to get rank one.
And then my force stack is just trying to make a wish.
It's just trying to achieve my make a wish.
There's like this little tiny Vtubers make a wish just to be in top 500.
That's just...
You're so lucky.
You are so lucky.
Am I?
I'm down again because all these fucking rank one force stackers are farming me.
My make a wish is to get absolutely shit on.
This make a wish streamer don't feel lucky.
I'm doing great.
I'm doing great guys.
At least I make money for getting shit on.
I'm okay with that.
More powerful yet.
Only half.
Woah.
I slept him.
On me.
Behind.
Woah.
Oh my god.
Who's fucking yelling for heals?
I got confused.
I'm actually getting confused.
I'm so confused.
I got a little confused there.
Woah.
Bro, I get shit on for free.
I'm practically running a charity.
Eh.
Try it.
There's a turret here.
There's someone.
There's an Amur behind us.
Or in front.
I am Groot.
Here you go.
I never do ads.
I don't know how.
I mean I do know how but I don't do ads on YouTube so I don't do ads here.
They have everything actually.
I feel like I should but I don't care enough.
I make enough.
I know a lot of Forgs.
I don't think we need it, right?
Okay.
There we go.
He's asleep.
Oh, it's after here.
Actually, no.
I don't think we need it.
No!
Why me?!
I'm banned!
Did you not see me run?!
I was running!
I literally ran for my fucking life!
I don't have a power in this place.
He used everything for that, right?
I'm on a fucking adventure over here so can you help me out here?
I'm gonna walk up right now.
I'm trying to heal you.
I'll walk up with my ult.
Mag awp, mag awp, mag awp.
He's still up, he's still up!
He's one, he's one, he's one!
We should push, get these kills.
Rip one, rip one.
Oh man, I'm damage boosting you, Sinatraa.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Oh my god, we are grooved!
At least I have one more push here.
And I EFTP up.
You're damage boosting?
Nice!
Oh my god!
Don't fear, lock the fuck in!
Bro, the last time that I still died!
It doesn't matter what I do!
I just die!
It doesn't matter!
Oh my god!
That's right.
Yay!
If I can't get top 500, you can't get top 10.
But it's not toxic, I swear, I just died.
You can't get rank 1 if I can't.
I'm gonna...
You can't get rank 1 if I can't get top 500.
That's the spirit!
They literally, they dropped...
I'm just saying, what we did to them.
They dropped, like, out of top 5 because of what I...
They dropped out of, like...
They dropped two places because of what I did.
I'm sorry.
No, they actually dropped...
Yeah, they dropped out...
They dropped down.
I'm sorry.
I'm not.
I'm desperate.
She said they couldn't...
Now I'll be on their list.
What about your stack?
How much...
We're not gonna look at it.
I'd feel bad if I did.
I'm gonna pretend that, like...
I'm gonna pretend that...
They're doing okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna pretend that everything is okay.
No, he's restarting his game.
I'm gonna use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
The less I know, the better, exactly.
I'm back.
What do you mean, villainous clips?
I'm an angel.
What do you mean?
I'm a fucking angel.
If anything, I might be the happiest Marble Rivals streamer right now.
Like...
It's no denying of a fact that I might be the happiest one out of everybody.
That might be true.
If anything...
I'm the least depressed when I play Marble Rivals.
Oh my god, they're grooting it.
I'm not gonna...
What?
Are you still...
He wasn't even there for the Iron Fist.
He wasn't even there for it.
I...
Bro.
Gomez, I understand, but he wasn't even there.
Groot made a house.
Look at me.
He made a house for the Iron Fist.
They're building a generational...
You're right.
This is like generational hatred right there.
They might have the same...
Maybe you're right.
Maybe what's his name?
FatBuckMac has terrorized Hog's lobbies too.
That's like being...
Oh my god.
Yay.
FatBuckMac, that's literally...
That's literally the trauma that they all have.
What are they doing?
Are they grooting it?
Are they gonna groot all over?
What are they trying to do?
What are they trying to build this house for?
Are they playing Minecraft?
It's like...
Oh my god, we're in Minecraft.
It's beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
This is...
Oh my god, it's not gonna cost fucking a million dollars.
Groot crap.
Wait, actually...
No, it's...
No, it's not, because there's a hole right here.
There's literally a hole right here.
Like, what the fuck are they gonna do?
If that was New York City, the rent would be like...
Like 500k a month.
That's a bit too...
It's natural lighting, Toki.
You don't understand.
Oh my god.
It's like 200k in Utah.
Free air conditioning.
The central air.
So I'm just gonna say, let's respect it.
Nevermind, they can't...
Versus AntiMark, ok, GG, we won.
The central air.
Thank you, I'm glad you guys enjoy my pain.
I'm glad.
They don't know about Adam!
They don't know Kuroba is an Adam player!
They don't know.
You know what would solve Kuroba's problem?
Oh wait, he didn't put that on his title.
Okay, because like the last time I watched his stream, he would put on his title...
Number 1 Adam player, but he didn't.
I don't know if he removed it, because...
I don't know if he removed it, because of this, but like... Oh, look at that!
It's great!
No,
he literally just wrote Rank with X these people.
Oh my god, I was gonna say, if I see- If I looked up Kuroba and I see Number 1 Adam, you know who I'm banning.
You know who I'm target banning.
Hey, that's not bad!
I'm like, watching me is like a PSA to not... not...
To not go full Rivals.
I told you guys, I'm like the... I'm like the...
Do not- Do not smoke on a- On a cigarette carton.
Like, this is what happens when you smoke.
But you still buy it anyway.
This is your lungs when you're on Marvel Rivals.
And then you're like, hey, maybe- Hey, it actually looks a little fun.
Looks pretty fun.
We buy it to support you.
3... 2... 1!
Don't say that to my- To this- Where is my sponsorship?!
Where is it?!
Oh...
But then we can go.
I'm scared.
What if I fuck it up?
Yeah, I didn't fuck it up, guys.
Let's go!
I was like, they were all so confident!
Oh my god!
That was unfortunate, though.
I got hella'd.
I got fucking hella'd.
Hey guys, I don't- Oh!
Yeah, we killed Ella.
That's fucking right, bitch!
Oh my god!
Alright.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
I'm very scared.
I'm very scared here.
I'm very scared, guys.
Magneto's- Oh, nevermind.
Nevermind.
Wait, um- Change low!
Change low!
Fear.
Oh my god.
What can I do?
Oh, whatever.
Fuck this.
I've had enough.
I've fucking- I've had enough of this.
They're gonna change ult after this.
Come on.
Come on, Magneto.
Magneto has.
Oh my god.
Oh hey, fuck that clone in general!
I'm Groot.
Alright.
Chat, get off of Magneto's dick.
Guys, you gotta repopulate the mutant population.
How else will he saw mutantkind?
How else will he fix it?
Every kid he gets, it's another mutant and they're so overpowered as fuck.
Like fastest guy alive?
That's like Quicksilver?
Fucking hell.
Scarlet Witch?
Like that shit's broken.
Good!
Good.
Fear.
Are we winning this?
I can't tell.
I'm just- I don't know.
I- I don't know.
I saw-
Goodbye, Hogs.
Wait, why did we- I think we're-
Oh my god.
Is everybody okay?
Is-
I'm not okay!
Nope.
No.
Guys, I- I might have- I shouldn't have said that.
I should not have said if everybody's okay.
I think everybody was not okay, guys.
I- I- Guys, I don't think everybody was okay, guys.
Oh shit, we have the combo.
We have the combo, guys.
That hella player's insane, though.
Oh my god, that- Fear Magneto!
Oh, thank god.
Are we gonna be okay?
Are we- Are we- Are we gonna be okay, guys?
Nice.
Yay!
Who first?
I go first.
Okay.
I like how he's like- He asked and he's like, I go first.
I'm gonna have to use it.
I have to use it.
You- You- You did it.
He didn't fucking ult in the direction of the guys that got ulted, so I had to ult.
What the fuck?
He's like, don't worry, I'll go first.
And then the ult was not even on.
Was not even on.
Fear.
I'm alive.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Hello.
How did you live?
Past tense.
Who first?
Don't care.
Me first.
I wouldn't have ulted if her ult was on us.
Her ult was literally behind us- like in front of us, so I had to.
We are on your ass.
We haven't yet?
They're getting a new tank?
What happened to the other tank?
He got kicked?
What happened?
Oh my god!
Whoa.
Guys, what are my lobbies?
I thought it'd be like fun and happy and dandy like Shroud.
Is this just a Duel Keeper debuff?
Like, is it?
What happened?
They all seem to have such a great time with Shroud.
I brought the circus with me.
I had a feeling they were going to do that.
That's why I was like really scared.
I was- whoa!
I can't see you.
I legitimately predicted that they were going to...
Oh, I need heals too.
I have to reload.
Bro, I have to reload.
I can't keep you all up.
Oh my god.
Hey buddy, I think we're dead.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's Grooting.
He's gonna Groot!
I can't see you.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
I lived, I lived, I lived, I lived, I lived, I lived.
I lived, I lived, I-
I'm a little scared of that.
I need it.
Oh my god.
Please.
Fear, fear.
Fear, come on, please.
Please.
Please!
Everybody, please!
I'm so stressed out!
I'm so stressed!
Stressed!
Oh my god.
Please!
I'm stressed, guys.
Heal, heal, heal.
All I am, I'm just healing.
That's all I do in my life.
Fear.
Oh my god.
So low.
I'm so scared.
This is so stressful, guys.
I've never been so stressed in a game before.
I have to do two more minutes of this.
I love Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god.
Fear, fear.
Okay.
I can... I feel the fear.
Three and a half.
It's fine.
Clap, clap, clap, clap!
I'm healing.
I'm Groot.
I'm Groot, I'm Groot, I'm Groot, I'm Groot.
Don't die, please.
Don't die.
Please don't die.
One more minute of this.
There's a portal right behind us.
Updating, updating.
I thought...
I legitimately thought... I thought our...
Oh my god.
There's like... they're all in front of us here.
I can't... I can't move.
Oh, I couldn't.
They like blocked me.
I legit... I couldn't move.
I got fucking...
If you guys can live, I will.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Please live.
Please live!
Okay, three, two, one.
Oh
my god.
He's Mutant Kiting.
Please.
Oh my god, please.
I froze... I froze Strange.
There's a... there's clones to my right.
Tell... tell my last one, last one!
Oh my god, no!
You have no supports.
Please live.
I will, I will.
Just play my...
I'm damage boosting this.
No, that's just...
Oh my god!
I won't forget it.
Thank you for the raid.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I was like, thank you guys.
That was way too hard than it should have been.
That was actually...
Thank you.
Sorry, kudos for the raid.
Hello everybody.
My name is... I'm so stressed out.
Oh my... that was the most stressful game I've ever played today.
I've never been so... so hard for a GM.
They're... they cannot... I don't believe they're GM 3.
I... that was such a stressful game.
I've never had... like...
The top... against the top 10 stack was easier than this.
It's crazy that the top 10 stack was easier than the fucking GM 3 game.
That is... that is not GM 3 my fucking ass.
We were against a GM... we were against two GM 3 players but there's no fucking way.
There's no fucking way.
I don't believe it.
I've never been so stressed out like healing before.
But hello everybody.
My name is DonkeyBrain.
Thank you Zykoona for the raid.
I usually stream on YouTube so please check me out there.
But I've been doing my rank grind on Twitch.
Because I really want to try and end top 500.
So far I am up 30 points.
In 5-6 hours.
So, is that good?
No, it's not.
Surefour stop.
I've had such bad luck today.
Surefour, I've actually had insane luck.
Like terrible luck today.
Please Surefour.
Surefour ban my Widow.
We lost Surefour.
It wasn't the Widow problem.
Oh my god.
I was beating the fuck out.
Look, it wasn't just my fault.
The other support also banned Widow.
So you can't put the full blame on me.
I get at least 50% of that blame.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, so my stack might be depressed.
And we already had one guy rage quit.
So, I think it's going alright.
But I might be the happiest Marble Rivals streamer.
No, you are not the happiest Marble Rivals streamer.
I'm ranked 150 right now with like 12 wins today?
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
That's fucked.
Hey Surefour, you want play later?
So I can tank that.
So I can tank it.
Come on, you don't need all those points.
You don't need, it's about, if you are like secure in top 500.
Then it's not fun for your viewers.
Your viewers want a story.
If you are safe, then it's not fun to watch.
Yeah, they want to see a struggle.
They want to see a journey.
If you are safe, then there is no journey.
Like, what are the odds?
What are the like, that's the word.
Like...
Like, you know, but I can't threaten.
Okay, look, you can threaten the Black Widow pick if we play.
I'll let you threaten people.
Like, what's the word for like, you know, there's like no struggle.
It's not fun to watch a streamer not struggle.
There's no story.
There's no character arc in development.
Yeah, there's no stakes.
Yeah, there's no stakes involved if you are safe in your ELO.
It's boring.
You gotta lose some.
To make it exciting.
Oh, man.
I've heard everybody 4 stacks the top 10, though.
It's a little rough for the solo queuers.
Hey, Adam's playable now.
Damn, that was deep.
I'm now okay with losing a few.
See, this is all about the hero's journey.
It's been planned.
So, like, the more I struggle, the sweeter the victory.
So then, like, everybody will find...
See, if I get top 500 so easily, then, like, what's the point?
What's the...
What's the point?
There was no journey.
Exactly.
I'm losing on purpose so we get to have a better video.
So we get a better video for my channel.
Where are we going?
Wow!
The support split would be good.
I'm scared.
I'm a little scared here.
Where's my... rest of my team?
There they are.
Oh, shit!
Look at him go!
Let him go!
We won that?
How?
How the fuck did we win that?
Yo...
Oh my god!
Somebody save me!
What happened?
Yeah, fuck that clone in particular, though.
Like, actually, what happened?
How did I live?
How?
I don't know how this works.
I don't know.
How am I alive?
Like, how am I fucking alive?
This is called triple support, guys.
Nobody dies.
Welcome to new goats.
Actual new goats.
Guys, I don't know if I...
What?
Whoa!
They're gonna dance!
Oh, oh.
I'm okay.
Stay with me.
I'm just gonna play with my...
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna play here.
And then I...
I mean...
Is my Starlord okay?
He is.
I should give him the orb.
Yay!
I still don't know how I fucking lived there.
I legitimately was just like...
I was like, everything's gonna be okay, guys.
And then I got TP'd.
Smooth sailing.
This is it.
This is where things turn around.
This is my hours, guys.
This is literally my hours.
This is where I actually start queuing.
I know why I lose now.
I play at the fucked up normal hours.
The jokey hours is where I win.
This is my element.
When I grind at 11pm, I recognize the 11pm players.
I'm in my natural habitat.
The degeners.
Exactly, I finished my warmup.
Exactly.
I'm finally locked in after 6 hours.
After I made these pro players lose practically all their rank, I'm locked in.
Now they have a journey.
Now they really want to win.
That's why I did it.
Because at first, they're not gonna try as hard.
But now they're desperate.
Now they want to know what it's like to win again.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Almost forgot about this guy.
He's too busy clapping.
Jesus Christ.
Don't die.
Please don't die.
Oh.
That's fine, we're fine, right?
We're fine, right?
We're fine.
Yes.
How?
How is this still going on?
How are we still fighting for this one point?
Oh my god, it's over.
It's finally over.
It's actually over.
Oh my god.
It's finally over.
That's crazy.
It took me so...
It took like 20 years for this game to end.
Mate, wait.
You know what's great?
Because like, normally they don't play at these hours.
Which means they don't know who the fuck Korova is.
Which means Adam will finally be ba- Which means they won't ban Adam because they don't know who he is.
This is it.
Because normally, nobody's degenning like me.
They're not going to open this stream and figure it out.
That's crazy.
That's fucking crazy talk.
Wait, she's cooking.
Fuck that clone in particular.
He's won, he's won.
Fuck these clones.
It's all coming together.
You see how nobody's banning Adam?
Guys?
You see that?
Nobody's banning Adam anymore at these hours?
Because they don't know who the fuck he is.
Because who plays at these hours except for freaks like me?
Who's Korova?
Look, he's the guy in my stack that's like, apparently, he's like the rank 1 Adam.
Oh my god, just stop!
He basically, this entire day, has been like, they just target ban Adam.
Which is crazy.
They like target, hard target, ban Adam.
Which is crazy and funny at the same time.
They're like that scared.
But like, every time I watch his stream, he gets to play Adam.
Like, that's so fucked.
Oh, I need heals.
I guess I die too.
Unless...
That's fine, right?
Woo!
Let's go!
Oh, let's not go.
Let's go again!
I was gonna say, alright, time to walk away.
Wait.
Oh, I was gonna say, what is the fuck is Strange doing?
That's okay, they're still healthy.
We should get the Strange.
He's frozen?
Come on, Starlord.
Oh, I'm not!
Starlord's up!
Nice!
Let's go!
There you go.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
That was such a fucking long-ass fight.
That's actually...
I hate how easy Luna is to use.
Yep.
Luna is the second easiest support character.
Who's the first Rocky Raccoon?
Rocky Raccoon is the easiest support.
But he's also the most hated in high elo, because why the fuck would you ever play Rocky Raccoon?
We don't talk about Rocky.
Three supports works.
Oh my god, we got her peak!
We fucking did it!
Oh my god!
We fucking...
I don't... I never knew what it was like to get a peak.
I never knew.
Sarah, thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you.
SM, thank you for the Twitch prize.
Oh my god, can I run an ad?
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm gonna run an ad now.
I'm gonna be a Twitch streamer for today.
You guys know how...
You guys know how to not get ads?
Sorry, the people who got ads can't even...
I should've said it before.
Sorry, I'm still learning.
I should've said it before I ran an ad.
But like, the people who are subscribed, at least you know.
But hey guys.
Hey guys.
If you don't wanna get ads...
Just subscribe.
Wait, oh yeah, I should tell them when it's done.
Alright, let me know when your ad's done.
Well, you won't hear this, but like, I'll figure it out.
SoSharky, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Bro said ads like crazy.
Oh yeah, anyway.
I don't... I don't run ads.
I'm just fucking around.
But like, I heard that...
I know that like, some orgs, when you join an org...
You have to run a mandatory like...
Around like three to six minute ads per hour or some shit.
Like, it's like mandatory for the org.
Because they have like a contract with Twitch.
And like...
And it's like something like how...
That's how like they make money as well.
So that's why...
That's why you see a lot of like...
A lot of like streamers who are in orgs.
They run ads a lot.
Just cause like...
Just cause like, it's like part of their contract with the org itself.
Trust5, thank you for the five gifted...
Yeah, I'm leaking company secrets.
I think that's like a...
I'm pretty sure the streamers...
I'm pretty...
I found that out from the streamers.
By watching streamers.
Like...
Oh my god.
Leaking company secrets.
It's like common knowledge.
Trashfire, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
MrBrokenBond, thank you for the five gifted subs.
But yeah, that's why you see a lot of streamers...
Like, I don't run ads because I don't need to.
I'm perfectly fine...
Well off with just...
Well, I'm not like...
I'm not a fucking millionaire, guys.
I know everybody thinks like streamers are millionaires.
But I live in...
I live in Canada.
And like...
Our rent is not okay.
Why is there five Groots?
Or three Groots?
Why is there more Groots now?
What are...
Alright.
Let me get an angle on this.
They're building...
They needed more builders.
Guys, they...
They needed more...
It's...
They recruited another...
The Groot...
It's like...
No, it's broken.
Wait, I saw this...
I saw this video once.
Guys, I just need a coach.
No.
No, Ducky.
Shut up.
Ducky.
Don't let me out.
Let me out.
Cutter, Mike.
One girl, three trees.
Run.
Yes.
I got out.
Oh my god.
It was the tree.
I'm free.
I wish the human torches...
I wish you could play the human torch now.
So I can just start burning the house down.
Run the ads.
Someone run the ads.
Quick.
Let's go.
Okay.
He got us.
He brought us out.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
No.
19 inches of venom.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
They're fighting.
What happened?
They broke the house.
That timing.
Oh my god.
Who would win?
A big fucking tree?
Or what?
Or one Canadian?
You know about lumberjacks in Canada?
You know about the lumberjacks in Canada?
Okay, my favorite...
Okay, I've been obsessed with Marvel rival memes.
And we got our ads.
And one of my favorite Marvel rival memes is the Wolverine TikToks.
I mean, I don't look at them on TikTok.
I see them on my Twitter feed.
But the one that was the animal music.
Yeah, Leo!
I love...
Wait, I'll send you the video.
I fucking...
I love this video so much.
This is legitimately one of my favorite memes from Marvel rivals.
Wait, is this the right link?
Oh, it'd be awkward if I give you guys the wrong link, right?
Okay, this one.
This is one of my favorite.
I'm gonna rewatch it because I love it so much.
I'll watch with you guys.
I'm not gonna show it on stream.
I fucking love that video.
It's such a...
I love those memes.
This is why I play Wolverine.
Oh my god, fight!
Fight!
Where did they go?
What did I just witness?
Therapy.
This is how pro players cope with each other.
This is how they survive the harsh world.
They're letting out their frustrations on each other.
So it doesn't implode within themselves.
Because they don't know how to talk about their feelings.
Guys, you gotta learn how to talk about your feelings, guys.
They're bonding.
They just... Oh no.
Oh no.
But yeah, that's how they do it.
Oh, you wanna be... Okay, here's what I would do.
Wait, where are they?
I need them to drop down.
I need...
I need them to group up.
I just need them to group up together.
And then I can do it.
Wait, wait, not me!
Not me though!
No, no, no, no!
I'm just a little guy!
I'm just a little...
No!
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god.
No!
They're waking him up!
What do I do?!
No!
Not me!
Don't awoo me!
Wake up.
There we go.
Oh, he almost got...
Oh no.
No!
Oh my god.
Who keeps waking him up?!
If I hit the floor eventually...
Eventually...
If I hit the floor...
Oh my god!
No!
Oh!
I can't handle the awoos.
You see, these are the normal queues people tend to get.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Sleep!
What?!
You can get me in spawn?!
That should be illegal!
Maybe just...
Just fine.
I don't die.
I don't...
No!
Get me out of here!
Okay, but what if I...
There we go.
How do I parry?
I've never done this before.
Oh my god, how do I parry?
Please get me out of here!
Get me out of here!
No!
Please!
This is a hatecraft!
There we go.
Oh, you can't sleep me.
I'm in spawn.
I know that.
You don't know that.
I do.
There we go.
The awoo haunts me.
Wait, what?
Does he know where I am?
You idiot.
And you're a pro player?
You're a pro player?
Oh no, he's gonna actually kill me now.
He's gonna actually kill me after I said that.
So he doesn't know.
Is he gonna rewatch this part of the VOD?
Oh, you can't eat people in spawn!
That's fucking right.
As it should be.
I'm Jeff.
They won't know.
They won't know I'm right here.
What are they gonna do?
Open my stream and find out?
No way.
What are they gonna fucking do?
Huh?
What are they gonna do?
Exactly open this part of the stream?
And then just...
Oh, that's fucked.
No.
No!
Let me eat!
My arm!
It's okay.
There's still this one.
There's this one.
I can get it.
I got it.
Where am I?
Where could I be?
That's right.
Oh, that's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
That's fucking right.
Ah!
It's fine.
I got the other guy.
Da da da da da da da da da da.
Alright.
What?
What happened?
Wait, did I...
No!
Oh my god!
What?
No, that's so fucked.
I'm okay!
They don't know.
Please, I can swim faster than this.
I can keep swimming.
Wait, they can't get me if I'm under.
Wait, that's crazy.
That's a new tech.
I didn't know that.
They can't get me if I'm swimming.
Get it out.
Watch.
Sorry, I fell down.
No!
Then how come they couldn't get me there?
Oh no, they did it after.
Wait, who did I...
Oh shit, I got...
That's not him.
There we go.
This is the actual Q time.
What are you gonna do, huh?
What are you gonna do?
That's what they're gonna do.
That's...
What did I do?
I hit one guy and now I'm the bad guy.
I hit one guy.
You commit one murder and now suddenly everybody says you're evil.
My simulated environment is ready.
Oh, is this baseball?
Wait a minute.
Missed.
That's fucking right.
Get better aim.
Where am I?
I wanna get on the bridge.
Wait, how do I...
Alright.
Where is he?
That's right, get over here.
Get over here.
Oh, you wanna fucking run?
That's... Oh wait, that's legal.
That's legal.
Hulk sends his regards.
Holy shit, this queue time is crazy.
I know like that's usually how...
I heard like some pro players queue for like two hours before they get a game in top 10.
That's actually insane.
I don't know if I could live like that.
Yeah.
No, it's...
Yeah, I heard like some pro players...
Some pro players have to wait two hours for games sometimes.
Don't, don't please.
I'm just a little guy.
Oh, they...
It's bugged?
Alright.
Who knows?
We have to wait another...
Woah!
Aha!
Alright, if we wait another five minutes, I'm pulling up a second game.
I'm pulling up...
I'm pulling up a second game.
You know like, we're doing the Overwatch special where...
where like Overwatch streamers pull out a second game just to pass the time.
Or like, watch YouTube videos, but we're not gonna watch YouTube videos.
We'll just pull up a second game.
No one played Bolatro on stream though.
I wanna watch Bolatro on stream.
Do I not outlive this?
I thought I outlived this.
I wanna play that like on YouTube.
That's fucking right.
I live these.
If I get like 20 bubbles, I'll live these.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't live these.
Nevermind.
Oh, I could play Holocure.
That's true.
I don't know if I wanna do a new update for...
I don't know.
I don't know what to play.
Okay.
That was good.
Alright.
What do we play?
If it hits five minutes...
If it hits five minutes and we still don't get a...
and we still don't...
No!
We did it!
We found a game!
Oh, I heard people.
Yep, I haven't played Blooms.
Oh, are they still queuing?
There's AC Killer.
I never played Bellatro.
I wanna play it on YouTube.
Because it's like my first game.
We did it.
Get my ass back there.
Doom you hard tilted mace.
He had to walk away.
Damn.
That's rough.
You think he touched grass after?
You think?
Oh my god.
You think he actually like went out and got some fresh air after that?
Bro, he was saying some fucked up shit.
Apparently he was saying some shit in Korean.
He was so tilted.
He like literally started saying shit in a different language.
That was how tilted he was.
Apparently it was really bad to the point where when the stack Gomez, one of the people in my stack was like, don't translate that.
Don't translate that.
Can't be that bad.
Oh, it could be that bad.
If at one point they were like, don't translate it.
I think it might have been really bad.
I don't know.
Just a maybe.
Alright.
Everything will be okay.
I don't know if it will be.
But like, you know, sometimes you gotta be hopeful in this fucked up world.
I'm worried about going in.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Like, okay.
I'm like, what do I do?
What do I do?
What the fuck?
What?
I literally didn't know what to do there.
I was like, okay.
There's a Psylocke here.
What do I do?
I knew I was gonna die regardless.
As I stay in spawn and like, I guess like my team's just like, I guess die.
It was like, you die, you die, you don't, you die, you do.
Scenario.
Oh, I need heals here.
Thank you.
Let's go!
I'm a little worried.
I'm just a little worried.
Just a little bit.
Whoa!
I was like, yeah, I'm a little worried.
And then I'm like, oh, there he is.
Yeah, that Hawkeye's scary.
He's a little scary.
They're just saying all the frustration.
I do that to a lot of people.
Yeah, that seemed about right.
Oh!
Whoa!
What happened?
Oh, alright.
Let's go!
You got your heals!
Wait, is he going Jeff?
Oh no.
I'm sorry to keep banning your Adam.
I'm so sorry.
I'm scared.
He said he's never gonna miss.
No, I have to reload.
I have to reload.
Yay!
Oh shit, sorry!
Whoops.
I forgot to heal this guy.
Um...
Jesus Christ.
Guys, don't worry.
Guys, he's...
I'm a little...
Fuck!
Okay!
Wait, this is last fight.
Okay.
Alright, fear.
Guys.
We can forehold this.
I believe.
That was like...
That was a whale.
And I'm also scared about that.
That is rough!
That's the worst part about these queues.
You wait so long just to lose.
It fucking sucks.
Alright, let me...
Let me look at Steam.
What can we play as a second game?
If these queues go longer than...
If these queues are like...
Um...
What's the word?
If they're like...
6 plus...10 minutes long?
I'm fucking pulling up a second game.
The second time I open up the queue and there's 10 minutes long...
We're opening a secondary game.
We're going fucking Overwatch style.
Where we play a second game.
It's funny because like...
It's always like they either watch Hell's Kitchen...
What was the other one?
The hotel one?
The...
Hell's...It's not Hell's Kitchen.
Ah, what is it called?
The...
Refurbishment of hotels?
Hotel Hell?
Yeah, Hotel Hell.
Or like the other one for restaurants.
Restaurant Hell.
Or like...
They watch MasterChef.
It's like I do all of this...
To pass the time.
I don't know who I gave this to.
Oh, it's to Magneto.
I feel like I'm gonna get...
A Hawkeye just standing there.
I feel like.
I don't know.
It's a little scary.
Standing here.
Just a little scary.
You know?
Just a...
Just a little scary.
I have no idea.
I'm a little scared just standing all the way over there.
Because I don't know where the Hawkeye is.
I don't...
Oh my god.
We're not gonna be watching shows.
I wanna keep my VODs.
Guys.
Oh shit.
Guys, I wanna be able to keep my VODs.
Guys.
I'm gonna...
I'll watch like...
I'll play a game.
Cause that's safer.
I hope they don't die.
Oh my god.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
I'm putting a fucking show!
It doesn't matter.
I did put a show though.
I did.
Oh.
That's fucking rough buddy.
That's...
That's why...
I don't understand.
That's why I fucking ban Hawkeye all the time.
So whoever has the better Hawkeye...
They're...
I don't think Hawkeye liked my show.
I don't...
I guess I don't think he liked my show.
I don't know.
I don't think he was a fan guys.
I like the winter outfit.
Winter outfit's cute.
Yeah.
Um...
I'm not spending any money until I get my sponsor.
Oh hey!
Who's this guy?
Oh my god it's Mr. Fister.
Oh it's Rex.
Oh he's nice.
Oh this guy.
This is the Raccoon player.
I fucking roasted him in my stream.
But like...
Oh he lost.
Thank fucking god.
I'm sorry.
Yes!
This brings me joy.
I'm sorry.
It's not you.
I just don't like Raccoon players in general.
I legitimately...
I just don't like Raccoon players.
I swear to god.
They're all so...
This is what I mean!
They're not sniping.
They're trying to min-max top 10 right now.
So like...
I get caught in the crossfire.
Because I just want to know what it's like to be top 500.
I just want...
So like...
I get caught in the crossfire in general.
Because there's only like 3 days left.
So all the top 10 players are like min-maxing.
And trying to become top 10.
They are?
They are here?
I hate everything.
Marble Rivals has like...
unlocked something inside me.
And I like it.
Real and true.
It's...
I'm tired of being a nice guy.
I want to be part...
You know what?
Maybe Hydra ain't so...
I think...
I feel like Hydra must be like a great place to work for.
Because like...
I feel like they must have good benefits, you know?
It's like...
I don't know.
I feel like...
If you look at Hydra versus Agents of Shield.
Or like...
I feel like...
Oh shit!
Wait, they are?
Wait!
Oh, I did not know.
I mean...
I will work for Agents of Shield.
I didn't know!
I just...
I was like...
I do not work for Hydra.
Understood.
I...
Guys, I never...
Guys, I never watched Captain America.
I never watched the movie.
I just know Hydras are like the bad guys.
In the MCU.
But like...
I didn't realize their origins.
I just thought...
I just...
I just thought they were just a supervillain group.
I just thought...
They were like a regular supervillain group.
Like Skeletors.
I thought they were just like Skeletor.
No, I'm not.
Supervillains are just Nazis.
I swear I didn't know.
I was just...
I was just trying to yap.
Guys, I...
Guys, please, I didn't know.
I didn't know.
I thought they were like Skeletor.
I legitimately thought they were like Skeletor, guys.
I thought it was like the Thanos shit.
You know?
Like the typical villain group.
You know, I should have known.
Because like, they came from Captain America.
And legit, Steve Rogers...
He's literally just...
He... Steve Rogers is like...
You know, he's fighting World War 2.
And we all know what's going on in World War 2.
We know.
Let's go.
I...
Yeah, I should have...
I should have...
From context wise, I should have known.
I should have known.
It's okay, I'm just ignorant, guys.
Anyway...
I feel like working for a villain in general...
The health benefits must be really, really good.
To work for a villain.
Like, just like...
Employment benefits in general.
Because like...
If you think about it, you know you're gonna...
Like, you know, the risk of dying...
From the supervillain...
Must be like, really...
Like, you know...
You know you're fucking working for a bad guy.
So like, what are the benefits of working for a bad guy?
So like, I'm just thinking...
Maybe they have like, 401Ks...
And like, insurance or some shit.
Because like, the Joker is scared of insurance companies.
Or like, taxes and stuff.
No, not like Hydra.
We're off the topic of Hydra, guys.
We're...
Hydra, no matter what...
They're just... They're Nazi.
Yeah, he's like, scared of the IRS.
So like, maybe like...
Working...
Maybe working for villains ain't so bad.
Like, I'm just thinking...
Because like, the potential to die...
Because like, you...
There's a higher risk to die working for a villain...
Than it is to die working for a hero.
So like, I'm just thinking...
Maybe like, employment benefits outweighs the...
The pros and cons.
And so...
So like, maybe you get like, retirement...
Or your fam...
Like, if you die from the job...
Maybe like, you know, your family's like, set for life.
So that's a Spider-Man.
Yeah, but I feel like...
If you work for like...
If you're a hero, you get less shit.
Because you know, heroes are like...
Heroes are pussies and they're like, I'm doing this for free.
I wonder if fucking Peter Parker is a broke-ass bitch.
But like, because they're like...
My reward is the reward of the people.
You know?
But like, don't fuck that.
I won't get paid.
I'm gonna save your fucking life.
Like, the government should pay me.
You know?
Like, if you didn't...
If I wasn't there...
People would have died.
So I should be paid by the government.
You know, I'm right.
A hero is literally like...
Saving the world.
Every day.
And what benefits do they get?
Honor?
The fuck?
Honor doesn't pay rent.
No, I'll just be like...
Hero for hire.
That's right.
Okay, but like...
They can't all be Batman, guys.
Not every hero can have millions of dollars.
You mean I'm mercenary?
No, because I'll still do good things.
I'd just rather be paid for my good deeds.
Because like...
Because like, Hawkeye gets paid by the government, technically.
So why can't the other characters get paid by the government?
That's horrible.
He doesn't count.
Also, why don't the billionaires pay for the other heroes' income?
Fucking Tony Stark could have paid for Peter Parker's rent.
I thought they were homies.
Instead, he just gave him a fucking suit and be like...
There you go.
That's so true.
Why can't he just pay for Peter Parker's rent?
He did once.
He did...
Oh, just one time.
Pay for his fucking college.
That boy's 16.
He needs someone to pay for his college.
It raised suspicion, I guess.
He's a billionaire.
He can fucking kill ten people and hide it.
They'll just be like...
I didn't do it.
Here's ten million dollars.
I'm aware.
Doki, please.
In fact, why doesn't he fund...
Professor Xavier's school?
Why does he need fucking handouts?
College just never...
Doki would need it.
Because he's not a mutant.
Oh yeah, but he uses the mutants...
Whenever he feels like it.
Because they're mutants.
Oh shit, is Tony Stark like me?
You know what?
I think he's a cool guy.
Nah.
He's cool in my book.
Nevermind.
He's cool.
Wow.
What happens if fucking...
You know he's old, right?
Professor Xavier?
What do they do when he dies?
Where is the school gonna get money?
He died like several times...
In the X-Men universe.
He's already dead several times.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're fucking pulling up a different game.
While we wait in queue.
Alright, what game should we do?
What is a good game that I can just play...
And don't need to worry about streaming on YouTube?
Tetris?
Nah, I don't really want to play Tetris.
I'm looking at like stuff we can play.
I wanna play...
I wanna play Bellatro like...
On stream.
On YouTube.
I know I'm like streaming right now.
But I wanna... Wait!
Wait!
This is a game that I've been wanting to play.
But I'll play it here.
I heard about the new Squid Game Roblox game.
I heard about that...
The Squid Game Roblox game.
And I actually wanted to try it out.
Am I allowed to be on voice chat though?
How do I get in voice chat for the Roblox?
Uh...
Wait, here I select this spot.
What is spawning?
Alright, let me see.
Oh, I need...
I can't hear them scream.
I can't hear the little kids scream.
And like grown ass adults scream too.
That sounded so bad out of context.
Uh, which one recommended for me?
Mingle?
The Squid Game?
Which one was it?
Was it Season 2 Squid Game?
Which one was the Squid Game where like you can hear...
You can actually hear people scream in the background?
There's so many.
What do you mean?
I just want...
I'm just trying to find that Squid Game!
Is it Shrimp Game?
The one where you can hear them scream?
Wait, what?
What are you having your 1v1?
What are you doing?
Oh my god, they're fucking brawling.
Is this Shrimp Game?
Oh my god, they are.
They're fucking brawling now.
Oh, they're letting out the anger.
Alright, Shrimp Game.
Shrimp Game Roblox.
Let's boot this up.
I hope I don't like...
Crash my own.
No, I can't!
I'm so stupid!
I forgot I can't do anything!
My OBS disappeared!
I forgot!
I forgot my OBS disappeared!
I'm so sad.
I really wanted to play.
My OBS is still...
How do I push it back to the...
Guys, okay, so like...
It's not in my apps right now.
That's the thing.
My OBS literally disappeared from...
From my apps.
And when I press alt tab...
There's no OBS.
But like...
But if I close it, then I make another...
Stream and I don't want to do that.
I don't want to make another stream.
Okay.
Wait, is it...
Is it on my other tab?
No, I don't have another window.
I'm pressing window tab...
And it doesn't exist.
It actually doesn't exist.
Anywhere.
It's gone.
I don't see it.
I don't see it at all.
Yeah, there's no other desktop now.
There's no new desktop.
It's literally like one.
Desktop one.
Try a search bar.
Can I look it up?
OBS.
No?
No, because then I have to reopen it.
Might have to try...
No, but I don't want to make another one.
I don't...
I don't want to make...
Oh, I found it!
I got it back!
I found it!
I did it, guys.
I don't know how I did.
I just...
I did it.
Alright, nice.
Now I can play Roblox.
Alright, guys.
I did it.
I'm gonna tell you.
I'm not gonna...
Explain how I found it.
Because I think like...
You guys are gonna be very embarrassed...
At me, so...
So...
So I'm not gonna explain how I did it.
Alright.
Alright, copy.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
There we go.
Wait!
Do I need to...
Wait, why is it not showing up?
Why is my Roblox not showing up?
How do I make it show up?
Where's my Roblox?
Hello?
Hey, where's my Roblox?
Oh, I have to...
I have to use window...
I forgot I have to use window capture!
So dumb.
Okay.
Roblox.
There we go.
Wait, I'm not ready.
I'm not ready.
Wait, I'm not ready!
Give me a sec!
What happened?
Oh, we need 50 players.
Okay, okay, there we go.
I'm in.
I'm fucking in.
Oh, I'm lagging, but I'm in.
I'm in, but I'm lagging.
Let's go.
Okay, computer.
Okay, we are in.
We are in.
Cute.
Guys, I don't know if we can play Roblox, guys.
I don't know.
I don't know if we can play Roblox.
How is there only five?
I missed out!
Because I was trying to figure it out!
Guys, I need more players!
Oh my god, please!
We're only six of us!
People died!
Die now!
In game, in the stream game.
I'm literally waiting in the queue to wait for a queue.
That is so fucked up.
I might as well boot a third game.
I boot up a third game to wait out the Roblox queue that's waiting out the fucking Marvel Rivals queue.
We've gotten full circle.
There's only nine of us!
Wait, I want clothes.
I like how here we're all equal and we don't have any cool... oh wait, nevermind.
We can't use our cool cosmetics.
We have to buy their cosmetics in this game.
I don't want to play Bellatro on Twitch because I want my very first Bellatro stream on YouTube.
Guys, we're in queue so we gotta wait.
But like, I'm in another queue right now too.
There's no way!
We're...
Where are the players?
How is there nobody here?
Get in!
Oh my god, are everybody...
Okay, it requires eight players.
We're three.
There's three of us.
Okay.
Now there's two.
Guys, there has to be more of you.
How do I join another server?
How do I join another server, guys?
Copyrighted music.
Oh my god, just the two of us?
Just the three of us?
Hey guys!
Wait, you guys are veterans?
Hey, there's TSMCurry5.
I didn't know they recruited us.
Just the three of us?
Alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna join a new server.
Fuck this.
Alright.
I'm gonna fucking find another server.
I'm gonna reboot it and maybe I can get in.
Please, I don't want to wait in the queue to be in another queue.
Please, don't do this to me.
I'm literally waiting in the queue to be in the queue.
Oh my god, I'm in.
I'm fucking in.
There we go.
We're in.
We're lagging a little bit.
Oh my god.
We're lagging a little bit, but it's okay.
We should be able to start whenever, right?
Eight players to start?
Start the game!
Oh, there's 31 of us.
I want Nunu.
The fuck is Nunu?
What the fuck is Nunu?
Alright, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Hello.
What?
Are we in?
What do we play?
What do we do?
Hello, everybody.
I'm player 272.
And I'm here to make friends.
In Shrimp Game.
I'm here to make friends.
Cash prize is zero dollars?
The fuck is this scam?
I'm dying for zero dollars?
I'm...
Guys, why is there Marvel Rivals in my Squid Game?
How dare...
I came here for Roblox.
And they're right here.
Bum.
Squid Game in Wakanda?
Hello, guys.
I'd like to send a heartfelt...
Oh, well, I guess I'll never...
I don't know the lore.
Oh my god.
It's red light, green light.
Alright, guys.
I'm so ready.
There's no way I could...
There's a...
Woooo.
Oh my god.
Yay.
I
fell.
I tripped.
I didn't realize that's a thing.
You can trip?
Oh my god.
They pushed...
I got no friends.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
You can push people?
That's so fucked.
I literally saw them push people.
I made it.
Oh my god.
I just saw them push...
I can't get pushed?
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
I literally just saw people pushing each other.
I made it to the next day.
Yippee.
Oh my god.
I get $500,000.
$500,000.
That's like one month in New York City.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Hostile kids are cruel.
Children are so cruel.
Did the match start yet?
No.
I was like, I didn't hear anything and I stopped hearing things so I got a little worried.
Alright.
What's that?
Are we doing red light, green light again?
Where are we?
Or is this a...
Oh, it's a shape.
What am I gonna get?
Oh.
How do I do?
Hostile ahead.
I'm worried, guys.
Guys, I'm so scared.
Guys, I'm so scared, guys.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
No.
No, we got a game.
I still got it.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I just saw it get shot.
I saw the child get shot.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Okay, I still have time.
I still have time.
Guys, I still have time.
Did you forgot the goal?
Oh my god.
I saw a child get shot.
I don't know.
Guys, they're still batting.
We have time.
Oh my god, a million dollars.
Let's go.
They're still batting.
They're batting the second character now.
I still have time.
Oh, wait.
What does that mean?
Wait, what does that mean?
Do I still have time?
Yeah, they're doing the second band, guys.
We still have time.
Wait, I don't know what that means.
What are we doing?
What's gonna happen?
We still have time, guys.
We have four seconds.
We still have time.
What's going on?
I picked my hero.
I said 25 seconds.
I'm so scared.
2, 1.
Oh.
Wait, everything's okay.
What happened?
What's going on?
Alright, are we attack or defense?
This is gonna decide whether or not I keep going.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Please, we gotta...
I gotta...
Oh, we're attacking.
We're fine.
We're attacking.
We're so okay.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
You guys are gonna lose.
I'm sorry, children.
I'm...
I'm sorry.
They gotta push him out of me.
I'm sorry, kids.
I'm sorry.
You left the kids out.
We're not in queue anymore.
That's fine.
I skate, so I go fast.
You left the kids to die.
Not intentionally.
Look, what are the kids gonna do with a million dollars, guys?
What the fuck are they gonna do with a million dollars, guys?
Legitimately.
What are they gonna do?
They don't...
The children don't need the million dollars.
The children are fat.
The children will be fat.
Oh my god.
I hear so many noises and I'm getting scared.
I hear so many sounds.
I was still fighting them.
Wait, change, change, change.
Change is low, change is low.
Wait, Magneto on point.
Oh my god.
What would these kids do with a million dollars?
Guys, what the fuck are they gonna do?
Legitimately, it got like...
Did Legitimately get like recalled?
Legitimately got recalled.
Kids don't know what to do with a million dollars.
You wanna know what I know?
Cause I didn't know what to do.
No, wait, I say that to my dad.
Cause I wouldn't know what to do if I was a child with a million dollars.
No, I'm saying hypothetically.
Wait, what?
What's going on?
What?
I'm coming back, guys.
What happened?
Oh my god, like, okay, the reason why the cheese were moldy is cause they said they didn't put any preservatives and because they didn't put any preservatives, like...
We're in the wrong spot, we're in the wrong spot, we're in the wrong spot.
We're in the wrong spot!
Okay, that was pretty funny.
That's really funny.
We actually ended up on the wrong spot.
That's like, not gonna lie, that's so impressive for us.
Oh, I didn't know where that was.
That was great.
That's actually crazy.
I can't believe we were at the wrong spot.
It was a throw on me?
Thank you.
You didn't see us go to the wrong spot, right?
No, no.
I died.
Yeah, yeah, I was with her.
Magneto.
It's Gomez's fault.
We were just walking for a spawn.
We died.
We were just resetting.
I was keeping up with my team.
Bye, guys.
Of course not.
I can't believe we were at the wrong spot.
We were capping our own spawn, but we still won.
Like, how?
That's freaking crazy.
We were at our own spawn.
Skill.
You're right.
It's pure skill.
That's how.
We take those, guys.
We fucking take those.
Yay.
They're gonna need to sleep in a restraining order?
For some reason, they won't do it again tomorrow.
I don't know if that's Stockholm Syndrome or, like, I made new friends.
You guys think I'm their friend?
Or do you think they're really tilted?
I don't know about Carrova.
I might be the worst support player he's ever played with, but, like, maybe...
There's a Thor and a Psylocke behind us.
Please.
Please!
Help me!
There are no friends.
Only rank.
True, true.
I'm coming back.
I froze him?
Nice.
Yay!
I sit in a 30-minute queue to be placed with 3 GFs.
That's rough, buddy.
That's so fucking rough.
That's pretty rough, man.
It's actually pretty rough.
You think they'll be okay?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
That'll be fine, right?
We're gonna be so healthy.
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Whoa!
Fear, fear, fear, fear.
Fear, fear, fear.
There we go.
Don't worry, I'll body block!
It'll be so funny if I put it on damage right now.
It'll be so silly.
Oh my god!
I jumped up!
How?!
I jumped out of it!
Oh my god!
You're alive!
I hope they start taking damage.
Not me!
But not me!
No, I didn't mean it!
We did it!
It's a thing!
Yeah, I'm so glad our game was shorter than our queue time.
That was fun.
Not for me.
I had a great time.
Now back to the Shrimp Game.
Alright, guys, now we can go back to Shrimp Game.
Yay!
I'm gonna use the bathroom before we play more Shrimp Game.
I'll be right back.
Time for the main event.
Time for...
Back to the main event, guys.
Back to the main event.
Let me boot it up real quick.
Alright, opening...
Opening it up.
It's time.
I'm sorry to the kids I ditched last time.
I'm so sorry.
To the children I ditched.
I'm really sorry.
I think they might have lost.
It's okay, we can do this all over again.
How do you make a private lobby?
We'll make a private lobby next time.
It's okay.
Oh, you're right!
They can't feel anything because they're dead now.
You're right.
That's great.
That's great to know.
Wait, I need VIP?
That's money.
Fucking Rivals doesn't even sponsor me.
You think I have the money?
I'm fucking grinding the game for free right now.
You don't need VIP?
I don't?
Okay, how do I do it then?
Uh...
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Um...
Come on, start the game.
Start the game, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm the- Yeah, I've played these games before!
I've played these games before.
I know how it happens.
Alright, I'm ready.
Okay, I need to get out of this part.
Okay.
I'd like to extend a heartfelt welcome to you all.
Everyone here will participate in the six different games over six days.
Where are they?
Okay.
Alright.
Bro, do you think I'm gonna save the other people?
I'm gonna fucking...
I love the newest trend for like there are a lot of people playing these squid game type games like Call of Duty and Fortnite and Roblox and they do like a soundboard.
They do a- I'm fucking- I'm not- I don't trust them.
No, I got a game!
Okay, I'm gonna push somebody down before.
Before this happens.
I'll push someone down.
How do I push people?
Guys, how do I push people down?
Before I die?
Guys, how do I do it?
Guys, I need you to teach me.
It's a P?
I'm gonna do it.
It's not P!
You guys lied!
Push is a VIP feature?!
What's the point?
It's literally...
It's literally P!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
He went back just to push me!
He fucking walked back just to push me!
He looked at me!
Oh my god!
Okay, we gotta leave again.
We gotta leave.
The pro is gone.
Oh my god!
The force of that shot!
Bro!
Fuck that one guy that turned around just to push me down!
Like, what's wrong with him?!
Oh my god!
What the fuck was wrong with him?!
Karma!
Bro, that's so...
Yeah, true.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright!
No, they have...
They have the...
Top 10 squad again.
The top 10 stack.
The 4 stacking top 10s.
You know that guy?
You know the top 10 stack?
You know, with 4 people in that stack that were trying for top 10?
You know, those guys?
The top 10?
What were they again?
The what?
What were they?
The potion for Kuzco?
I'm gonna grab Tringe.
I got Tringe.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Oh my god!
Alright, my passive got popped.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got grabbed.
Who did he grab?
Let me tell you.
I need to grab again.
Oh.
You'll be fine, right?
Alright, oh shit!
Oh my god, oh my god!
I'm never okay.
I'm never fucking okay.
I should stop damage boosting.
I should just heal.
I'm not getting a lot of...
Ult charge from it.
This person got...
They got a lot of ult charge.
I need to heal more.
So I can grab ult charge for it.
Oh my god!
I tried my best to keep him up.
Like, I actually tried so hard to keep him up there.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Tried so hard and got so far.
I think I'm like...
I think like...
The shrimp game, like actually locked me out.
What?
Oh my god.
There's a Hulk behind you.
He's low, he's low.
Oh, nice.
Oh no!
I quit!
Oh!
It's fine.
It was planned.
Okay, you guys can live.
I'm gonna ult.
Oh, I got you.
I'm gonna ult for you.
Oh my god.
No way!
Oh my god!
The supports are getting so fucking harassed right now.
Holy shit.
Oh my god!
Guys, I don't...
They're all red.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm trying!
Oh my god!
I'm trying so hard to keep people up.
Are they still alive?
How?
How do I not be...
I can't fucking go inside.
Wolverine's low!
He has no passive.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm like the weak link here.
Please stop.
Oh my god!
We're trying to save your life!
I slept somebody.
Hulk is behind us.
Bro!
Stop!
I can't see!
Oh my god.
Wolverine!
Boom, boom, boom.
I'm so sad.
Oh shit!
I can go up here for us.
I'm punching a cap off!
Hulk is low!
Hulk is one!
Oh nice!
Oh my god.
I can't move!
Alright.
Everything's fine.
I'm having a great time.
I fucking love eternity games, guys.
No, this isn't even an eternity game.
I'm up against a top 10 stack.
This is fucked.
I'm not even top 500 and I have to play against them.
Like, what's wrong?
I'm in this shit, baby!
Oh my god.
Oh nice!
Awesome, thank you for the raid, Blurred!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you for the raid.
Hello, everybody!
If you're new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm here suffering in rank.
Oh my god, why are they stuck?
You came second.
But yes, please check me out on YouTube if you like my content.
In three days, I'll be back on- On three days, I'll be back on YouTube.
I'm just- I'm just trying my best in Marvel Rivals ranked to see if I can get a top 500, and yet I'm fighting against top 10s right now.
I keep fighting against top 10s at the moment.
It's actually crazy.
These guys are fucking insane.
I'm fighting for my goddamn life right now.
I swear, I'll return back to normal in- I'll return back to normal in three days when this is all over.
You're right.
I'll either get top 500, or I'm gonna break every pro in my way.
They'll be like, let's play with Doki Bird!
She has clout!
And she's like, she seems really funny.
And then they don't realize they don't realize the fine print when it comes to playing with me.
It's not as fun as you think it is!
It's-
It's not- It's not- It's not as easy!
I'm good.
Oh my god.
Woah!
There's a Wolverine on us!
In the back.
I'm getting into mass, I'm getting busy.
Come here, Mantis!
What's up, bitch?
Okay.
One-way ticket.
Oh my god, Wolverine's on top!
Wolverine behind, Wolverine behind.
Top right.
We're hiding here.
Yeah, we're about to get devious.
He's enjoying his load, Ganon.
No!
Wait, come on, come on.
We're coming over, we're coming over!
Okay, okay.
I'm coming in.
Yeah!
Wait, wait, strangers!
Strangers have- Strangers low, strangers low!
I'm gonna push the cart.
Oh my god, I'm one.
I'm pushing cart.
I got you!
Oh my god.
I can feel it.
I think you're dead.
Oh damn.
Oh my god, what's going on over there?
What's going on?
I'm just- There's a Hulk, that's a sneak.
Wait, I'll taxi you, I'll taxi you.
Oh, Hulk smash time!
I love you, I love you, I love you, I love you.
You're gonna have strangers though.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Please!
Why is it always me?!
It's just me!
Wait,
wait, there's a Wolverine on spawn!
He's trying to spawncap me!
Oh my god!
The Wolverine's coming!
What the fuck is going on?!
Arts are only for doki.
Doki!
Yay!
We beat the top end team!
Thank - This is our first victory against them.
Every time I see a Wolverine, all I think of is like- Ba dum bum bum ba da dum!
Ba dum bum bum ba da dum!
Ba dum bum ba da dum!
Oh my god, my new peak!
Guys, for those who didn't see the- For those who- Who didn't see the video- That - That I sent of my favorite Wolverine meme- Is this.
This is literally my favorite Wolverine meme.
Oh!
My goal- Top 500.
270 should be the cutoff, I think.
It's like- Oh!
Ba dum bum ba da dum!
Animal!
Animal, yeah!
I think 250- 250 or 270 could be the cutoff.
Because there's still- There is- 3 days left of the season.
And it's at 200 right now.
I love that video.
That video lives rent-free in my head.
It actually- Lives rent-free in my head.
Alright, back to the main event.
Guys.
Back to what we actually came here for.
Uh- Maybe- Maybe we'll finally get to- We'll finally make it to like- The third game.
Alright.
Opening it up.
Alright, it's time.
We're back at it again!
This time we'll make it to the third game!
I believe!
This is it.
We're back to- We're back to shrimp game.
We're gonna make it, I swear.
Wait, how much money do I have?
Okay.
How much money do I have in the shop, actually?
Is this a shop?
Oh my god, there it is!
Oh my god, I almost got it!
Alright guys, if I stop leaving after first game, I might be able to afford it.
Oh my god.
Wait, it only expires- Bro, that guy- Are you telling me that guy pushed me once?
That was an actual crime!
He- You can only use it once, and he used that one time to turn around and push me!
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
Oh my god, that's- I - This is a perfect representation of society.
You asked how and he showed you how.
It was- It was not racially motivated, it was fucking VTuber motivated.
He knew.
He knew I was a VTuber and he's like, only fleshies are allowed here.
Revenge for the mutants.
VTuber spotted.
Oh!
Fucking hate these PNGs.
That's right, those goddamn PNGs ruining my games.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Alright, here we go.
PNGs.
PNGmag.
Alright.
Here I go.
We are at almost the 8 hour mark now.
Alright, guys, I swear to god they pushed me.
I swear to fucking god.
Oh my god, they already got pushed?
The game hasn't even started yet!
I'm so scared, I'm so scared.
Don't push me.
Why are these gunshots so- I thought this Roblox was for kids.
Why are the gunshots so realistic?
I'm sorry if it's loud.
Oh my god.
So many.
There's so many people pushing.
My god.
He died?
He made it across!
How did he die?
He died after crossing.
Yay.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I can afford it!
I can afford the push now!
I can push the children!
I need to give my ID to Roblox so I can hear the voice comms.
I hear the voice comms are like the funniest shit.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
I like the video of like- The only reason why I won't play this is that there was a video of these children playing this game and like, it goes so hard.
Did I like it?
I hope I liked it.
Oh, it's this.
It's this.
I think it's this.
There's no way.
Oh, thank god.
From the cookie.
That's why I really want to have voice comms on.
Alright.
Saved.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything will be fine.
Oh my god, why are they walking around?
I don't like that.
I don't like that they're walking around me.
This is so nerve wracking.
I'm sorry.
Not the Mona Lisa.
Yay, we did it.
We made it.
The kids screamed.
That's what I'm saying.
I want voice comms on because the children screaming is so funny.
Okay, I'm sorry.
That's out of context.
But like...
Oh my god.
It's like...
I have a family!
Chants.
It's like...
I swear, children are such good actors now.
That kid screaming that he has a family.
I felt so immersed, guys.
It was so immersive.
I felt like I was there.
I felt like it was real.
It felt so fucking real.
That kid's gonna grow up as a voice actor.
I can feel it.
I can fucking feel it.
For those who missed it, the stakes are real.
It felt like the stakes were actually real there.
Alright.
Oh, it's the merry-go-round.
Which one's me?
Where am I?
I can't tell where I am!
I don't... wait, that's me.
I found me.
I'm like...
That's me!
How?
Get in!
Friends!
You're my friends!
We're friends.
We're okay.
Yay!
We're like...
Top.
Bang, bang, bang.
Yeah!
What?
My door!
Get out!
Oh, that poor girl.
Oh, she made it.
I think we all made it.
We all made it.
Alright.
Did we all make it?
We did it, everybody!
We did it!
Yay!
Bang, bang, bang.
I'm Lily Thanos.
That guy looked like he had... I haven't watched Squid Game Season 2 yet, but he looked like he had so much fun.
Friend, friend, friend, friend.
I'm gonna get there first!
Nice.
Oh, look.
Shelly died.
I got there first.
But I got betrayed.
Nothing personal, kid.
Nothing personal.
I got there first.
I got the ping on my side.
Let's go.
We did it!
Yeah!
Oh my god, wait.
Can I buy it now?
Push.
I can buy.
How do I use it, though?
I spent my money.
How do I use this?
He's not the kid the orphan is.
How do I spend my... How do I use it?
We have one, so we can't use it on these games.
Alright, what's this?
Oh, is this a glass game?
Oh, shit.
What if I just push him off?
Oh, no.
Guys, I don't know.
I feel like...
Can I push them off?
Yes.
How do I push them?
Guys, how do you push?
How do you do it?
How do you push?
It's not P, I tried.
I'm pushing them.
I'm literally trying to push them.
Um, I'm trying.
F?
No, it's not F.
T?
No.
Oh my god, it's so scary, because we're all bunched up.
Right click?
Don't be a hero.
Never be a hero.
Come on, children.
Do it.
Nice.
Bye, children.
Come on.
We know you guys want to.
One of us.
I'll keep waiting.
I'm fine with waiting.
If we all die, we all die together, kids.
Isn't that great?
If we all die, we all die together.
Come on, children.
That's good.
Good job, kids.
Come on, we have two more minutes left.
Worst prisoner dilemma.
Oh my god, he couldn't even make the jump.
How long is this bridge?
There's like six, seven more.
Come on, Sammy.
Get over here.
Come on.
We can all wait here.
I know you all want to wait.
If I could, I would push all of you guys if I could.
I really wish I could.
I literally spent my money on a push and I can't even push you guys.
Shit, I got a game.
Okay.
I can still wait, guys.
Come on, kids.
You know you want to.
I'm not gonna take the jump yet.
I still have time.
The moment I don't have time, I'll play.
There's no way.
Who told me to jump left?
Who was it?
Someone said left.
Don't worry, we still have time.
Come on, kids.
You know you want to.
We can wait here all day.
Children, we can keep waiting.
Come on.
Come on, we can keep waiting.
Stupid ass.
Alright, kids.
You think I care?
I hope the glass breaks.
I have nothing to lose.
This is my secondary game.
I'm here to play Marvel Rivals.
This is my second game here.
We're not gonna make it.
You know we're not gonna make it too.
You fucking know we're not gonna make it if you don't make that jump.
That's fucking right.
You know it.
We have 18 seconds left.
That's right.
We have 15.
You gotta make that jump, Smokemaster.
You gotta make that jump.
That's fucking right.
Now I'm gonna die.
We all die.
It's fine.
And I gotta pick my...
I got an attacker defense.
And then now I get to...
It's fine.
We all die to anyone.
Alright, close game.
I don't know if he wants to play.
If he wants to play...
Don't talk to me.
I'm very tired.
Now we're back to the main game.
We killed another man.
We're back.
I don't know if this comp's gonna work.
Wait, it's that Korean guy!
It's him!
I hope he's okay.
Yay!
We're back.
Yo, Thor.
If Thor doesn't work, are you strange?
Yeah, no.
I'm gonna go back if it doesn't work.
Alright.
Here we go.
I have a goal.
I have a goal to do today.
And maybe tomorrow.
It may be tomorrow.
No, he doesn't believe it.
What do you mean it may be tomorrow?
I don't like that.
I don't like that he said it may be tomorrow.
There's a Widow top right side.
Oh my god.
He doesn't believe that.
I think he stopped believing.
The fact that he's like, it may be tomorrow.
Wolverine's coming over.
No!
What the fuck?
I don't see you guys.
Guys?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
I got so confused.
Oh my
god.
He's going in.
Oh my god, I'm just scared.
Alright, I'm a little scared.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, let's go!
Let's do this!
Let's not do this.
Let's not do this, I guess.
Goodbye.
You know, it was very scary when like, you know.
What happened?
That was very scary.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't.
I can't keep killing you.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
Wolverine behind!
I slept him, I slept him.
I'm a little scared, guys.
Oh my god, I'm a little scared.
Oh my god.
This is a little...
Oh shit, no, fuck that one guy though.
No, you're right, no, fuck him.
Yeah, you're right, he deserved that.
He fucking deserved that.
Wolverine won, Wolverine won.
Jesus Christ.
I got both.
Lift!
We're all so slow.
Oh, he's... yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's so fucked up.
Where am I?
Okay, I'm here.
We're like animals.
Animals.
Magic?
No, mag, mag.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I can solo on cap if you want a moon knight.
Big.
I don't think we...
Just cause the Loki clones, they'll either swap or you can't kill him.
You're fine, you're so healthy.
Who wants a piece of me now?
Badum, badum, badadum.
Did you guys like how I like just stopped talking?
Oh my god, please, no!
I literally was like...
I just ran away.
I had PTSD.
I literally had PTSD.
And just fucking ran.
Peace out.
I was having a fun...
Some fun music time.
Alright.
Did we leave them?
Did we do it?
Oh my god.
No, no!
No!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, what do we do?
Their...
Their team is a lot better.
Bro, that Widow's fucking crazy.
Was it Wakanda?
The Wakanda dip, bro.
That Wakanda...
The Wakanda dip is crazy.
Heal us.
Oh my god.
Bro, fucking...
Wakanda, man.
What do we do about Wakanda?
This is why Wakanda no more.
This is exactly why we...
Wakanda no more.
No, no, no, Wakanda, maybe.
Wakanda's stealing my rank points.
Get them out of my fucking game.
We had a better chance at the last bridge.
Wakanda no more.
I'm gonna expose Wakanda to the world.
This is why...
This is why Wakanda shifts would've wanted to stay isolated.
Wakanda forever.
3, 2, 1.
My rank ruins.
That's not what I wanted.
Sometimes the sensitivity for this is fucking crazy.
Oh my god.
I like how they're like, you know what?
I'm gonna try Widow.
Surely, like, it'll be fine, right?
Oh my god, Wakanda, let's go!
How do I get out of here?
How do I?
Oh shit, okay.
Oh my god, I want to.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking... where do I look at?
Oh wait.
Oh my god, I didn't know where to look at.
Everybody was like, everywhere.
I was like, where do I... where do I position?
Guys, I didn't realize...
Oh.
Wakanda is so good.
Not like, actual Wakanda, but like...
Give you the damage boost.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Like, I don't even...
Please.
Like, where do I go?
Where the fuck is the turret?
Oh no.
It's so low.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's go in.
We're so undefeatable.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
We're so undefeatable.
Let's fucking go.
Oh.
That was my bad.
I hope he doesn't know that I did that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Don't worry.
He doesn't know.
Cause how would he know?
How would he know it was me all along?
How would he...
How would he know?
He doesn't know I woke him up, guys.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't.
There's no way he knows.
Guys, there's no way.
There's no fucking way he knows it was me that woke him up.
He did the fucking sickest sleep of his life and then I fucking woke him up for that.
For it.
There's no way he knows it was me, though.
No.
There's no way.
Alright.
I'll push the cart.
No, no, no.
No, you wouldn't.
You wouldn't, no.
Oh my god.
Oh.
They all just got deleted.
Oh my god.
I literally looked away for one second and then everyone was 100 to 0.
That's crazy.
Dude, no, their Widow is fucking insane.
Someone check his PCs.
Not gonna lie.
Someone check his fucking PCs.
I'm scared.
I wanna get that turret.
Alright.
It's alright.
There's a strange above us.
Don't worry.
I came back for all of you.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
Oh.
We're so healthy.
I think he has...
I think he has ult.
I think the Wolverine has ult.
I'm a little afraid.
I'm a...
I got you.
Oh, that's worse.
There we go.
Okay.
That's fine.
Got it.
He got it.
Oh.
It's fine.
He got it.
It's not fine.
I don't feel fine anymore.
Oh my god.
Okay.
You're right.
You're so right.
You're so fucking right.
What the fuck?
What the...
Oh my god.
You're so right.
Wait.
Magniel's one.
Oh my god.
You're so right for that.
Oh no.
He's...
It's too late.
It was too late.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's okay.
This is a wild game.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-da-dum.
Ba-dum-ba.
Like I...
Oh my god.
Please look at me.
Please.
It's alright.
It's okay.
He didn't pay for this game, but that's alright.
I believe in him.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where's the fear going for?
Where is he?
Oh my god.
I'm ulting this.
We might be slow, but...
It's fine.
Oh shit.
He missed.
What's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
What is going on?
No.
We made it.
What's going on?
My ult is still in shambles after this game.
I'm so sorry, Hyliss.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay, Hyliss.
I've also ruined other people's points too.
It's not just you, Hyliss.
I've also...
I've been fucking over a lot of people today.
LOL
It's alright.
That's the condition of playing with me.
It's okay.
It's not just you.
Don't worry.
It's not...
I think I love how Gomez was like...
I have a goal today.
And maybe tomorrow.
And he said it so dejectedly.
He said it so sadly.
I'm just like...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I love the curse of Doki.
No, they're not giving up.
They're just very dejected.
LOL I don't fucking know, man.
LOL I feel so confident in my team.
I don't...
I don't fucking know, man.
LOL That's what I like to hear.
That's what I like to hear.
Woo!
Oh, wait.
What?
What the fuck?
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Wait, there's...
Can I get rid of this Loki clone?
The Loki's invisible tomorrow.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm scared.
I slept him.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm trying to keep you up.
You go, Pomp.
You go.
Oh, shit.
I'm getting rid of that.
I'm a little scared.
Not gonna lie.
I'm gonna lie.
Whoa.
I will ult first.
Okay.
LOL
Oh my god.
Fear, fear, fear, fear.
No!
I got stuck.
I got stuck on the pulse bomb.
LOL
No!
I got stuck!
I'm so sad.
That hide behind the street.
I got stuck!
I couldn't move!
I was...
All you have to do is sit there and don't let them walk on our supports.
I'll kill their widow.
I hate this.
I literally was trying to move behind, but like the pulse bomb slowed me down.
The pulse bomb slowed me down.
I'm so sad.
I literally couldn't move anywhere.
I was stuck in the sticky.
I was not positioned in a way for the perfect widow to shield me.
Okay, I'll lock in.
I'll lock in.
Oh,
I can't jump that.
I'm too slow.
I'm just a little guy.
Just a sad little guy.
They're off of Wakanda!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is scary to be in.
I like how he's like, they're off of Wakanda.
Ornn's low, man.
Loki's up top.
Manta's asleep on me?
She's low?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
We'll bring low.
We'll bring no passive.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm so stressed out!
But I love Marvel Rivals.
I love Marvel.
Woah!
I slept.
Please.
I have to love this.
Oh my god.
Oh, fear.
Fear.
I tried.
I tried so hard.
Oh my god!
I tried so hard to keep him alive!
Probably not worth it though.
It was so close.
I literally did everything I could to keep him alive.
I was like, here's my leaves.
Take my leaves.
Just keep my leaves.
Oh my god.
Magnio!
Strange, strange, strange, magnio!
Mag-1!
Strange, strange, strange!
I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh my god, I can't believe we did it.
We fucking... oh my god.
They might be... guys.
They could be freed any...
Alright, now on to the real game.
Thank god we won that game so I can actually play the real...
Guys, here's a test.
Will we...
Will we win squid game first?
Or... are we gonna win squid game first?
Or are we gonna get top 500 first?
Alright.
Let's take our bets.
Let's do a poll.
Are we... oh man.
I can't do another prediction because we only have one prediction.
Hell yeah, give up hope for 44.
That means die, die in Chinese.
Let's go.
Here we go.
Alright, let's see where we're gonna...
Are we gonna get squid game win?
Or Marvel rival wins?
This is the real game.
Now it's time for the real...
Real gamer hours.
What's the leaderboard right now?
It's like...
202.
Yeah, but we're trying to get the cutoff.
I hope like...
I hope...
What's their team name?
North something, right?
I don't remember their team name.
But like...
I hope after this session, they realize how good they have it.
After this session, they're like, now that we know her name, let's make sure to avoid her.
Let's make sure to avoid her after this.
In season one.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, I can push.
How do I push?
They never told me how to push.
I have it.
I have it though.
I don't know how to do it.
I wanna push one of them.
Po po po po po po po po po po po po po po po po po.
How do I skit?
I wanna skit.
Oh, there you go.
Alright, the real game starts.
They said we're gonna make it to the end.
I believe in us.
We either...
get to the...
win a squid game...
Or make it to top five or get to the cutoff.
How do I oh there it is.
Oh my god There it is.
I'm gonna push them Do it That was that me oh
My god, they pushed me they pushed me
Oh How do I do it I won't push it I can't push how do I push
I swear to God I'm pushing it Oh, I did?
When the fuck did I use it?
No, no, no, no.
No, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
Don't you want to push me?
Oh, I made it!
I made it.
When did I use it?
Oh, did he die?
Penny with the bottle?
There he is.
We're gonna push you so he can't get in.
We're gonna make a wall.
We're gonna...
Oh!
He pushed me!
We had a wall!
He actually pushed me!
He was like, fuck you.
The anti-kid's wall.
I can't believe he fucking pushed me.
He tried to get in.
He tried to get through the wall!
Freak.
How dare you try to get through the wall?
How fucking dare you?
He knew what you were planning on doing.
Look, it's all about winning.
Guys.
Also, is the game too loud?
I have no idea.
Oh, thank god.
Wait, no.
The circle is... I don't know if the circle's hard.
I have no idea.
I hope the gunshots aren't too loud.
Alright, I can't.
I have to give them my ID.
I have to dox myself.
But like...
But like, I said, I can't.
My god, this is so... Like, this is so stressful.
I can't do it right away.
I'll do it next time.
If we're back at it again tomorrow.
I also don't know how fast the ID approval thing is.
Oh my god, did you guys see that?
No one's dead yet.
Yay!
Did you guys see the Fortnite with Elon Musk stream?
That stream was so fucking funny.
I think my favorite quote was like, NAME THREE WOMEN!
I didn't watch it, but I watched like, clips of it.
I love... I thought it was really funny when... What's his name?
Connor?
That's his name, right?
Connor was like, NAME THREE WOMEN!
WHY CAN'T YOU NAME THREE WOMEN?
And then he wouldn't name three.
No, he didn't!
He wouldn't name three!
No one knows... Like, people were... He's like...
This guy was like, I'm not Elon Musk.
But he sounds exactly like him.
I don't know, maybe it's a really good actor, but...
Yeah, the guy sounds like Elon Musk, but he's like, I'm not Elon Musk.
But he sounds exactly like him.
Oh, more money's being added.
And then, finally, after like, everybody was like, No, there's... Everybody was like, No, you're Elon Musk.
And then he's like, finally admitted that he really is.
Yeah, he finally admitted it on Twitter yesterday.
But I thought it was so funny that he couldn't name three women!
Like, any three women!
Just...
Oh, shit!
Wait, no!
No, wait!
Please!
If it's tug of war again, I can't leave the children again!
Oh, no!
It's tug of...
I'm sorry, children!
I gotta leave you again!
I'm sorry!
Am I even...
Am I doing anything?
I swear to god, I'm pressing X.
I swear to god.
I am... I...
I don't know.
I'm pushing X.
I'm pressing X, but my X key...
I am!
But I'm not!
I'm literally just standing.
I am!
I swear to god, I swear to god, I'm pressing it.
I swear to god, I am actually pressing it.
I don't know why it's not pushing.
Like, I...
Is there a delay?
Is there... Is there a delay?
Like, what do you want me to do?
Like, I'm pressing two things!
It won't let me.
It legitimately won't let me.
Did we win?
We did it, guys!
I contributed to this team!
No.
Oh, no.
We did it, guys!
I contributed!
We did it, kids!
We fucking did it!
I knew we could do it, children.
I knew it.
I knew we could do it.
Are we attack or defense?
If we're attack, I still have one more time to play a game.
Okay, we're defense.
Oh, no.
What game is it?
I can't...
Oh, no.
We're defense.
I'm skating over, guys.
I'm not throwing.
I'm literally... I'm skating over right now.
I'm fucking skating.
I'm skating so hard.
Wait.
Loading.
There's another intermission?
Are you serious?
Are you... Please.
There's... How is there another intermission?
Please.
I have 14...
Oh, my God.
Okay, I can't.
No, I will never know what the last game was.
I'll never know.
I'll never know what the last game was.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
I... Sorry, I got locked in.
I hate healing Iron Man sometimes.
That's why I put a snowflake on him.
But...
It still sucks to heal this.
I fucking hate healing this.
I... I... I...
I...
I froze her.
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I am perfectly okay.
I'm not okay.
I'm not... No.
We're not in queue.
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay anymore.
I have never been not okay.
I hate... I... Oh, my God.
Healing Iron Man has to be like one of...
Oh, my God.
Walk up.
Walk up with this.
No way!
No fucking way!
Oh, my God.
No fucking way.
Let's go back to squid game.
Okay.
I need to be locked back in.
Every time I change from squid game to...
Alright.
I'm totally okay.
I froze him.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
We're okay.
We're so healthy.
No.
Everyone's like, okay, never mind.
I saw the December video.
I thought it was funny.
That's so 2024.
My bad.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I froze him.
Oh!
Okay.
Never mind.
Well, never mind.
Whoa.
There's a hawk up here.
What the fuck?
Yeah, he just emoted.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
I hate you.
I mean, thank you for playing with me.
But...
You're too good at this game.
You think that was...
I have to, like, try so hard to aim.
Because he's trying not to die.
And I'm trying to make sure he gets healed.
But it's so hard to...
It's so hard to heal somebody.
That moves like that.
It's so hard.
Because you have to...
You're, like, killing their movement.
They're good players.
So their movement is so good.
Their movement is so good.
Okay.
Play.
No.
No!
What do I do?
What do I...
Why do I keep getting solo ulted?
It's either...
It's either Magneto or Maximum Pulse.
Yeah, fuck you!
You get solo ulted too!
Please!
Mantis, please!
I just came back!
I'm so sad.
Okay, the Mantis was right there.
Why me?
Why not Mantis?
Kill her.
Kill me.
Oh my god.
You didn't see that.
Kill her!
Luna.
Please.
Oh my god, you let him die!
I saved your life and that's how you repay me?
I saved your life and that's how you fucking repay me?
I'm so sad.
Please!
I'm just kidding.
Ungrateful teammates.
I hate this.
I'm just getting hard focus.
I just let the mods kill me and then flew away.
Okay.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm so fucking locked in.
Okay, I'm locked in for real though.
I'm locked in for real.
After what he did to me, I'm so locked in for real.
I swear to god, I swear!
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Oh my god.
I saw it.
I was so over it.
I did not know where he was but I knew he was close.
Oh no.
Strange half.
Strange low.
Oh
my god.
Strange low, strange left.
Jesus Christ.
No.
Oh
my god.
I had to look up.
I had to look up and be like...
Oh my god.
I had to look up.
I fucking...
Oh my god.
This is actual... Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
We were in the skies.
I was forced to look up.
I was like, please, you're so high up.
You're so high up.
We're not meant to look up.
That's why the sun is there.
Beware of the sun.
Holy shit.
It's been a while.
8 hours.
Shout out to these gamers.
I hope they're okay, mentally.
I hope they're...
I hope they're okay.
They've been with me for 8 hours now.
Almost 9.
They've been here for almost 9 hours.
It'll be fine, right, guys?
It'll be so... Oh, he's dead.
He's...
He's dead.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I was looking at the Hulk.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm just...
There's a lot going on.
There's absolutely a lot going on in this game.
So I'm like...
I'm like trying to figure out what the fuck is happening.
I'm trying to figure it out right now.
Jesus Christ.
I'm so focused right now.
Holy fuck, I'm so focused at the moment.
Okay.
That's fine.
Hello, I'm ready to dance, everybody.
Let's all...
Let's all... Oh.
Let's... Oh.
Hello, everyone.
Hello.
That's fine.
Okay, you're so healthy.
Oh.
It's alright.
Is he okay?
Oh.
That's a little awkward.
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
I mean, he literally got grabbed.
Like, I'd be afraid.
He literally got grabbed out of his fucking life by Hulk.
Like, that shit is traumatizing.
Hulk behind, Hulk behind.
I froze him.
Oh my god.
He's one, he's one.
The reload.
Oh my god, that was pretty cool.
I saw that.
Not gonna lie, that was pretty cool.
Okay.
He has his what on?
Yay!
Yes!
Dance, let's dance.
Let's fucking dance, everybody.
Let's...
Woo!
Free concert right here.
Let's go.
Wait, who's running?
There we go.
I thought he was like, I'm gonna use my girlfriend ult.
I was like, what the fuck is girlfriend ult?
Alright.
Alright, he's moving there now.
Oh my god, guys, I'm sorry, I have to really focus.
This is hell.
Healing Iron Man makes me have to focus even more than I should.
Because Iron Man is such a...
Like his move, he has to do so much movement shit.
Jesus, please.
Please live.
Hulk one still, Hulk one.
Behind me.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Time.
All I do is suffer.
Oh my god, Oh my god, is he okay?
I can't tell.
I can't... please.
I'm not here.
I'm gonna go this way.
Okay.
I'm... don't know what's going on.
I... I don't know what's going on, guys.
Behind us.
I'm frozen.
Okay.
Okay, that's not great.
That's not great at all.
That's not great.
That's not... that's not great.
That's not great, guys.
I...
No.
I'm alive.
Okay.
Strange is low.
Eww.
Okay.
Please.
Oh my god, I died.
Alright.
Okay.
I've never been so stressed in my life, everybody.
And like, I don't know what to do.
Bring me back to Squid Game.
I'm at a B in Squid Game at this point.
Wait.
Strange.
Strange is low.
Strange is one.
There's a Hulk on cart.
Please.
Oh my god.
That game was so stressful.
That game.
Oh my god, that game.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, did we get it?
215 is... Are we in the cutoff?
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Yeah!
We did it!
Guys, are you looking?
Guys, but it's not over yet.
Guys, it's not over yet.
Because we still have the M500.
So we need two more wins.
We need two more wins to secure it.
We're almost there.
We're almost... Oh my god, 333.
I'm fucking a degenerate.
I'm actually a degenerate.
Do you have the most games played?
No, thank god these guys exist.
Thank god.
Oh, thank you doctor for...
Oh, thank you.
I have 333 wins.
That's way too many.
Brosa, thank you for the 150.
Thank you, thank you.
Zesty and Hero, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Pomio, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there I am.
There I am.
Guys, here I go.
We did it, everybody.
We fucking did it.
This is how I feel right now.
Wait, I have a better idea.
Wait, because I don't have the toggle.
I don't have... Wait, actually, before we do it, let me grab...
Look at me, that's me over there, right there.
Oh my god, did you see this?
That's me.
Do another nine hours.
Oh my god.
Where did it go?
Oh, I was fucking...
Holy shit.
Hey, it's Kassadin.
Oh my god, it's Wakanda again.
It's fucking Wakanda.
There he is.
Wakanda came back.
Okay, guys.
Okay, but what if I'm gonna disappear for a little bit?
I'm gonna disappear for a little bit, guys.
Guys, don't worry, I'm still here.
Don't worry, I'm still here.
I just need to add something.
I just need to...
Let me add something real quick, guys.
Okay, let's see.
Right here.
And then...
Okay.
Let me see, where is it?
Alright.
Don't worry.
It'll be so worth it.
It's basically how I feel right now.
It's...
It's basically how we all feel at the moment.
My god, what did I name it?
What the fuck did I name this?
Oh, there it is.
I named it image21.
That makes sense.
Wait, okay.
Okay, let me...
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me adjust this.
Better than me.
There we go.
That's how I feel right now.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
I'm so okay, guys.
I don't know why you don't think I'm okay.
I don't know.
I don't know why you don't think I'm...
Oh, where did it go?
Oh shit.
Oh shit, where did it...
Oh my god, it disappeared.
I don't know what happened.
It disappeared.
Sorry, I don't know what happened to it.
It actually disappeared.
It flew away into the trade.
Immersion ruined.
Where did it go?
Wait, where did it go?
I don't know what happened.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of Wakanda.
It looks like...
I like how that looked.
That sounded really bad at a content.
You don't understand.
I'm scared.
I went through so much.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Take a nap.
Here we go.
That's unlucky.
I didn't think he was gonna eye me.
Hey, Wakanda's on Groot.
You know what, that's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
What?
That's not fine.
Am I addicted to this game?
I'm...
Hmm.
If you'd say addiction as a...
Whoa.
I'm gonna sit here.
Addiction is...
Are you saying it in a negative way?
Oh my god.
He fucking shielded it.
He shielded it.
Whoa.
Is you okay?
Oh my god.
I swear.
I fucking...
I will burn every tree.
I swear.
What am I stuck on?
I...
That's unlucky.
You can't do anything about it.
How did he get his ult so...
He got his ult so fast.
Like, the...
The Luna and I haven't even got it yet.
That's crazy.
Please.
Alright.
Here we go.
First...
Yay!
Oh
my god.
That's fine.
Why is this group still doing his stuff?
Holy fuck.
Okay.
This is so stressful, guys.
This is...
As we get closer and closer to 250.
It's...
These games are getting actual gamer.
I can't fuck around, guys.
I can't fuck around anymore.
Remember when we could fuck around and we could have conversation and then we watch mom and dad get the worst live on stream?
Those were the good old days.
Remember those days?
I don't think we use it here.
I don't remember that one.
I remember.
We all died so fast there.
Can we touch here now?
No.
Alright.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Oh.
I slept him.
I'm dead.
I don't know what happened to me.
What happened to me?
Remember those good old days?
I remember.
Okay, do you not see nothing?
No.
Now games are...
Now games are so sweaty.
Games are actually gaming now.
Woah.
Oh, this fruit is...
Oh.
Woah.
I'm scared.
Change path.
Oh my god.
Wake up.
He's asleep.
It's a dream.
Wake up.
It's not real.
It's fine.
I did it.
Wait, wait.
They're C9.
We're C9.
Go.
I damaged most of you.
Okay.
Wait, they portaled.
There's a stranger stream.
Nice pop.
Oh my god.
C9.
I'm freaking C9.
Holy shit.
That was so close.
Oh, fucking rat.
That was such a ratty play.
TheSpaceDrake, thank you for tier one.
Thank you, thank you.
Brando, thank you for the gifted sub.
1RO, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Shaggy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
JayMay, thank you for the 5 gifted subs.
And Classy, thank you for the 5 gifted subs.
Oh my gosh, there's more.
You have 5, 6, 7, 8.
Thank you for the 8 gifted subs.
Oh my god, there's so many things happened while I was freaking out.
McCrim, thank you for the 5 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
C9.
Basically, C9 is...
Wait, guys.
Oh my god.
I couldn't tap back into my game for a sec.
I was...
I was freaking out.
I almost couldn't tap back into the game.
Alright.
So, basically...
C9 is basically...
Back in Overwatch days, there was a team that would always forget about the...
Get back-capped.
And it was...
It was Surefour's team.
So, he lives through it.
So, his team would get, like, back-capped.
And we would...
Like, several times in the tournament.
And then, because of it...
It's called C9.
Because it was from Cloud9.
Right.
Wait, what?
Wait, there's a Psylocke right here.
Right here.
He's just poking us for free.
He's low.
I just left him.
The Strange is low.
Strange is low.
Strange is still low.
He's half.
Okay.
Nevermind.
We don't care about that Strange.
Woah.
Woah, there.
Woah, okay.
Oh, he's coming for you.
Oh my god.
I'm waiting for my leaves.
Give me health, give me health.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, I gave you a leaf.
You're welled up, you're welled up.
Yeah, you're welled up.
I can't get to you.
Okay.
You can measure it.
I'll match it.
I see sleeping.
Keep going, keep going.
Come on, Groot.
There's a Lunar Chair left.
Oh my god.
Why is she still alive?
She lived for so long.
I'm just looking.
I'm like, are you guys okay?
There's four of you and one Luna.
I'm like, there's four of you.
Are you guys okay?
That's pretty cool.
That's neat.
Oh my god, I'm trying to do it to the...
Alright.
Whoa, where did the Psylocke go?
I don't ever know.
The grid is half.
I'm damage boosting you for it.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Backing up.
Keep going.
We were a little bit too deep.
Whoa.
You're still...
I slept.
Oh, I didn't sleep.
Whoa, let's go, let's...
Where am I?
Who's my Luna?
What?
Oh.
That's lucky.
Grid slow, grid slow.
Did I grab it off?
I guess.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I'm like, I got it off, but then they did everything.
Am I shooting anything?
I can't tell.
It's fine.
They used it in the first engagement.
Oh, they got it.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Okay,
goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Wait, how did you die?
Okay, this is fine.
Oh my god, how did I jump so high?
I feel like a star.
They have grid all soon.
Oh.
Oh, thank god.
I can't see anything!
Grid one, grid one!
Oh.
Nice.
Oh my god, nice!
How did we live?
They still have no sportals.
They're gonna be close though.
Yeah.
I don't know how I lived that.
I don't know.
Damage boost here.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what the fuck happened?
What?
What's going on?
Let's change our point, let's change our point.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
I just...
There's too many stuff on my screen.
Oh my god.
There's way too much stuff on my screen.
That shit was a fucking shitshow.
That was actually a fucking shitshow what I had to watch there.
Alright, time for the real game.
Alright, intermission's over.
Intermission's over.
We're ready for our true passion.
Alright.
Back to the real game.
We time for the main event.
We did it.
Finally, it's shrimping time.
Time to push some children.
You're right.
Do I have to buy it again?
No, okay.
Okay.
Oh, what can I have?
Oh, I can buy these?
How much is it?
Cosmetics?
Products?
Wait, I want a...
Fifty...
Ten mil?
Who's wearing one right now?
Nobody can afford that.
Oh my god.
Sir, this is squid game, sir.
Sir, this is...
This is...
Get it out, bro.
What is this?
I just got here.
Look, we're...
Queues are long.
Okay, guys?
So, we gotta...
We gotta make time pass by.
I cannot be in the training range for another 15 minutes.
I cannot do that, guys.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, there's Goku.
Oh my god.
Hey, Goku.
Don't get mad my cosmetic doesn't show up.
I'm just...
I'm just Mr. Roblox guy.
Oh my god, Goku from Dragon Ball and Squid Game?
What number is Goku?
Number 40?
Alright, number 40.
I'm 224.
Low-key chill guy.
Wait.
How come his...
Did he pay for this game?
Why is he in a tuxedo?
Is Goku a do-less?
Wait, why are they in tuxedos?
What the fuck?
Alright, I'm ready.
We're gonna win a game.
We're gonna win this Squid Game.
I'm fucking ready.
How do I skip?
Skip.
Why is the police there?
Skippity.
Oh my god.
These are actual children.
Did you guys see like the exhibit?
Where...
In Korea.
And they put out like this little...
A children exhibit of Squid Game.
And then all the kids were like posing with like the guards and stuff.
As if like...
What?
How do I push?
Alright, I'm pushing.
I'm ready to push.
I'm ready to push you.
I'm gonna fucking push you.
Why would you cheat in Squid?
Why?
Why would you cheat in Squid Game?
In Roblox Squid Game.
I think somebody has a sound.
Oh, there was a loud noise.
Like a lag spike.
I was like, what?
Push, push, push.
Come on.
Let me push you.
Bro, that's fucked.
That's so fucked.
I wanted to push.
Oh my god.
I didn't get to use it.
I'm gonna use my push now.
I'm so sad.
Look at all these dead people over there.
Damn, she almost died.
Alright, what's our next game?
How did you get here?
What?
Why were you out here already?
Alright, grief the children.
We haven't got the umbrella yet, so I think we're fine.
Thank god.
I think we got all the shapes, but the umbrella.
Yeah, how the fuck did he get here before us?
I wanna know what the Mona Lisa looks like.
Yeah.
Not the Mona Lisa.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay, guys, I gotta lock in.
It's one out of four!
We can do this.
Guys, we have a minute, so it can't be that bad.
I play video games for a living, so I have the hand-eye coordination for this.
I have a minute, guys.
Guys, I have stable fingers, so it's fine.
Slow and steady.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I thought that was me.
I thought...
Oh, it was the guy next to me.
Holy fuck.
I thought...
It was the guy next to me.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I thought I fucked it up.
Like, at the finish line.
Oh my god.
My soul left my body.
Bro, same.
Oh my god.
That died me.
I legitimately thought it was me.
That was crazy.
That was fucking crazy.
It was the guy next to me that died.
Holy shit.
That stressed me out.
Yeah, that scared me.
That really scared me there.
Alright, here we go.
That was a movie.
Right there.
Alright.
That $1,900,000.
That's mine.
I can feel it.
I think...
I think this is it.
I think this is the moment where I'm gonna get that money.
Oh, did Goku die?
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
Guys.
Yeah.
I'm with Thanos.
Bing, bing.
Bing, bing, bing.
What a riddle.
Yeah!
Guys, please.
We got...
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys.
Guys, I'm a little scared.
What if...
You know.
This song is going to...
There's three of us.
Oh, thank god.
We made it.
Did anyone else not make it?
Oh, there's that one guy right...
Oh!
That poor guy.
There you go.
Yeah!
Nothing bad's gonna happen to...
We're fine.
Yay.
See?
Everything's okay.
Everything is okay.
I think everybody made it.
Everybody made it.
Nobody died.
Oh.
Except for whoever that guy was.
Yeah, boy.
And pay it.
Thank you for the Twitch prom.
Thank you.
Thank you for the gifted sub.
Another one?
Okay.
Yeah.
This is mine.
Yes!
No!
This is mine.
This is mine!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I made it.
Oh my god.
Someone died.
She did it.
Make it.
That poor woman.
I'm sorry.
That child lived next to the server.
There's no way.
That child actually lived next to the server.
More stressful than the top 500 tried.
Almost betrayed by the ping.
There.
That child lives next to the Roblox servers.
It's understandable.
There's only a two, four, six, eight of us left.
There's only eight of us left.
And I'm gonna win that 2.3 million dollars.
Alright.
Oh, is this the glass bridge again?
Guys, nobody's gonna fucking make it through.
There's no way.
I don't think- and there's no way.
This is way too long.
That bridge is way too fucking long in general.
All right, somebody make- he's examining.
He's...
Examining the bridges right now.
Like, do it kitty cat.
Come on, examine that bridge.
What do your eyes tell you?
All right.
What do your other eyes say- I'm just gonna wait here.
I- like, if they make it all the way to the end, then I'll be impressed.
Come on, what do you- playing chicken right now?
Let's just- Okay.
Feel like I'm gonna miss the jump too, I feel like.
I feel like that's gonna happen.
I'm just gonna miss the jump.
Come on, do it.
Do it, be a hero.
Be a hero, guys.
You got it.
Oh.
Now I'm scared of missing this.
Be a hero.
He did not got- come on!
Make the- did he just eat?
I don't eat too.
What do I eat?
I have it selected.
Oh, he did it.
All right.
Aw, that's all right, buddy.
That's why you're a sheep.
You gotta be a sheep.
Eat a honeycomb.
I- it's like right at the bottom, but I don't know how to eat yet.
Oh.
So you gotta be a sheep.
Gotta let all these guys die for the cause.
Come on, there's three left.
There's four left.
There's four left and there's- Wait, where did that other guy go?
There's four left and there's five of us.
Come on.
Do it, you know you want to.
Come on, you don't want to be a sheep no more.
Aren't you tired of living this monstrous life following orders?
Don't you want to, you know, make a name for yourself?
Pfft.
He's just like, parkour!
Does he even remember which one?
Parkour!
I can wait.
I can wait forever.
Oh, last one.
Come on.
It's you and me.
Wait, oh, he had a revive?
Bro, that's cheating!
You have revive?
I'm back from squid game?
You can't just- That's not in the rules of squid game.
If you lose, you lose.
You're already rich, what do you need the money for?
You're already- You're already rich.
What do you need the- Oh!
The rich people telling me!
The non-VIP to go first!
Wow!
I see how it is!
I fucking see how- Of course!
You see me, the non-tuxedo guy!
You want me to go- No.
No.
That ain't it, buddy.
That ain't fucking it.
Come on.
Alright guys, 50-50.
It wasn't left!
You're right, it wasn't- Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it in 20 seconds.
If I do it, I win everything.
Oh my god!
The rich gets richer!
The rich just simply get richer!
I knew it!
We'll never climb out of the slums!
And the poor gets poor.
Of course the tuxedo men win this!
What a cruel way to crash out.
I'm just a pawn in their sick games.
I truly am.
Not in squid game.
You don't eat anything.
You just die.
Oh my god.
It's so cruel.
Life really is cruel.
Oh my god.
What's my record right now?
What's my actual- Oh my god, I've never seen a road this bright before.
I've never seen a road this bright and beautiful in my life.
It's actually crazy.
You guys don't see it right now, but like- I have a golden road of victories.
And it's so- It's- I've never seen it before.
I'm playing the real game.
I'm playing a game that truly matters in my life.
The yellow brick road.
Alright.
Here we go.
That's right.
With 12 year olds and their mom's credit cards.
One of them paid me off the throw.
Two tuxedo men told me to take the jump and I did.
I thought I could finally be rich.
Just like them.
And then I got baited.
And then the rich one-
Sniped me in Squid Game Roblox.
Please.
Please, we need one win, guys.
Just one win.
We made it so far.
We actually- We actually made it so far.
You know our estimated queue time was two minutes?
It's been 17 minutes.
I played these games.
Before.
How do I push?
Oh my god, he just pushed her.
This is a long- Whoa.
Hello, sorry, buddy.
Whoa, sorry, buddy.
You pushed somebody.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He's just pushing.
No.
What?
That's it, that's it, that's it.
God, please.
Oh my god.
Let me push, let me push, let me push.
How do you push?
I made it.
Make a wall, make a wall.
Don't let them through.
Make a wall.
Oh my god.
Make a wall, don't let them through.
That's right.
I don't know.
I still don't know how to push.
I still don't know how to use the push button.
How do you use the push button?
Guys, did anyone else play this?
Does anyone know what the push button is?
Is it F?
E?
It's not E.
I tried E, but it's not E.
It won't let me push.
Maybe it's F.
I'll try F next time.
I have a million dollars.
Nice.
Oh, fuck that tuxedo.
I can't believe I paid to win that.
That's actually crazy.
I'm sad.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yay, circle!
The easiest one.
Alright.
Oh, you're looking at me.
Alright, here we go.
That's right.
I have the perfect hand-eye coordination.
I've done the umbrella.
I've done the star.
And I've done the triangle.
There's nowhere else to go but up.
Woah.
This is a little stressful.
Oh, thank god.
No one got shot.
Good for them.
Oh my god.
That poor child.
I thought he made it.
He got up.
I thought he made it just like me.
What did I do?
I was just happy for us.
I get the Mona Lisa.
The doki curse lives on.
It lives on.
Star looking.
Yay!
That song is so addicting.
Like, it's in the earworm.
It's like the...
This song is such an earworm.
This is a long queue.
How long has the queue been?
It's been...
Oh, they restarted the queue.
Oh, the estimated time has now become unknown.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Ba -dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
No, no, no, no!
Oh my god.
The match popped up.
Go, go, go, go.
Please, we need one more.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
We got in.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, he still thinks he's Adam.
Is everybody okay?
Ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Yeah!
Please, please, somebody come in.
Help me be my friend.
Friends!
Yay!
It's okay, we still have time.
I want to make sure other people...
I want to cuck other people from these doors before I leave.
I want to make sure these other children die before I leave.
Yeah!
Ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Oh shit, do I miss a lucky hero?
There we go.
Oh shit.
No!
I'm down, I'm down!
Get in!
Get in there!
Please!
Get in!
Yay!
Holy shit!
Yippee!
We did it!
Alright, now I leave.
I'm happy that I...
that I got two people killed.
That...
Thank you, brother.
I love you.
I'm happy about that.
Two people died because of me.
Oh my god.
Like, nothing happened.
It was worth it.
It was so worth it, honestly.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I can't tell.
I feel down.
Oh shit.
It's strangers though.
I'm capping point.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm so locked in.
Guys, after destroying those children, nothing can stop me now.
Nothing!
Damn, no!
After After ruining those kids' time and watching them.
Legitimately just watching them.
Wait.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
I was like, those sound like... that sound like footsteps.
What the hell?
Oh.
Yeah, man.
I'll let you run out first.
Oh yeah, sure.
I don't think we need it yet.
Help me, help me, help me.
I'm gonna use it.
Woah!
Come on!
Well, three, two, one.
Wolverine!
Oh.
Oh, please!
Where is it?
Where did the medicine?
What happened to the medicine?
We could have lived!
It's fine.
I wanted to get against anyway.
That's fine.
It makes the things, it makes the journey much more rewarding, you know?
Oh!
Oh my god!
I just saw a man die in front of me.
Dude.
I saw him die.
It was crazy.
Oh my god.
Truly fucking wild.
What I had to watch there.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Here, here, here.
There's a wolverine nearby.
I'm ulting this.
Oh my god.
The wolverine is behind us.
Okay.
The wolverine is like in our spot.
I'm going for him.
He's low, he's low!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Max one, or not one half.
Alright then.
I'm a little scared about that.
I'm on the point!
I got pulled.
Wolverine left.
He has again!
Yeah!
Oh, we did not need that.
Okay.
Whoa!
That was a little overkill guys.
Bro, fuck that one guy in particular.
I don't know who he killed, but like fuck that guy!
Fuck that guy!
That guy did not...
You know what?
Yeah, we just hate that man in particular.
Get the trick done and end them.
Oh my god.
One more round.
I think we need to win one more game after this to secure...
I don't know.
I can't tell if the cutoff is...
If it's gonna be 250 or 270.
I feel like 270 is safe, but then it feels like I'm greedy.
I feel really greedy.
They're like, wow!
We got you all the way here.
Hey!
500 is true.
Might as well just aim for 500.
Might as well.
En route.
Oh fuck it, I'm slapping.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I just got my ult.
I'm not gonna use it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's hiding in plain sight.
Guys, if you're stream sniping right now, he's over here.
Alright.
Why would...
Then we know they're stream sniping!
That's basically it.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I should've ulted that.
Not my bad.
Oh my god.
I just didn't think he would get deleted.
I was like, whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright.
So I wanted to know if they were actually stream sniping me, you know?
I wanted to know.
If he died from that, then I know they have my stream on a second monitor.
It's just that easy.
It's like the most easiest way to figure it out.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I'm saving you.
I'm saving you.
You're so healthy!
I had it ready for it.
I'm not okay.
That did not feel okay there.
It's okay.
I'm okay now.
Jesus Christ.
Oh no!
Wait, their exchange is low too?
Here.
Oh my god, his mic spiked there.
That like...
That like woke me up.
That actually woke me up there.
That mic spike.
I am brute.
Oh!
Oh
my god, you're all okay.
You're all so healthy.
You're so fucking healthy.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
I'm backing out now.
What?
The
fuck?
Wait, there's a...
Luna to your left.
Yay!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
GG so fun.
Had a blast.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I like the squid game!
I actually don't know if this was...
Thank god I have UFO.
What am I...
Oh shit, we're doing another one more.
Oh my god, we're doing one more.
Okay, let's...
I feel a little...
I feel a little fucking feisty here.
Let's go.
Where am I?
224.
Okay, but this is the cutoff.
203.
Okay.
Alright.
Now back to the real game.
That means I still have a chance.
Guys, I still have a chance to win a squid game.
Guys, I still have another chance.
One more game and we're secured.
And then we're gonna...
Oh my god, I hope we don't lose that one game.
I hope we don't fly too close to the sun, guys.
I hope we don't fly too close to the sun.
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
I don't think they want to come back tomorrow, so we're gonna...
They're gonna try and get this all done today.
Don't worry, don't worry.
No, it's not gonna jinx.
It only happens to the children.
That's fine.
The jinxes only happens to them.
Be careful, Icarus.
Be careful, fly.
Fly right up to that stupid sun.
It's okay, this is it.
The real game is here.
Honestly, I think it is.
Ever since...
Ever since we started playing squid game, we've been winning.
That's actually crazy.
That's crazy.
We've actually started winning because we've been playing squid game on the side.
I don't even know if I'm locked in anymore.
I let out all my jinxes in squid.
I basically gave my jinxes and bad luck to the children.
And then we win.
Yeah, the 12 year olds are getting it.
Instead of me.
Thank God.
Thank God for the 12 year olds.
The cries of the kids.
Get me...
Get my adrenaline going.
What the fuck?
Exactly.
Losing squid game, winning rivals.
Boom, boom, boom.
How do I skip cutscene?
Oh, there you go.
I skipped it.
Maybe it's spacebar.
I'm gonna try and push the children.
Yeah, I know.
I've seen them use the soundboard for like every...
Every other...
Every squid game equivalent.
So like Call of Duty, Fortnite, Roblox, but I don't have voice chat because I didn't dox myself on Roblox.
How do I...
It's not...
It's not F.
I'm going in.
Come on.
Oh, there's some new players here.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm trying to figure out how to push guys.
It's not E.
Is it enter?
I need to make sure I don't jump accidentally.
I did.
I pressed 1 though.
I have equipped.
I do have it equipped.
Press 1, then left click.
Oh my god, that is it.
I used it.
I was running when I used it.
Oh my god, wait.
Make a wall.
Come on.
Come on, lady.
Get over here, lady.
We're gonna push you.
Come on.
We're here.
We're making a wall.
I figured it out.
I figured out how to push.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
That's right.
That's fucked up.
Make a wall, children.
Make a fucking wall.
You can't.
You can't save the push in glass game.
I tried.
All you get is a fucking honeycomb to eat in front of people.
That's all I could do.
All I could do was just eat my honeycomb.
Also, Sean, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Alright.
Yay, a circle.
Yeah.
96 versus 79.
Do you know these are children names right there?
The little crap.
31.
I just played an insane Marble Rivals game.
I can survive a circle.
My...
Every time.
Our team lived.
Let's go.
Guys, our team lived.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
Every time that gunshot fucking freaks me out.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
We lived.
Guys, we're survivors.
Yeah, see, I can eat my honeycomb right here.
I did it.
I just ate it.
That was the munch sound.
I survived again.
I survived another day.
We're back to figuring out.
If I'm gonna get a secure top 500.
Or win.
Or win a squid game.
Which is first.
There's still hope.
We can't gamble.
Because we already gambled already.
We can't gamble anymore.
We have to wait until the end result.
To finish our gambling.
Another day, another munch.
Munch.
Oh.
Another intermission?
I don't understand the extra intermission.
Oh, they add more money.
That's what the intermission is.
Did he die?
Oh!
I didn't realize he...
Oh my god.
A fucking pay to win.
That's what I...
Oh my god.
I actually...
I actually almost got shanked again.
And so...
I almost died to a shank again.
Oh my god.
I couldn't let that be my legacy.
I couldn't let go.
I like this guy's...
I like this guy's costume.
And Toki came back on the fifth day.
Guys, I almost got shanked again.
Like, that's so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Responded to a fucking crew of shankers.
Friend?
Turn up.
Oh god.
Wait.
Yes!
Oh my god!
I got the cat man!
Cat man!
Let's go, cat man!
Let's watch the people die.
Oh, are they gonna make it?
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, she's still alive.
Oh.
Oh, there's her cold, dead body.
Children!
Get away from that body!
Get in here.
Friend.
Friends!
Get in here!
Please!
Glasses man!
Oh my god.
We did it.
Glasses man, I knew you'd be my friend.
I knew you'd be my friend.
Yay!
Oh, everybody lived.
Yeah.
No.
No!
Please, somebody come live with me!
Please.
Oh my god, Gumball.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we lived.
Gumball, you and I.
You and I.
We lived.
Oh my god.
I knew we got this together, friend.
You and I, Gumball.
010912.
Oh.
Gumball?
Hello?
Guys.
Guys, I'm still here!
Guys!
Let me out!
Guys, please!
I'm still in this game!
Gumball was never real.
Hey guys, I sorta got locked in.
I got locked in, but I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Okay, I got locked in.
It was a little freaky.
What the fuck?
You can do that?
But I got baited the jump.
I hate this music.
This music is so ominous.
Oh, goodbye, sir.
That's why you become sheep.
That's why you are.
We gotta be sheep, guys.
There's no point in trying to be a leader.
There's no point.
Come on, take the jump.
Wait, how do I type in the Roblox chat?
My dad works for this game, and it's usually and it's usually the right side.
See, it worked.
Now they'll think I'm right.
See, look at that.
Oh my god, it's working.
No way.
Oh my god, now they'll think it's always right.
That's crazy, bro.
Oh my god, it's actually working.
See, I said it's usually right.
I gaslight them into thinking, oh my god, wait a minute.
Wait, am I fucking psychic?
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, what the fuck?
What is it?
What?
No way.
Oh my god, no fucking way.
Wait, no fucking way.
That's crazy.
I told you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I was actually right.
I told you guys, it's usually right.
I've played these games before.
Oh my god, I've never got this far before, guys.
I've never got this far before.
This is crazy.
I literally had like wall hacks on and could see where the gas was.
Okay, what's this?
Wait.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh.
Wait, why are they...
Why is he walking to me?
Come on, that's right.
Give it up.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Oh, they're starting.
They're starting the brawl.
That's fucking right.
I'm running now.
Whoa.
That's fucking right.
I'm not.
Whoa.
I just gotta get away.
He's crazy.
Pink man is crazy.
Pink guy is crazy.
He has nothing to lose.
Pink man has nothing to lose.
Why are you targeting me?
Oh my god.
Pink guy is crazy.
Wait.
No.
I fell.
My god.
I got hit.
I got hit there.
Iron fist time.
You're right.
It's iron fist time.
We're playing iron fist.
I got tapped out.
There's nothing to lose.
And everything to gain.
He really has nothing to lose here.
He's just gonna throw fucking hands.
Oh my god.
I don't know who's low.
I'm gonna go.
I'm sneaking in.
I'm sneaking.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit.
There we go.
I have nothing to lose too.
Get over here.
Oh no.
Not me.
I just gotta live.
I just gotta live 19 more seconds.
No.
I just gotta live.
Bro, he's just locked in.
His fist is magnetized to me.
Holy shit.
He's actually...
Oh my god.
Get away from me.
Two seconds.
Two.
One.
I lived.
I can't fucking stop me.
I can't stop me.
They all targeted me.
They all fucking targeted me.
Oh my god.
There's Gojo.
I didn't know we had...
There was no instructions.
It was just...
It was just start punching.
How was I supposed to know?
All they told me to do was start punching.
How was I supposed to know there was more?
That was literally my only instruction.
How was I supposed to know?
Survival of the fittest.
Oh my god.
That was more intense than Marvel Rivals.
They all just started punching.
Okay.
Oh, when the time runs out and no one dies, that's good.
All the... I'm glad.
I'm glad they all died.
I'm so happy.
I'm so fucking happy.
Alright, I'm still in queue.
I checked.
Okay, now I know that's like shank hours.
Like when...
It's like nobody was shanking when I was like just chilling in the bed.
This is like the first time I've had people start shanking.
That's why I'm gonna save my pay to win for that punching game.
I'm just gonna be like surprised I'm here.
I'm gonna go punching and I'll punch as many kids as I can in Roblox.
In Roblox, everybody.
And then like after that...
After that, I'm just gonna revive myself and then I'll...
And then...
And then I'll win.
I got the strat now.
What a save.
Quick disclaimer by the way, in Roblox.
I'm just gonna... I'm gonna punch the children in Roblox.
Like this.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you.
I'll show you guys how I'm gonna do it.
Watch this.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
Get... get pushed.
Get pushed.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Oh.
Get... get punched.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
King Ray.
I'm coming for you.
Oh.
Oh man.
That's fucking right.
I'm going.
I'm coming for this girl.
I'm going for the Tom.
Tom, whatever.
I'm coming for you.
Come on.
Oh.
Push Gojo?
Did he make it?
Oh, he made it.
Make a wall.
Oh no.
That's right.
Make a wall.
We're not letting you through.
Come on.
Oh, you think we're gonna let you?
You think... you think we're gonna...
I think...
I'm out.
I tried to turn around and push somebody.
Oh, and I... I wanna do what they did to me.
I wanted...
I was trying to push somebody up.
This is it.
I believe.
I fucking believe.
Right here.
Right now.
This is it.
This is a game changer moment.
That's me.
I'm gonna be top.
Bang.
Boom.
Are you broke?
I am so tempted to buy robux.
I'll just buy them or I'm broke.
Children are so cruel.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh, you guys don't see that?
Oh my god.
These kids.
These kids are shaming each other for not having robux.
He called a child a brokey.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Poor child.
Alright, circle tab.
I'm getting better at this.
Those gunshots just don't faze me anymore.
It's like life now.
Yay!
It's like another child got shot.
In robux.
Yay!
Alright.
Yippee!
We did it!
We survived another hour!
I've become numb to the gunshots.
I got used to it.
I don't know if that's bad.
I think that's pretty bad.
I got used to it.
Alright.
Bum bum bum.
I should buy purple hair so I can be Thanos.
I actually haven't watched Squid Game 1 or 2.
I've just like seen the clips and I read, like, I've seen the clips and I read the summaries of it.
I feel like I'd be way too sad if I actually watched the full season.
Like, it sounds incredibly depressing.
Yeah, 2's already out.
That's where the mingle...
Hello, Gojo.
Hello.
I need my honeycomb in front of him.
Bang, bang, bang.
Boom, boom.
I love Big Bang.
What is it?
Big Bang?
Oh, nice.
I used to listen to their music a lot.
They were like BTS before BTS was a thing.
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Woo!
What the fuck?!
Just because I'd rather buy cheeseburger doesn't mean I'm fat.
Shut up!
My god, children.
Holy shit!
Kids are so mean!
Oh my god!
Why are kids so mean?!
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Get over here!
Please!
There's 4 seconds left!
No!
Don't shoot me!
I'm coming back.
I'm back!
It's fine.
I lived.
I don't have to play that stupid game.
I don't want my death because I don't have friends.
I don't want that to be me.
Guys, I don't want my death to be because I don't have friends.
Wait, wait a minute.
Did I glitch out?
Wait, am I gonna get shot?
Wait, I paid 75 robux.
Am I gonna get shot?
Oh no.
What do I do?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I broke the game.
I broke the game.
Oh my god, thank god.
Yay!
I don't need friends.
I pay to win.
I I don't want to die friendless and alone.
I'm just now I'm friendless alone but a winner.
I don't want to die friendless alone and a loser.
I'd rather I'd rather be friendless alone and a winner.
Money is the only I would keep.
I love these.
How long is the cupid?
I don't know.
I played three games of roblox already.
Yay!
We did it.
What's the next game?
Guys, I was with you guys.
Oh my god, that was an insane game everybody.
Wait, Gojo's dead.
Wait, where did Gojo go?
Oh my god, Gojo's dead.
Oh my god.
What happened?
Gojo didn't make it.
He died friendless.
He died alone.
Oh my god, it's the last place again.
Alright, watch this.
Okay.
Alright.
My dad works for this My dad helped make this game.
And he told me that usually it's the right most of the time.
Okay, but now it's not working because it's on the left side.
Oh, see, look.
See, it's working.
See, guys?
Look at that.
It works.
Now they're gonna go right again because I said that.
Oh my god, it's not working because it went left.
Now it's actually left.
Oh my god, there's 20 of us.
One of you, oh my god, see, since it's usually right, they're actually gonna think I'm right.
They're gonna be like, wait, she, oh my god, maybe her dad does work, did make this game.
Maybe her dad, look, see, that's what you get for not believing my dad.
That's what you get for not believing my dad.
You should have, you should have believed my dad.
Hey, Koro.
Oh, see, look at that.
That's what you get.
Wait, that's what you get.
Oh, yeah.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it's usually the right.
Okay.
It's usually the right side.
It's usually it.
Come on, children.
Come on.
Oh, wait, it's left this time.
What the fuck?
What a twist.
Wait, if I wrote I'm hacking right now, would they ban my account?
I'm hacking right now.
Can you go right?
Oh, I wanna be part of the crew.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Wait, what was two?
Wait, what's the pull?
What was the pull?
Alright, watch this.
I have walls.
Wait, actually.
Usually, I play I've been playing for like for like five hours.
And usually, they make it to the right.
No.
God damn it.
I can't believe it's left.
Now they won't believe me anymore because it went left.
Now they won't believe me.
Alright, guys.
31 seconds, everybody.
What the fuck is this pattern?
It's like left, right, left, right.
Okay.
So I did three already.
Someone else help.
I did two.
Wait, he lived?
How did he live?
What?
Hacker.
Toki, why?
Why?
You're a child.
How do you remember?
How does he know?
How did he keep track?
Toki, why?
You're supposed to be a child.
How did he know?
Oh my god, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
What if he start punching me?
Guys, I played this game before.
No.
Oh my god.
Woah.
What if we just...
I'm fucking defending my circle.
I'm defending it.
That's right.
One of us has to die.
Hey.
Won't it be funny?
I'm about to get very silly.
Yeah.
How silly, my dude?
How silly?
Woah.
That's pretty silly.
What happened to being silly, guys?
Wait, do I just have to stand in these circles?
Is that it?
No?
Woah!
The most HP wins?
What the fuck does that mean?
Oh, it's a battle royale?
Oh shit.
Wait, maybe if I...
Alright, I have a lot of HP.
Oh my god.
Let's get him.
Let's fucking get this one guy.
Yeah, that's right.
Let's get this guy.
You got this.
You fucking got this, I believe.
Oh my god.
What?
How did he live?
How did the other guy live?
Wait.
But there was two of us.
The punch him.
Wait, I did it!
Oh my god.
I thought we did it.
I thought me and him.
We were tight like that.
No one.
I thought we were both close like that.
We were both tight like that.
What happened?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe that happened.
Guys, I don't understand the absolute explanations.
This has been my fourth Roblox game.
These queues.
This has been my fourth one.
This is a long queue.
We literally need one more.
That's the most fucked up part.
We need one more game and then we'd all be free.
Shout out to Gomez for sticking out.
Kurova fucking head to bed.
He was like, I'm fucking heading to sleep.
I won't say gave up but he's like, these queues are too long.
It's way too late now.
Shout out to Gomez for sticking it out.
Our first victim was Mace.
Our second was Kurova.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that face?
Shout out to the entire squad for like making it this far.
Oh my god, we got a game!
Okay, I gotta punch a child first before I have time.
Legitimately have time.
I legitimately have time.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Where are all the children at?
C'mon, c'mon.
C'mon, let me...
C'mon.
If we lose, you gotta do two more probably tomorrow.
I was like, you gotta lock it and I'm right here playing Roblox.
Everyone, please, do it.
If only he knew.
If only she still locked it.
Oh my god, I made it just in time.
Make a wall!
Make a wall, children!
Make a wall.
I'm ready.
Make a fucking wall.
Don't let the guy in.
Don't let them in.
Nevermind, I'm gonna fucking go.
C'mon, you know you want me.
You know this is gonna happen.
Alright, alright.
I'm locked in.
Oh my god, I'm fucking Raccoon.
Okay, this is a little concerning.
This is a little concerning.
I saw a Raccoon player.
Alright.
Don't worry about it.
One of them's a Raccoon.
Okay, we got it.
Alright, goodbye Roblox.
We almost won that one game.
I like how Gobus was like we probably have to get it tomorrow.
Alright, you're chillin' then.
We'll play around it.
And then if we can't, then I'm gonna blame you.
When you have a burn out, I disappear.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
4 3 2 1 What is he doing?
I don't think so.
Oh.
Nope, we're just walking the weirdest pathway I've ever seen.
Alright.
Let's just casually walk to high ground, guys.
Wait.
She's low, she's low, she's 1.
Why did it take us 20 years to- wait, I'm 3 slow.
Why did we- okay.
There's a Magneton on point.
Magneton on point.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Oh my god.
Oh my- I froze- I froze Strange.
Oh, the item!
The item!
Oh, that was so close.
Why did we not kill the Magneto?
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
We didn't kill- we didn't kill Magneto there.
Why did we not kill the turret?
Did you see the turret that free farm?
I'm still as old.
Fear, fear, fear.
He's 1, he's 1!
I got Nemo.
Focus Strange, Strange on point!
Strange 1, Strange 1.
Magneto, Magneto.
Oh my god.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in.
Oh my god.
You almost fucking died.
But I'm still locked in.
Alright.
What?
You have no morale here.
I froze Strange.
Oh.
I have an ult.
I'm ulting.
I'm pushing up with it.
Woah.
Woah, we should help her.
We'll be in it.
I have to reload.
Oh my god, they're horde chasing me.
Wait, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag 1.
Nice,
nice, we got port.
No!
I'm keeping them up.
The Strange is chasing you?
Nevermind.
Strange half, Strange half.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's frozen, he's frozen.
He's half again?
Oh my god, please.
They have Strange ult here.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead.
I froze Strange, I froze Strange.
He got healed.
He's looking for ult, he's looking for ult.
I'm sorry.
Every time I...
Every time I see him, I just think...
Mantis is trying to run.
Do you have TP for spawn?
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Did they actually?
This is one last push.
And then we're all free and I'm back on YouTube.
Oh my god.
My Luna thinks purple is healing.
Is it?
That's rough.
That's rough, buddy.
Oh.
That's a...
That's a gear up, buddy.
Oh my god.
I told you guys.
The ROBLOX...
The ROBLOX saved me.
I let up my bad luck in ROBLOX.
Was she using the bug and I got stuck?
I told you guys.
The bug...
Oh my god.
We're gonna be free, guys.
We're gonna be free.
Oh my god.
There's the key behind me.
Wait, what?
You guys ready?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh,
he's back.
Do it, do it.
Get that Nemora.
That was so cool.
Wait, stagger, stagger.
Don't kill, don't kill.
Yeah, don't kill her, don't kill her.
Keep her here.
Close the supports.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Nice.
Can we not play?
What are they doing?
We don't have a team that's on the main.
That's actually so...
That's so rough.
I can't believe this is my...
This is my top 500 secure game.
Out of all my games, this is how we end it.
This is how we end it.
Holy fuck.
We have a rocket raccoon and we're against a team that has like four support players.
That's crazy.
What?
What is this luck?
We struggled so hard and then like this is how we...
This is how we end our...
This is how we end our Marvel Rivals break up.
It's gonna be in a video.
We got it and then it's like... Anyway, this was our final game.
We played against a team that had four support players.
Life's great.
Oh shit.
Oh my god!
That was right at my face!
Wait, strangers won.
Oh, that guy was like fuck that raccoon in particular.
Bro,
that guy actually fucking threw it at the entrance.
That's crazy.
I told you!
That's why I'm like...
Why don't you do the exploit?
Wait, what's the skin?
I can't see it.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
Nice.
Wait, what?
Wait, there's a mantis behind his rocket!
Oh my god!
What?
We might be, yeah, just a little bit.
What happened?
I just said I'll do it myself.
Oh god, mantis.
Oh my god.
He fucking soloed me and the rocket.
To be fair, the mantis had like...
The mantis got me low already though, guys.
Come on.
Can't give credit too much to it.
Alright.
Alright, let's give it to Gomez.
You're gonna need it.
Oh my god.
Nice.
No, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
Yeah.
Nice, that was pretty cool.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Live!
Nice.
Don't worry, I'll give it to Gomez.
Bro, I have one hour on tank.
I can't!
Oh my god.
The rest of them are not.
You know what, maybe this game...
Fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
I don't know how I lived that.
Okay, okay.
I saw the whale and I was like, I think I gotta stop.
Oh my god.
They're just walking up to us.
What do we do?
Oh, goodbye.
Unless...
I froze him, I froze him, I froze him.
They just walk up slowly to us.
That was so scary.
He just like walked up to us.
It's over.
It's 11 hours.
Oh my god.
It's like over.
It's actually over.
We're all here.
We're all free.
Oh and I got MVP.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
And I got MVP for it.
You know what, I'll take those.
I can take those.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh my god, I'm at the bottom!
Let's go!
Like always.
Alright guys, as per tradition.
As per tradition.
Where am I?
Alright, there it is.
There I am.
We're here.
Oh my god, do you see that?
Do you see that?
Oh my god, that's me.
That's me.
Oh my god.
That's me right there.
That's me.
Oh my god, we did it.
Thank you for playing through hell.
I'm sorry for the trauma.
It's okay.
I'm used to it.
Roblox was always the answer.
At least...
At least you are now a stronger person.
And you appreciate your team more.
Alright.
The Roblox pregame.
Therapy can't fix what I've Bro, I don't think he's okay.
I don't think he's okay.
Therapy can't fix what I've been through.
Oh my god, cash out the prediction.
Guys, it's time to cash out.
They stuck it through the end.
I broke him, but that's not new.
That's not new guys.
Alright, here's the history.
This is actually crazy.
We started out so rough.
We started out so fucking rough earlier.
Oh my god.
What the fuck.
But like, this is where we started out.
Like, the four losses.
That's where we were at.
And then like...
And then like, we started and it got a lot better.
A lot.
And then this one is when I started playing.
I think this was when... Was it here?
Or here?
It was like one of these.
When I started playing, I did like Roblox pregame.
Like right here.
And then like, just things started looking great.
Like...
We were playing... We did Roblox pregame around this time.
And then we just kept winning.
Oh my god.
Alright.
The chemistry was terrible between me and Kurova.
We had negative chemistry together.
We had negative synergy together.
We just kept double support ulting.
And then I was in my own head about support ults.
So then I just stopped ulting because I was like, what if I double support ult?
And then I stopped ulting.
And then I was like, I'm sorry Kurova.
I'm so sorry.
And then slowly, we didn't need therapy.
We didn't need support counsel therapy.
Like couple counseling therapy.
We just, we did our best to fucking tough it out.
And then we started figuring our synergy.
And things got a lot better.
Things got...
We have like 0 point... We have like 1% synergy now, guys.
We have...
We have 1% synergy now.
I'm proud of us.
I'm so proud of us.
Yes.
Do I deserve an ad now?
Wait, did he ad me?
I don't even know if he ad... Oh, he did.
I didn't know they added me.
I don't check.
People fucking... I don't check.
Yes, you... Yes.
You did it, gamer.
I didn't know I was looking at my history.
I'm not adding Mr. Fister, guys.
This guy gave traumas in my stack.
Literally, they all started beating the shit out of Iron Fist in the practice range.
Him and the other guy, the big MacBook guy.
Why not?
Him, this guy, and... Fuck this.
I'm sorry.
You might be a wonderful person, but you're a Raccoon player.
You could...
You could be a wonderful fucking person.
But we did it, everybody.
We're free.
I swear to God, if the cutoff...
I swear to God, if...
How many days do we have left?
How many days?
Two days.
And if like in three days, if in three days, the cutoff, I swear to God...
Oh my... I swear to God, if in three days, the cutoff is more than two...
Where am I?
268?
Oh my God.
I swear to fucking God, I would freaking freak out.
I...
I will...
Freak out if the cutoff goes higher.
I...
I wanna be free, guys.
I swear, I...
I don't know if I can survive longer.
I don't know.
If in two days, I start worrying...
And he got... He got...
He got like...
Wait, we're almost the same!
I'm just as good as you!
We're like almost the same.
No, I'm not.
They're fucking a lot better than us.
They're so much better than me.
If you need us, call the Avengers.
As a long-time fan, I will answer.
Oh my God, is he a Dragoon?
Prove it.
I shouldn't He helped me get here.
Oh my- I mean, he was the one that stuck it out.
He was the remaining player that stuck out to the end.
He literally stuck out to the end to be there.
To be here.
Everybody else went to bed or crashed out.
Hogs replaced Mace because Mace crashed out.
Mace was having a rough day.
He was having a rough day.
But shoutout to Mace for organizing the stack.
He did not have to.
I literally was like, I don't think I'm gonna make it.
And then he was like, we're gonna get you there.
And then he organized this entire stack.
And then, shoutout to Kurova, Gomez, Hogs, Mace for going through 10 hours of fucking hell.
We went through stream snipers.
We went through, like, 4 stacks trying to get rank 1.
And then, like, trying to farm me for rank 1.
We went through so much.
I got- I went through so much pain.
I'm just a little, like, make-a-wish VTuber.
Trying to get to top 500 for the first time.
And then top 500 for this game.
And then I had, like, 3 different 4 stacks just being like, fuck you.
Oh my god.
Huge shoutout to all the people that played with me.
Booger, Healeth, Surf4r, Ruben, Albert Lele, SlashMac.
Who else played with us?
The Rugsby Chan guy that hopped on.
SK.
Who else?
Shoutout to Tony Flora, the man.
Lau.
Oh my god, Lau climbed so much.
How the fuck?
Look at this guy.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry for exposing you, Lau.
In the morning he was 350.
In the morning he was 300.
I'm sorry, Lau.
What happened?
Oh.
I'm so sorry, buddy.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Alright.
Oh my god.
And shoutout to all the children in Roblox that I beat up to achieve this goal.
We did it, guys.
We're freed.
We did it, everybody.
We fucking did it.
We're free.
We've made it.
It only took us one week of hard grinding.
I can see my family on YouTube again.
Until the cutoff fucks us up.
See you guys in two days when I find out that the cutoff is like 279.
Or 269.
So I'll see you guys in two days if that happens.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Please stream not Marvel for this stream.
GG's.
Get rekt.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Oh yeah, before we go.
It's time to do the prediction.
They did it.
They stuck out.
They stuck out to the end.
Prediction.
How do I do this?
They are in it to the top 500.
Oh my god.
44% of you did not believe.
Guys, look at that.
Look at that.
Let's go, believers.
Let's fucking go.
It's payday.
44% of you are gonna go bankrupt.
But the rest...
You guys got it.
You got the money.
Alrighty.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
We did...
Please follow all the people that helped out.
Exclamation point squad.
To see all the gamers that...
Helped out on the grind.
I will say...
Like I said.
Thanks for coming to this journey.
It was a very fucking long journey.
It was incredibly long.
One week plus of just rivals.
We played so much.
Oh my god.
And it was honestly an incredible...
The last...
I just can't believe that was the last game that got us the secure win.
But anyway, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
You've all been there for so long.
You all stuck out for 11 hours of this.
For the final climb.
Unless we come back in two days.
We'll see.
I'll see what it's going to be like in two days.
But as always, everybody.
If you are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out on YouTube.
If you want more of my content.
If you like my content.
I'm going to try and stream on Twitch at least once a week.
Or once every other week.
Because I want to try and grow my Twitch audience too.
But my main platform is YouTube.
So please check me out on YouTube.
If you want to know when I'm going to go live on Twitch.
Please follow me on Twitter.
Because I usually tweet out when I'm going to be live on Twitter.
So exclamation point Twitter.
Exclamation point YouTube.
Or socials.
You can see where my social media stuff is.
If you want to support me by other means.
I have merch.
Merch and custom PC cases.
I have an Android.
If you're new here and you didn't know about it.
Yeah, I do have an Android.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Let me grab the Nendoroid real quick.
I always have to swap between the two.
Let me grab the Nendoroids for this.
Exclamation point Nendoroid.
It would mean a lot if you pre-order it.
Because it lets me have a chance to get a second Nendoroid.
With my other design.
So yeah.
You have a Nendoroid.
They're planning on restocking it.
Apparently from what I'm told.
But for now, you can get the wall scroll.
The desk mat.
And everything.
The charm.
I do have a Nendoroid.
Exclamation point Nendoroid.
If you want to pre-order my figure.
What else?
I have a gamer subs code.
Doki Bird for 10% off.
And that's everything.
I think that's everything.
I can share.
But yes, please support and follow all the people that played with me.
Exclamation point squad.
They stuck it out for 10 hours.
Especially Gomez.
Who fucking stuck it out all the way to the end.
Like he played 10 hours.
He had to go through 10 hours of my support play.
I was definitely not playing at my best today.
So I really appreciate it.
Especially, you know.
Shout out to Kurova.
Because he's a better support player.
So like, I know that feeling.
Shout out to his mental for getting through 8 hours of that.
Our chemistry was so off.
And like, I don't know.
I felt really bad.
And the fact that when he played with me, Adam was always banned.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that people banned your Adam.
99% of those games.
I'm so sorry.
And shout out to Roblox Squid Game.
For letting me win.
Anyway guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and run around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Also shout out to Mace for getting all this organized.
I'm sorry for...
I'm sorry that you crashed out.
I'm really sorry my games caused that.
I'm really sorry.
He organized the entire stack.
Stuff happened.
Those games were very rough, guys.
Those games were incredibly rough.
Anyway guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and run around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Woah.
Oh, sorry.
He wants walkies now.
Oh, yeah.
But here.
Take a screenshot of this.
Woah.
Look at that.
Sorry.
He wants walkies.
I'll see you guys.
Bye.